>> KARINCHAK IS FUN TO WATCH.
WE WILL TALK WITH BYRON BUXTON.
THE MAIN EVENT, NELSON CRUZ.
BOTH THESE GUYS ARE STAGGERINGLY
BIG HUMAN BEINGS, 265 -- NEARLY
IDENTICAL STRUCK -- SLUGGING
PERCENTAGES IN THE TOP FIVE IN
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING FROM THESE
GUYS?
DAN: THEY ARE GETTING HOT.
NELSON CRUZ HAS HIT HIS CAREERED
AND THEY ARE HAVING A HARD TIME
SCORING RUNS, BUT THAT HAS
CHANGED BECAUSE FRAN MEL IS
STARTING TO CATCH FIRE.
HE'S A BIG, STRONG DUDE AND HE
IS THE GUY EMBRACING THIS
FULL-TIME DH, AND IT IS NOT AN
EASY THING TO DO.
WHAT HE'S BEEN CAPABLE OF DOING
IS GETTING A HANGING BREAKING
BALL FROM KENTA MAEDA AND HITS
IT ABOUT 460 FEET AND THEN GETS
A FASTBALL IN AND BOB'S THIS ONE
TO LEFT CENTER FIELD.
HE HAS AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
BASHER.
HE WILL HIT THE BALL TO ALL
FIELDS AND HE WILL HIT THE BALL
A LIVER THE PLACE.
NELSON CRUZ, KING OF THE AGES.
THE GREATEST NICKNAME IN
BASEBALL, THE BOOM STICK AND HE
KEEPS BOOMING.
HE IS AS GOOD AS HE WAS 10 TO 12
YEARS AGO.
HE LIKE FRAN MEL, POWER.
MAYBE A MORE ACCOMPLISHED HITTER
RIGHT NOW, THE BEST DH IN THE
GAME YOU ARE LOOKING AT, NELLY
CRUZ.
>> THE WAY CRUISE HAS BEEN SO
LONG, THOSE CRUISE MISSILES HAVE
BEEN FUN TO WATCH.
HOW ABOUT J.A. HAPP COMING OFF
HIS BEST AVERAGE.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> HE'S BEEN MUCH BETTER AND HE
NEEDS TO BE.
THE TWINS PITCHING -- HE IS A
UNIQUE GUY AND HE THROWS A LOT
OF FASTBALLS.
I CALL HIM A BACKWARDS LEFTY.
HE WILL THROW THE BALL INTO
RIGHTIES.
YOU WILL SEE A TWO BALL MIX,
PRIMARILY A FASTBALL-SLIDER GUY
BUT WHEN HE IS MOVING THE BALL
TO BOTH SIDES OF THE PLATE, THE
KEY IS TO BE DOWN AND INTO
LEFTIES AND GET THE SLIDER OVER.
IT IS NOT GREAT, IT IS GOOD.
IF HE IS COMMANDING THE
FASTBALL, HAS SLIDER IS BETTER.
HE FINALLY PUT IT ALL TOGETHER.
FOR THE YANKEES.
HE'S PITCHED GOOD BASEBALL FOR
THE TORONTO -- THE PITCHING
STAFF THAT WAS SO GOOD LAST YEAR
HAS NOT BEEN AS GOOD THIS YEAR.
MAEDA HAS STRUGGLED AND THEY
NEED J.A. HAPP TO PICK IT UP.
>> I WORRY ABOUT THE GUY, 38
YEARS.
>> HE LOOKS THE SAME AS HE DID
FIVE YEARS AGO.
>> OUR QUESTION COMING UP
-- WHO WILL WIN TODAY, TWINS OR
INDIANS?
HAPPEN VERSUS LOGAN ALLEN --
HAPP VERSUS LOGAN ALLEN.
TWINS AND INDIANS ARE COMING UP,
AND THAT IS OUR POLL QUESTION.
WHEN WE COME BACK ON THE MELKY
GAME OF THE DUTCH MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK PREGAME WE WILL HAVE
MUCH MORE.
THERE IS A LOOK AT ALAN TRYING
TO BOUNCEBACK.
THEY WON THREE STRAIGHT GAMES
AND YOU WILL HEAR FROM BYRON
BUXTON AND --
♪
>> YOU ARE WATCHING THE MLB GAME
OF THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW
PRESENTED BY GOOGLE PIXEL.
I REMEMBER THE DAY BYRON BUXTON
SINCE I GOT TO CALL THE FUTURES
GAME WITH AARON BOONE AND
EVERYONE SAID, WAIT UNTIL YOU
SEE THIS BYRON BUXTON KID.
WE WILL GET INTO YOUR SPEED AND
JUST THE SECOND, BUT HOW ABOUT
YOUR POWER?
WHERE IS THAT STEMMING FROM?
BYRON: I THINK IT'S JUST A
LITTLE BIT OF EXPERIENCE FROM
PREVIOUS YEARS, AND JUST
TRUSTING MY ABILITY TO TRUST MY
PROCESS.
IT IS TIMES WHERE THINGS DO NOT
GO YOUR WAY THAT YOU TEND TO
SWITCH UP WHAT YOU ARE TRYING TO
GO AND DO, AND FOR ME, I'M JUST
STICKING TO MY APPROACH AND MY
PLAN AND JUST BEING AGGRESSIVE
AND SWINGING AT GOOD PITCHES,
THAT IS THE BIGGEST KEY >>.
THERE ARE A LOT OF SLOGANS IN
BASEBALL, PITCHERS BEST FRIEND
-- A PITCHERS BEST FRIEND IS A
GUY LIKE YOU IN CENTER FIELD.
DO YOU SURVEY CENTER FIELD AND
SAY, THIS IS A PLACE I MIGHT BE
ABLE TO ROB A HOME RUN?
BYRON: I DO.
EVERY NEW -- NEW ROAD TRIP WE GO
ON, I KIND OF GO OUT AND TAKE
THAT FIRST DAY TO GET ACQUAINTED
TO THE FIELD, GO OUT EARLY AND
SEE HOW THE BALL BOUNCES OFF THE
WALL, THE BALL, IF IT SNAKES IN
THE OUTFIELD OR NOT, HOW TRUE IT
IS.
THE LITTLE THINGS IS WHAT I
FOCUS ON COME ON THE FIRST DAY
TO LEARN OR FIGURE OUT IF I NEED
TO TRY TO BREAK OR CUT OFF THIS
BALL A LITTLE BETTER.
SOME FIELDS, THE GRASS MOVES
BETTER THAN -- QUICKER THAN
OTHERS.
YOU WANT TO KNOW THAT TO GET YOU
THE BEST CHANCE.
>> WHICH IS A MUCH TOUGHER PLAY
FOR YOU, THE BALL COMING IN ON
OR THE BALL COMING OVER YOUR
HEAD?
BYRON: FOR ME, IT IS PROBABLY
MORE SO THE BALL I'M COMING IN
ON.
I FIND MYSELF -- WHICH I'M
LOOKING FOR A LITTLE BIT MORE --
BECAUSE I'M RUNNING PRETTY GOOD
TO TRY TO GET THERE.
I HAD IS BOUNCING MORE SO THE
BALL MOVES FOR ME -- MY HEAD IS
BOUNCING MORE SO THE BALL MOVES
FOR ME.
ON THE WAY BACK IS MORE CONTROL
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT A LITTLE MORE
TIME TO READ THE BALL AND LOOK
AROUND TO SEE YOUR SURROUNDINGS.
>> NOT ONLY READ THE BALL, BUT
ALSO YOUR SPEED, 31 FEET PER
SECOND I BELIEVE WAS THE SPRINT
SPEED BUT BOTTOM LINE, YOU ARE
FAST.
YOU OBVIOUSLY INCREASED THAT.
HOW DO YOU MAXIMIZE GETTING THE
BEST OUT OF YOUR SPEED?
BYRON: YOU KNOW, IN THE
OFF-SEASON I GO HOME AND TAKE
ABOUT A MONTH, MONTH AND A HALF
AND DO SPEED TRAINING, NO MONTHS
-- NO WEIGHTS, JUST WORK ON MY
FORM AND TRY TO HELP ME GET THE
EXTRA 90 FEET OR WHATEVER.
OBVIOUSLY, I HAVEN'T STOLEN MANY
BASES BUT IT'S PART OF MY GAME
AND EDIT SOMETHING THAT I WANT
TO INCREASE, TO GET BETTER AT.
I GO BACK HOME WITH MY HIGH
SCHOOL TRACK COACH A LITTLE BIT
AND WE JUST GO THROUGH
TECHNIQUES AND DRILLS.
IT JUST KIND OF WORKS OUT FOR ME
EVERY YEAR.
I SEEM TO GET A LITTLE BIT
FASTER.
>> IT IS A LONG SEASON AND YOU
GUYS HAVE GOTTEN OFF TO A SLOW
START.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT SEPTEMBER
AND OCTOBER THE MINNESOTA TWINS
WILL BE WHERE THEY NEED TO BE?
BYRON: 100%.
OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS BASEBALL.
THINGS HAVEN'T MONTH AWAY WE
WANTED THEM TO BUT THINGS WILL
CHANGE.
ONCE THEY CHANGE, THIS TEAM IS
ELECTRIC.
WE CAN GO ON A WIN STREAK, 15,
20 GAMES, SO WE HAVE TO BE
COMPETITIVE AND DO OUR THING, BE
OURSELVES AND BE COCKY.
WE HAVE TO GET BACK.
>> I LIKE THE COCKINESS.
LEADING OFF TODAY, YOU HIT 30
YESTERDAY.
DO YOU HAVE A PREFERENCE WHERE
YOU BAT IN THE ORDER?
BYRON: NOT REALLY, WITH THE WAY
THAT WE GO.
THEY KIND OF TELL US IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHERE YOU HIT IN THE
LINEUP, JUST BE YOU.
THAT IS SOMETHING I TOOK IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
THEY JUST WANT YOU TO GO IN BE
YOURSELF, DO WHAT BYRON BUXTON
OUGHT TO DO OR NELLY CRUZ OR
WHOEVER THE SITUATION MAY BE,
THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO GO AND DO
TOO MUCH.
THE LINEUP IS ONE THROUGH NINE.
ONE GUY JUST KEEPS THE LINE
MOVING.
>> IS MINNESOTA NICE, A MYTH OR
REALITY?
BYRON: A LITTLE BIT OF BOTH.
I'M FINDING IT MORE OF A
REALITY, I GUESS.
I HEAR THAT QUITE A BIT,
ACTUALLY.
I COULD GO, JUST WRITING TO PICK
UP MY STUFF -- RIDING TO PICK UP
MY STUFF FROM TARGET, MR.
BUXTON, IT IS MINNESOTA DAY.
IT IS A BRUTAL DAY OUTSIDE, JUST
POURING RAIN.
>> IT IS ALWAYS A POSITIVE TO
HAVE A POSITIVE ATTITUDE ABOUT
WHAT THE WEATHER IS LIKE,
WHETHER IT IS BYRON SAXTON OR
BYRON BUXTON.
THANKS FOR THE TIME AND KEEP
CRUSHING IT.
>> YES, SIR, THANK YOU.
>> MLB GAME OF THE WEEK PREGAME
SHOW PRESENTED BY GOOGLE PIXEL.
♪
TIME TO SHINE THE LIGHT ON OUR
CREATOR SPOTLIGHT.
THAT WILL BE ZACH HAMPEL.
HE HAS THE MLB GAME LIVE ON
YOUTUBE AND HE HAS LOTS OF
ADVENTURES AND STADIUMS,
EXPLORES THE NEXT AND CRANNIES
AND EATS CRAZY FOOD, TALKS TO
PLAYERS AND HAS OVER 11,000
BASEBALLS CAUGHT.
ZACH HAMPEL, WHOEVER IS AT THE
PLATE, SEND A HOME RUN IN MY
DIRECTION.
RUNNING US NOW IS ZACH HAMPEL.
IS HE A FRIEND OR A FOE?
FIRST AND FOREMOST, THANK YOU
FOR THE TIME.
THIS OBSESSIVE, CRAZY FAN
JOURNEY, HOW DID IT BEGIN?
ZACH: IT IS GREAT TO BE WITH YOU
GUYS.
I'M DEFINITELY A FRIEND, NOT A
PHONE.
LET'S GET THE RECORD STRAIGHT.
THIS STARTED WHEN I WAS A LITTLE
KID WATCHING BASEBALL ON TV AND
JUST SEEING FANS GETTING
BASEBALLS AND CELEBRATING MY
CRAZY.
THAT LEFT SOME KIND OF
IMPRESSION ON ME AS IT DOES A
LOT OF KIDS, BUT FOR WHATEVER
REASON, I WAS HOOKED.
IT TOOK ME YEARS TO GET MY FIRST
BASEBALL, A TOSSUP.
-- IT WAS ACTUALLY NUMBER 60 FOR
ME.
I'VE BEEN TO TWICE AS MANY
STADIUMS AS THERE ARE TEAMS
BECAUSE WHENEVER MLB PLAYS IN AN
ALTERNATE VENUE, I TRIED TO GO
THERE.
BECAUSE I WAS IN SYDNEY FOR THE
SERIES.
I HAD A WILD TIME AND CAUGHT A
LOT OF BASEBALLS ON THE STADIUM.
ONE OF THE MANY ADVENTURES THE
SEASON ALREADY.
>> WHAT'S YOUR FAVORITE PARK?
I ASSUME IT IS THE ONE YOU
CAUGHT THE MOST BALLS THAT.
WHICH ONE IS THAT?
ZACH: CAMDEN YARDS, BUT I WOULD
GO WITH TIGER STADIUM.
YOU'VE THROWN ME SEVERAL
BASEBALLS OVER THE YEARS,
INCLUDING ONE IN THE UPPER DECK
AND RIGHT FOR TIGER STADIUM IN
1988.
>> MY NEXT QUESTION WAS GOING TO
BE THIS -- YOU'VE GOT SOME --
A-ROD 3000 HIT.
WHEN YOU WANT TO GET A BALL FROM
A GUY LIKE A-ROD, ARE YOU
NERVOUS?
DO YOU HAVE TO BE AT THE RIGHT
PLACE AT THE RIGHT TIME?
DO YOU FIGURE, -- ZACH: YANKEE
STADIUM HAS A SHORT PORCH.
I LOVE SITTING OUT THERE.
HERE I AM, THE OLIVE GREEN
SHIRT, CELEBRATING LIKE A
MADMAN.
A-ROD CAN HIT HIM ANYWHERE, YANK
ONE DOWN THE LEFT-FIELD.
THAT WAS MY STRATEGY FOR HIM I
WAS LOOKING AT CHARTS AND
STADIUM DIAGRAMS, DRIVING MYSELF
CRAZY ABOUT ALL THE BASEBALLS.
JOSH THE METS FOR ALL THE
BASEBALLS LOST.
IT IS AMAZING YOU CAUGHT TROUTS
FIRST AND I BELIEVE YOU HAVE A
CRAZY STORY ABOUT CATCHING IT
BACK FROM HIM.
ZACH: MIKE TROUT HAS BEEN COOL
TO ME SINCE I CAUGHT HIS FIRST
HOME RUN IN BALTIMORE AND GAVE
HIM NOT BASEBALL AFTER THE GAME.
THEY HAD PRETTY NICE CATCH ON
THIS ONE.
YOU CAN SEE ME CLIMBING BACK
WHILE THE BALL IS MIDAIR.
IF YOU LOOK AT THAT REPLAY, YOU
WILL SEE IT.
TROUT'S PARENTS AND FAMILIES
WERE THERE.
I DIDN'T ASK FOR ANYTHING.
I JUST TOLD SECURITY I WANTED TO
HAND IT TO HIM AND I ALWAYS
REGRET IT AS I GOT -- AS HE GOT
BETTER AND BETTER.
I DIDN'T GET ANYTHING FROM HIM,
SO A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO I WAS
LIKE, HEY, MAN, IS IT POSSIBLE
FOR ME TO GET A BAT FROM YOU?
HE WAS LIKE, I GOT YOU.
IT TOOK A WHILE FOR OUR
SCHEDULES TO ALIGN.
HE SAW ME IN TEXAS, GLOBE LIFE
PARK, AND HE SIGNED IT AFTER THE
GAME.
I WAS SO PUMPED UP.
THAT IS ONE OF MY MOST TREASURED
POSSESSIONS IN ALL OF BASEBALL.
HE IS MY FAVORITE PLAYER BY FAR.
IT WAS CAL RIPKEN JR. BUT HE
SURPASSED HIM.
>> DO YOU LOOK AT THE SCHEDULE
AND SAY SOMEBODY IS APPROACHING
A MILESTONE, WGAL CABRERA, WILL
THERE BE A -- MIGUEL CABRERA,
WILL THERE BE A CHASE THAT MAYBE
HE WILL BE SOMEWHERE IN THE
RIGHT PLACE AT THE RIGHT TIME?
ZACH: ABSOLUTELY.
SOMETIMES I WILL BOOK A FLIGHT
TO HIS CITY, OR MAYBE A TEAM IS
USING A COMMEMORATIVE BASEBALL
FOR ONE DAY, RETIRING SOMEBODIES
NUMBER, AND I WANT TO TRY TO GET
ONE, OR BUY SPECIAL TICKETS.
I'VE EVEN BOUGHT TICKETS IN
DIFFERENT SECTIONS FOR ONE GAME
SO I CAN GUARANTEE THAT I CAN
MOVE TO DIFFERENT SPOTS.
I WILL DEFINITELY BE KEEPING AN
EYE ON MIKIE.
IT DEPENDS ON WHICH STADIUM HE
IS LIKELY TO DO IT IN.
IF HE IS THAT .499 AND HE IS
GOING TO A PLACE WHERE THE
OUTFIELD CONFIGURATION IS REALLY
TOUGH, LIKE ANAHEIM WHERE THEY
HAVE THE PENS LEFT -- ENDS IN
LEFT FIELD THAT SWALLOW UP HOME
RUNS.
HE GOES TO RIGHT CENTER TOO.
MAYBE I WON'T BOTHER MAKING THAT
TRIP.
IF THE OUTFIELD IS WIDE OPEN AND
THERE IS A LOT OF SEATS, I MIGHT
MAKE SPECIAL PLANS.
>> YOUTUBE IS A PLACE NOT JUST
FOR BASEBALL BUT ALSO FOR MUSIC.
SPEAKING OF EATING IT, THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU.
THIS HAPPENS TO THE BEST OF US,
NOT A DOUBT ON YOUR AGILITY OR
ATHLETICISM, BUT WHAT HAPPENED?
ZACH: EVEN HALL OF FAMERS TAKE
AN OH-FER SOMETIMES.
I JUST HAD A BAD MOMENT IN
PHILLY.
ALL I CAN DO IS LAUGH AT THIS
POINT.
I JUMPED OVER ROWS OF SEATS
HUNDREDS OF TIMES IN BATTING
PRACTICE WITHOUT INCIDENT.
I TAKE PRIDE ON BEING AGILE AND
ATHLETIC AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED.
ONE TIME I TRIED IT ON TV DURING
A GAME, ABSOLUTELY WIPED OUT,
AND THE DUMBER THING WAS THERE
WAS NO ONE ELSE AROUND FOR
SOCIAL DISTANCING.
I JUST PANICKED AND THOUGHT I
HAD TO GET TO THE FRONT ROW AS
QUICK AS POSSIBLE.
THANKFULLY, I WASN'T HURT, AND
IT IS SUPER EMBARRASSING BUT I'M
GLAD EVERYONE CAN LAUGH ABOUT
IT.
I HAVE A VIDEO ON YOUTUBE
EXPLAINING WHAT WENT DOWN.
WHAT A MESS.
>> YOU ARE ALWAYS VERY
SELF-AWARE.
I LOVE THE PEACE ON H -- PIECE
THEY DID ON HBO.
THEY SAY HE IS A BALL HOG, WHAT
DO YOU SAY TO THOSE CRITICS?
ZACH: I'M DOING WHAT I LOVE AND
I'M NOT HURTING ANYBODY.
I'VE GIVEN AWAY THOUSANDS OF
BASEBALLS.
I'VE RAISED THE COUPLE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS THROUGH MY
COLLECTING EFFORTS PITCHING FOR
BASEBALL AND SOFTBALL, WHICH IS
A CHARITY THAT PROVIDES
EQUIPMENT FOR KIDS AND
COMMUNITIES ALL OVER THE WORLD.
THERE IS A LOT OF HATE TOWARD ME
ONLINE, WHICH IS REALLY UNCALLED
FOR, BUT IN PERSON, IT IS 99.9%
POSITIVE.
I'D SAY AN AVERAGE OF 100 PEOPLE
A DAY COME AT TWO -- UP TO ME AT
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL GAMES AND
WANT SELFIES.
I DO VIDEOS AND I'M A BASEBALL
FAN, BUT PEOPLE GO NUTS FOR THIS
STUFF AND IT IS POSITIVE IN
PERSON.
I DON'T KNOCK PEOPLE DOWN.
THERE IS A LOT FALSE RUMORS.
YOU CAN WATCH ME FOR FIVE
MINUTES OR FIVE YEARS, THAT IS
NOT WHAT I DO.
>> I LOVE THE GOOD VIBES.
JUST IGNORE SOCIAL MEDIA.
JUST POST AND GET OUT OF THE
WAY.
ZACH HAMPEL.
DAN WILL NEVER FORGET THE FACT
THAT HE GAVE THAT BALL.
>> THAT'S IT, ZACH.
IF I COME OUT OF RETIREMENT, I
WILL THROW YOU A BALL AGAIN.
ZACH: I NEED THAT TO HAPPEN.
LET'S DO IT.
>> J.A. HAPP IS LOOKING GOOD.
HIS FASTBALLS, FOUR-SEAMERS, AND
SINKERS ACCOUNT FOR 88.8% OF HIS
PITCHES THIS SEASON.
THE 38-YEAR-OLD CAME IN REAL
SIMPLE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
FASTBALL, FOUR-SEAMERS, AND
SINKERS, AND THE BEST OUTINGS OF
HIS CAREER.
A NO-HITTER FRIDAY AGAINST THE
PIRATES, HAPP, PIRATES-INDIANS
-- TWINS
>> HE'S OUT OF ROOM AND IT'S OUT
OF HERE.
FRIEND MEL, AND THE INDIANS COME
RIGHT BACK AND TAKE THE LEAD.
-- FRANMILL AND THE INDIANS COME
BACK AND TAKE THE LEAD.
HIM AND ROSARIO CATCHING UP A
LITTLE BIT, THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK PREGAME SHOW PRESENTED BY
GOOGLE PIXEL, THE INDIANS AND
TWINS COMING UP LITERALLY
MINUTES AWAY.
PICKS TO CLICK BROUGHT TO YOU BY
BETMGM, DAN PLESAC HAS ALL THE
ANSWERS.
WHO WAS GOING TO WIN THE A.L.
CENTRAL?
TWINS, WHITE SOX?
DAN: WHITE SOX.
LOVE THEIR STARTING ROTATION,
THEIR DEPTH IN THE BULLPEN.
MICHAEL KOPECH HAS BEEN THROWING
THE BALL REALLY WELL.
>> ROYALS .550, A REALLY GOOD
VALUE.
DAN: THEY ARE A WILD-CARD TEAM.
>> TOTAL RUNS SCORED TODAY?
DAN: I WILL SAY NINE OR 10 RUNS,
10 OR ABOVE.
I THINK THE BALL TRAVELS WELL,
OVER NINE.
>> OVER-UNDER AT NINE SO YOU
WILL TAKE THE OVER.
HOW LIKELY TO GO DEEP -- NELLY
CRUZ OUR FRIEND MEL RAYS?
DAN: I WILL GO WITH THE BOOM.
I AM GOING BONE STICK.
>> WE GO FROM THE OFFENSE TO THE
PITCHING, SO J.A. HAPP, OVER OR
UNDER, SPECTACULAR BOARDS
FRIDAY.
DAN: I'M GOING TO GO OVER
BECAUSE SOMETHING TELLS ME HE
WILL BE IN THIS GAME LONG ENOUGH
TO GO SIX OR SEVEN INNINGS.
I SEE FIVE STRIKEOUTS.
>> LOGAN ALLEN, STARTS REALLY
GOOD.
I THINK THEY WILL COME OUT
SWINGING, UNDER.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO THE
CLEVELAND INDIANS, YOU SAY THEY
WILL BE A WALKER TEAM.
IS THIS A .500 TEAM?
I PITCHED FOR 18 SEASONS AND
THERE WERE VERY FEW TEAMS AND
LINEUPS.
WHEN YOU ARE PITCHING YOU ARE
LIKE, I DON'T WANT TO SAY
INTIMIDATED BUT YOUR THOUGHT
PROCESS IS, YOU BETTER BRING
YOUR A GAME.
THAT WAS NOT GOOD.
>> IT'S LIKE THOSE OLD
COMMERCIALS, WHERE'S THE BEEF.
DAN: IN THE BATTER'S BOX.
>> THE MINNESOTA TWINS, THEY ARE
SLOW STARTS BUT SOMETIMES IT
GETS CONCERNING.
IT IS MAY 1.
WE ARE STILL 10 GAMES UNDER .500
WENDY YOU GOT CONCERNED IF YOU
ARE MINNESOTA?
-- WHEN DO YOU GOT CONCERNED?
DAN: I GET CONCERNED RIGHT NOW.
THE RED SOX SIGNED LIAM
HENDRIKS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THOUGHT THE CALL
MAY SIGNING -- THIS GUY DID NOT
ALLOW HOME RUN ALL OF 2020, A 60
GAME SEASON, BUT HE HAS REALLY
STRUGGLED.
THE BULLPEN HAS BEEN BAD.
>> HE WILL NOW BE USED IN LOW
LEVERED SITUATIONS, NOT THE
CLOSER.
.16 E.R.A. DURING THIS LUMP.
WHO WILL WIN, THE TWINS 56%.
PEOPLE ARE FEELING PRETTY GOOD.
THE HALL OF FAMER WITH SCOTT
BRAUN AND TROY HAWKINS, A COUPLE
OF HALL E VOTES.
JON MOROSI AS WELL.
ENJOY THE GAME.
>> HERE'S THE PITCH.
>> DRIVES IT DEEP.
>> WHAT A PLAY.
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
OH, MY!
>> A BURST OF WARMTH AND
CLEVELAND FOR A HOME CROWD THAT
HAS BEEN HIGHLY ENTERTAINED THIS
WEEK, AND ITS FRANCHISES ON
YOUTUBE THAT HAVE THE A.L.
CENTRAL THRONE FOR THE PAST
THREE -- FIVE YEARS.
A DAY GAME OF THE WEEK,
PRESENTED BY GOOGLE PIXEL, WE
ARE IN OHIO.
TO EVERYONE WATCHING WORLDWIDE
ON YOUTUBE.
WE HAVE A MATCHUP OF TWO TEAMS
THAT HAVE TAKEN THE A.L. CENTRAL
AT THE TOP FOR THE LAST FIVE
SEASONS.
CLEVELAND TOOK THREE AND IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS IT HAS BEEN FAVOR
OF MINNESOTA.
THEY ARE OFF TO A 7-15 START AND
THE BULLPEN HAS BEEN A BIG
PROBLEM.
CLEVELAND TRADES AWAY FRANCISCO
LINDOR AND CARLOS CARRASCO, A
.500 BALLCLUB.
WE WILL HAVE OVER 20 GAMES
EXCLUSIVELY ON YOUTUBE THIS
SEASON, EASY TO FIND US,
YOUTUBE.COM/MLB.
JOINING OTHER FANS BY
SUBSCRIBING TO THE MLB.
WE HAVE TWO OF THE NICEST, MOST
DOWN TO EARTH AND DURABLE FORMER
BALLPLAYERS JOINING US TODAY,
LATROY HAWKINS WHO WAS DRAFTED
BY THE TWINS IN 1991, AND THE
HALL OF FAMER JIM THOME WHO
PLAYED FOR CLEVELAND AND
MINNESOTA.
WE ARE VERY MIDWEST FOCUSED, AND
ANOTHER FRIEND JOINING US FROM
THE MIDWEST IN JUST A FEW.
START US OFF ON THIS TWINS TEAM.
LOOKS LIKE ONE OF THE BEST
PLAYERS IN THE LEAGUE AND HOW
DOES HE LOOK TO YOU?
LATROY: WE ARE WITNESSING A STAR
BEING BORN.
HE WAS DRAFTED FOURTH OVERALL,
HAD SOME INJURIES EARLY IN HIS
CAREER, BUT THIS YEAR HE IS
STARTING TO ABSOLUTELY CRUSH THE
BALL WITH AN OPS OF .12 70'S --
1.276.
HE IS USING ALL PARTS OF THE
FIELD AND ONCE HE UNDERSTOOD
THAT, WE ARE SEEING HIM BLOSSOM
AT THE PLATE.
OTHER HAND, HAS TO STAY HEALTHY,
BYRON BUXTON HAS TO STAY HEALTHY
.
WHERE BYRON BUXTON GOES, THE
MINNESOTA TWINS GO.
EIGHT OF HIS HARDEST HIT HOME
RUNS, FIVE HAD BEEN HIT THIS
YEAR.
WE ARE MEASURING HARD CONTACT.
HARD CONTACT, HOW OFTEN YOU CAN
BARREL THE BALL.
THAT'S THE TWINS MOTTO OF
HITTING, FIND YOU A GOOD PITCH
THAT YOU CAN PUT A GOOD SWING ON
AND HIT IT HARD.
SCOTT: THAT WAS STATCAST 3D
POWERED BY GOOGLE CLOUD.
SHOWING US WHAT BYRON BUXTON
BRINGS TO THE TABLE, AND EVEN IF
YOU ARE UNAWARE OF HOW THESE
STATISTICS ARE FORMULATED, BRUTE
STRENGTH, HITTING A BASEBALL
HARD, BYRON BUXTON IS AT THE TOP
OF THE CLASS IN ALL OF THE
CATEGORIES THAT STATCAST HELPS
US WITH, TO MEASURE THE WORK HE
DOES WHEN HE IS HEALTHY AND ON
THE FIELD.
HE WILL BE LEADING OFF FOR THE
MINNESOTA TWINS.
WE HAVE A CLEVELAND SQUAD GOING
FOR ACE'S -- GOING FOR A SWEEP
AND JOSÉ RAMIREZ HAS DEVELOPED
INTO A SUPERSTAR AND IS
REGULARLY PART OF THE M.V.P.
CONVERSATION.
WHAT DO YOU LIKE ABOUT HIM?
JIM: I LOVE EVERYTHING ABOUT HIM
.
FIRST OF ALL, I LOVE WHERE HE
STANDS ON HOME PLATE, CLOSE TO
THE PLATE.
HE'S GOT GREAT PLATE COVERAGE.
WHERE CLEVELAND GOES, HE GOES.
RAMIREZ, THE LAST FOUR SEASONS
HAS FINISHED IN THE TOP THREE
M.V.P. VOTING THREE TIMES.
YES, COUNT THEM, THREE TIMES.
WHERE CLEVELAND GOES, HE
DEFINITELY GOES.
LOOK AT THIS YEAR, WINS,
CLEVELAND HAS 11.
HE'S GOT SEVEN RUNS AND 11 ARE
-- SEVEN ARE -- 11 RUNS AND
SEVEN RBIS.
FRANCONA, BEFORE THE GAME, SAID
THIS GUY IS A FORCE BEHIND THE
LINEUP.
I KNOW THE CLEVELAND FANS LOVE
THIS KID AND HE'S IMPROVED EVERY
YEAR, THAT HE SO MUCH FUN TO
WATCH.
SCOTT: HE MESORACO AND IF YOU --
HE IS A AND IF YOU COMBINE HIM
WITH FRANMIL REYES -- WE HAVE
ANOTHER FRIEND STATIONED IN
CLEVELAND, OHIO.
LET'S SAY HELLO TO J.P. MOROSI
WITH MORE ON THE HOME TEAM.
J.P.: GOOD AFTERNOON, WHERE IT
WAS JUST FIVE YEARS AGO THAT ONE
OF THE GREATEST WORLD SERIES WE
EVER WITNESSED HAPPENED AT
PROGRESSIVE FIELD, BUT THE
INSTITUTIONAL MEMORY ON THE
CLEVELAND SIDE HAS BEGUN TO
FADE.
JUST THREE PLAYERS ON THE ROSTER
TODAY WHO APPEARED AND THAT 2016
FALL CLASSIC, ONE OF WHOM, JOSÉ
RAMIREZ, IS IN THE LINEUP TODAY.
BARDO PEREZ HAS THE DAY OFF
BEHIND THE PLATE AND BRYAN SHAW
IN THE BULLPEN HAS ALREADY
PLAYED FOR TWO TEAM SINCE THE
END OF THE 2016 WORLD SERIES.
CLEVELAND INDIANS, ONE ROSTER
MOVE TODAY.
NICK WITTGREN REJOINS THE
BULLPEN, TAKING THE PLACE OF
OLIVER PEREZ AFTER A LONG TENURE
IN CLEVELAND.
HE HAS 696 APPEARANCES IN MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL GAMES AS A
PITCHER, SECOND ONLY TO JOAKIM
SORIA, AMONG MEXICAN BORN
PITCHERS IN HISTORY.
THE HERO OF LAST NIGHT'S GAME
WAS FRANMIL REYES WHO GREW UP IN
THE DOMINICA -- DOMINICAN
REPUBLIC ITEMIZING VLAD GUERRERO
SR..
PERHAPS HE TOOK UP PLAY FROM
DUST TOOK A PLAY FROM HIS BOOK.
FRANMIL REYES BACK IN THE
STARTING LINEUP FOR THE INDIANS
THIS AFTERNOON IN SUPPORT OF
JOSÉ RAMIREZ, THE LONGTIME
CLEVELAND INDIANS STAR.
SCOTT: JP , THEYF CALL
HIMRANIMAL FRAN
IMAL FOR A REASON.
BROUGHT TO YOU BY GOOGLE PIXEL,
STARTS IN MOMENT.
>> A GAP IN RIGHT FIELD, BUXTON
ON THE FIRST PITCH, THE FIRST
AND SECOND WITH TWO DOWN AND
THAT WILL BRING UP MCCUTCHEN.
BUXTON DROPS ONE INTO THE
CORNER, A FAIR BALL.
HE WILL GO INTO SECOND WITH A
DOUBLE.
NOW A BLAST TO LEFT CENTER
FIELD, BUXTON, A DIVE AND CATCH
IN CENTER.
WHAT A CATCH BY BYRON BUXTON,
PRESERVING THE LEAD, A
TREMENDOUS CATCH BY BUXTON TO
KEEP THE TWINS OFF 10 TONIGHT.
>> A PITCH AND A FLY BALL, BACK
IT GOES, DEEP IT GOES, AND IT IS
GONE.
WHAT IS GOOD IS NOW EVEN BETTER,
A TENT INNING, TWO RUN BLACKS --
10 INNING, TWO RUN BLAST.
>> HOW MUCH MORE CAN HE DO IN
ONE BASEBALL GAME?
LEFT CENTER FIELD, BUXTON DIVES
AND MAKES ANOTHER TREMENDOUS
CATCH.
>> WARMER WEATHER IN CLEVELAND,
OHIO, THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
ON YOUTUBE IS BROUGHT TO YOU BY
GOOGLE PIXEL AND HOPEFULLY THE
RAIN HOLDS OFF TODAY.
THE TWINS AND THE INDIANS
FINISHING UP THEIR THREE GAME
SERIES AND FOR MINNESOTA, THIS
IS NOT THE START THAT THEY
EXPECTED STUMBLING OUT OF THE
GATE, SEVEN WINS, 15 LOSSES.
ROCCO BALDELLI AND HIS SQUAD
WHICH HE LEADS FOR THE THIRD
CONSECUTIVE SEASON, STILL THE
YOUNGEST MANAGER IN MLB BASEBALL
AND YOUNGER THAN ONE OF HIS STAR
BATS, NELSON CRUZ.
TROY, THE LAST 15 GAMES HAVE
PRODUCED JUST TWO WINS AND ROCCO
BALDELLI TALKED TO THE TEAM
YESTERDAY, IT IS LIKE THE GUTS
ARE BEING RIPPED OUT OF US.
THE BULLPEN IS HAVING STRUGGLES.
WHAT HAVE YOU OBSERVED?
LATROY: JUST THE LATE INNING
DRAMA, LACK OF OFFENSE, AND THE
BULLPEN WAS BUILT TO BE A LOT
BETTER THAN WHAT THEY ARE.
THEY HAVE DEFINITELY STRUGGLED,
A LOT OF ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT.
YOU CAN SEE LATE INNING GAMES,
WE HAD MANY OF THOSE, FOUR
WALK-OFFS.
THEY'VE LOST FOUR GAMES IN SEVEN
INNING DOUBLE-HEADERS.
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO MAKE THE
PITCHES WHEN THEY'VE NEEDED TO.
SCOTT: MINNESOTA 4-8 ON THE
ROAD.
YOU ADD IT ALL UP, AT THE BOTTOM
OF THE DIVISION.
IT IS ONLY APRIL, BUT STILL ONLY
EIGHT WINS AND -- SEVEN WINS AND
15 LOSSES.
THE INDIANS CHECK IN AT 11-11 ON
THE YEAR.
BYRON BUXTON BACK IN THE LINEUP
YESTERDAY WITH A BANG, OF
COURSE, HIS SEVENTH HOME RUN OF
THE SEASON, AND HE LEADS MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL WITH AN OUT OF
THIS WORLD .847 SLUGGING
PERCENTAGE.
JOSH DONALDSON SECOND, NELSON
CRUZ DOWN TO THE THREE WHOLE.
JORGE POLANCO.
MITCH HARPER LOVES LEFT-HANDED
PITCHING.
MITCH GARVER.
SIMMONS BACK ON MONDAY FROM THE
COVID INJURED LIST, AND ALEX
KIRILLOFF GETS THE START EVEN
THOUGH HE IS A LEFTY, AGAINST
THIS SOUTHPAW, LOGAN ALLEN ON
THE MOUND.
HE HAS HAD TWO UP IN TWO DOWN,
INCLUDING A BAD MATCH UP WITH
THE YANKEES, JUST FOUR RUNS
ALLOWED, SEVEN OUTS RECORDED.
HE HAS A .628 E.R.A..
-- 6.28 E.R.A.
THIS IS A YOUNG MAN FINDING
HIMSELF AND THEY ARE PREACHING
CONSISTENCY AND THE
AGGRESSIVENESS THEY SAW FROM HIM
IN SPRING TRAINING THEY HOPE TO
SEE SLIP INTO THE REGULAR
SEASON.
LATROY: YES, HE HAS TO CONTROL
HIS EMOTIONS AND THERE ARE THREE
KEYS TO THE GAME -- FOUR-SEAM
EFFECTIVENESS, USING HIS HIGH
FASTBALL, KEEPING RIGHT-HANDED
BATTERS -- HITTERS HONEST,
PITCHING INSIDE ON A CASE TO
CASE BASIS, AND EXECUTE.
THEY'VE HAD A GREAT GAME PLAN
AND HE FOR CAN CONTINUE THAT AND
FOLLOW THE PLAN, HE WILL HAVE A
GREAT DAY.
SCOTT: YOUR GOOGLE PIXEL
DEFENSIVE LINEMAN FOR THE
CLEVELAND INDIANS, AUSTIN HEDGES
GETS TODAY FROM ROBERTO PEREZ
WHO CAUGHT LAST NIGHT AND WILL
PLAY CATCH WITH LOGAN ALLEN.
YU CHANG ON FIRST, HERNANDEZ ON
SECOND.
ROSARIO AND RAMIREZ FROM LEFT TO
RIGHT.
WE ARE READY TO GO AT
PROGRESSIVE FIELD, BYRON BUXTON
LEADING THE WAY FOR MINNESOTA,
TWINS TEAM THAT IS DESPERATELY
LOOKING FOR A W TO SALVAGE A
GAME IN THE SERIES.
A WORLDWIDE AUDIENCE WATCHING ON
YOUTUBE.
FIRST PITCH ON ITS WAY FROM
LOGAN ALLEN, IT IS TAKEN UP AND
AWAY.
TIME FOR THE MOST HOME RUNS IN
THE AMERICAN LEAGUE -- TIED FOR
THE MOST HOME RUNS IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE, AT SEVEN.
THE ONLY THING THAT CAN HOLD HIM
BACK IS THE INFIRMARY, STRAIN
HAMSTRING EARLIER THIS MONTH.
JOSH NAYLOR FADING BACK, AND
IT'S GONE.
SECOND PITCH OF THE GAME, BYRON
BUXTON MUSCLES UP, HIS EIGHTH
HOME RUN OF THE SEASON, AND THE
TWINS GRAB A 1-0 LEAD.
IT IS EASY POWER, JIM THOME.
JIM: THIS GUY IS ON A ROLL.
YOU KNOW, THAT BALL ACTUALLY GOT
A LITTLE BIT DEEP ON HIM AND
WHERE HE IS AT, WHERE HE STANDS
IN THE BOX, WHAT A GREAT SWING.
TO STAY BACK, LATROY, AND USE
YOUR HANDS LIKE THAT AND KNOW
YOU CAN SHOOT THE BALL TO RIGHT
FIELD IS SO IMPRESSIVE.
LATROY: THAT ARE STANDING, AND
YOU KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THAT IS,
USING THE ENTIRE FIELD TO
CONTINUE TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
SCOTT: THIRD CAREER LEADOFF HOME
RUN FOR BUXTON, AND THAT BRINGS
US TO DONALDSON, WHO HAS
RECORDED 11 HITS THIS SEASON.
OVER .300, WAS ON THE INJURED
LIST WITH A HAMSTRING STRAIN.
SAME WITH DONALDSON, KEEP HIM ON
THE FIELD, 35 YEARS OLD, AND THE
TWINS LINEUP WILL DO A LOT MORE
DAMAGE.
JIM: YES, THEY WILL.
SCOTT: YOU PLAYED WITH DONALDSON
IN HIS TORONTO DAYS.
LATROY: I HANDED HIM HIS M.V.P.
TROPHY FOR THAT SEASON.
JIM: HOW DID YOU PICK UP THAT
JOB?
LATROY: SOMEBODY IN NEW YORK
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE COOL TO HAND
HIM HIS AWARD.
LOGAN ALLEN, LEFTY.
DONALDSON, HE'S JUST -- HE'S ON
100 ALL DAY LONG.
HIS ENERGY LEVEL IS SO HIGH IN
THE CLUBHOUSE AND HE'S GOING TO
CHALLENGE HIS TEAMMATES TO BE
BETTER THAN THEY WERE THE DAY
BEFORE.
DONALDSON WILL SAY, YOU NEED TO
BE BETTER THAN YESTERDAY.
JIM: SO GUYS, WHAT IS
INTERESTING, HE'S GOT TWO
STRIKES ON HIM AND HE KIND OF
WENT TO THE NO STRIDE, WHICH
I'VE NOT SEEN DONALDSON DO THIS.
LET'S WATCH THE REMAINING OF
THIS AT-BAT AND SEE IF HE
FLATFOOT'S WITH HIS FRONT FOOT
AND KEEPS IT DOWN.
NOW HE TAPPED IT, BUT HE SUCH A
GREAT HITTER, IT'S FUN TO WATCH
THIS KID BECAUSE WHEN HE GETS
REALLY HOT, HE CAN CARRY A
BALLCLUB.
LATROY: YEAH, HE'S THAT TYPE OF
PLAYER.
YOU GET ON HIS BACK AND HE WILL
DRIVE THE BUS.
WHAT IS GREAT ABOUT HIM, HE CAN
HIT THE FASTBALL.
I'VE SEEN HIM ON TOP OF MORE
FASTBALLS, UNBELIEVABLE.
SCOTT: THAT ONE TWISTS FOUL.
LOGAN ALLEN USES THE FASTBALL,
THE FOUR-SEAMER ABOUT HALF THE
TIME.
THE STRIKEOUT PITCH THAT HAS
EMERGED AS THE SLIDER.
HE SAID IT HAS COME A LONG WAY
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS.
DONALDSON CLOCKS THAT ONE TO
DEEP LEFT.
FORGET ABOUT IT.
THE TWINS GO BACK TO BACK TO
START THE GAME.
JOSH DONALDSON RECORDS HIS
SECOND HOME RUN OF THE SEASON,
AND IT IS 2-0 MINNESOTA.
JIM: THEY ARE NOT MESSING AROUND
HERE.
THEY ARE COMING OUT READY TO
HIT.
THIS IS A REALLY, REALLY GOOD
OFFENSE.
THE TWINS, WHEN THEY START
SCORING RUNS, THEY ARE A
DANGEROUS TEAM FOR SURE.
LATROY: THEY DEFINITELY HAVE
STRUGGLES ON THE OFFENSIVE PART
OF THE GAME, WHEN YOU HANG
CHANGEUPS LIKE THAT, THAT'S AN
ELEVATED CHANGEUP, THAT'S RIGHT
IN HIS WHEELHOUSE.
HE STAYS BACK ON THE BALL BETTER
THAN SOME OF THE BEST IN THE
GAME.
GOOD RESULTS IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
SCOTT: IT DOESN'T GET ANY EASIER
WITH THE 40-YEAR-OLD NELSON CRUZ
TAKING A BREAKING BALL FOR A
STRIKE.
LATROY, BOMBA SQUAD WAS THE NICK
NAME THAT EMERGED IN 2019.
WE ARE SEEING SHADES OF THAT IN
THIS FIRST INNING AGAINST LOGAN
ALLEN.
LATROY: THEY DEFINITELY NEED
THAT SAME TYPE OF SWAGGER FROM
BOMBA SQUAD 2019 TO GET THE
SEASON TURNED BACK AROUND.
SCOTT: LOGAN ALLEN HAS GIVEN UP
FIVE HOME RUNS TO THE LAST 10
BATTERS HE'S FACED.
THAT GOES BACK TO HIS START
AGAINST THE YANKEES.
LATROY: WE TALKED ABOUT LOGAN
ALLEN -- FRANCONA TALKED ABOUT
IN THE INTERVIEW, SAYING HE HAS
TO KEEP HIS EMOTIONS IN CHECK.
THIS IS A PRIME EXAMPLE OF, YOU
GAVE UP TWO HOME RUNS.
YOU CAN CONTROL YOUR NERVES AND
MAKE GOOD PITCHES AND GET YOUR
TEAM IN TO GET A CHANCE TO HIT
AS WELL.
SCOTT: 424 -- 423 FEET OF GLORY
FOR DONALDSON.
THERE'S THE TAGTEAM, BROTHERS SO
FAR -- BASH BROTHERS SO FAR
TODAY.
PAYOFF TO CREWS  --CRUZ, BALL
FOUR.
NELSON CRUZ IS MIKED UP ALONG
WITH SHANE BIEBER.
NELSON: YOUR FACE!
ALL DAY!
SCOTT: HE STOLE YOU ARE LINE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU USE TO'S -- YOUR
LINE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU USED TO SAY,
RIGHT?
JIM: THERE WERE DAYS WE SAID
THAT, GOT THE BOYS GOING.
WHAT I LOVE ABOUT NELSON CRUZ IS
HIS ENERGY.
THIS GUY COMES TO THE BALLPARK
EVERY DAY READY TO GO, AND IT IS
REFRESHING.
A GUY LIKE THAT CAN RUB OFF ON
THESE YOUNG GUYS.
WHAT A GREAT LEADER HE IS TO
THAT BALLCLUB.
LATROY: THROUGHOUT THE GAME, YOU
CAN HEAR NELSON SCREAMING, GOOD,
BAD, DOESN'T KNOW -- DOESN'T
MATTER WHAT'S GOING ON.
YOU CAN ALWAYS HEAR HIM.
HE IS THE CALMING VOICE FOR
THOSE GUYS ON THE TEAM.
SCOTT: AS THEY CHAT WITH LOGAN
ALLEN, LET'S GET TO THE GOOGLE
PIXEL PITCHING BREAKDOWN.
IT'S BEEN A ROCKY START FOR
ROGAN ALLEN -- LOGAN ALLEN, BUT
HOW CAN HE PICK THINGS UP?
LATROY: THE FOUR-SEAM
EFFECTIVENESS, THROWING THE BALL
OVER THE PLATE, ELEVATING THE
FASTBALL, BECAUSE IT IS PROVEN
HE CAN GET SOME SWING AND MISSES
ABOVE THE STRIKE ZONE, KEEP
THOSE RIGHTIES HONEST.
ALREADY HAS TWO HOME RUNS BY
RIGHT-HANDED HITTERS BUT THOSE
HAVE BEEN ON STEAK FASTBALLS.
FOLLOW THE GAME PLAN.
THEY HAD A GREAT GAME PLAN THAT
WAS EFFECTIVE AND HE CAN FOLLOW
THAT COME HE CAN HAVE A GREAT
DAY.
SCOTT: HE MISSES AGAIN TO
POLANCO.
THE TWINS SECOND BASEMAN BACK IN
THE LINEUP AFTER A DAY OFF
YESTERDAY.
HE IS WON FOR HIS LAST 12.
-- HE IS ONE FOR HIS LAST 12.
ALLEN FINDS THE CORNER.
BY THE WAY --
JIM: SCOTTY, ANOTHER REALLY,
REALLY GOOD PLAYER HERE.
THIS KID, WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
ENERGY AND WHAT HE DOES UP THE
MIDDLE, HE'S JUST A DYNAMIC TYPE
PLAYER -- THERE YOU GO.
SCOTT: HE TEES OFF AND JORGE
POLANCO MAKES IT THREE HOME RUNS
IN THE FIRST FOR THE TWINS, A
BURST OF ENERGY FROM THIS TWINS
OFFENSE.
4-0.
LATROY: TALK ABOUT PITCHERS
HAVING TO PITCH AHEAD IN THE
COUNT AND STAY OUT OF HITTER'S
COUNTS, 3-0, 3-1 COUNTS.
YOU GIVE THE HITTERS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SOME DAMAGE
LIKE POLANCO ON THIS 3-1
FASTBALL.
SCOTT: BEAUTIFUL SWING.
THAT'S A DEJECTED LOOK FROM
LOGAN ALLEN WHO HAS GIVEN UP
SEVEN HOME RUNS TO THE LAST 12
BATTERS HE HAS FACED.
THAT WRAPS AROUND FROM HIS LAST
START.
IT IS BUXTON, DONALDSON, POLANCO
IN THE FIRST, NO OUTS RECORDED.
FOR A TWINS TEAM, IT WAS SLOW
HEADING INTO TODAY.
THEY HAD LOST 13-15 AND ALREADY
ACTION IN THE BULLPEN FOR
CLEVELAND.
HOW DO YOU HANDLE A SITUATION
LIKE THIS WITH LOGAN ALLEN?
LATROY: YOU SEE WHERE CARL
WILLIS WENT OUT TO TALK TO HIM.
THIS IS A SITUATION WHERE YOU
HAVE TO CONTROL YOUR EMOTIONS,
TAKE A STEP BACK BEHIND THE
MOUND, GATHER YOUR THOUGHTS, AND
GO BACK AND MAKE PITCHES.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE PITCH IS GET
AHEAD IN THE COUNT.
SCOTT: MITCH GARVER FEASTS ON
LEFT-HANDED HITTERS, 30 PLUS
HOME RUNS A COUPLE SEASONS AGO.
HASN'T LOOKED THE SAME IN LAST
YEAR AND 2021, WE TALKED TO
ROCCO BALDELLI ABOUT IT THIS
MORNING.
HE SAID, JUST GET BACK TO THE
BASICS.
THEY LIKE TO SEE HIM DRIVE THE
BASEBALL TO ALL FIELDS.
HE WAS A HITTER IN THE MINOR
LEAGUES AND THE POWER EXPLODED
IN 2019.
LATROY: ALEX -- THE LAST TWO
PITCHES --
JIM: SCOTTY, WHENEVER YOU GET --
SCOTT: ALLEN'S 2-0 TAKING ON THE
OUTSIDE CORNER.
GO AHEAD, JIM.
JIM: THE BIG THING TOO, IS WHEN
YOU CAN GET OUT OF APRIL IS A
PLAY, YOU ARE DEALING WITH COLD
WEATHER AND FINDING YOUR GROOVE
AND GETTING SETTLED IN.
I'VE PERSONALLY HAD SOME REALLY
BAD APRIL'S.
I THINK WHEN YOU GET BACK ON THE
FASTBALL AND STAY ON THE
FASTBALL, THEN EVERYTHING KIND
OF FLOWS IN YOUR AT-BATS.
WHEN YOU ARE TRYING TO COVER A
BREAKING BALL, CHANGEUP, AND THE
FASTBALL, AT-BATS CAN GO IN A
REAL HURRY.
ONE OF THE THINGS I THINK WITH
GARVER, HE'S GOT SO MUCH POWER
EVERYWHERE THAT EVENTUALLY, THIS
KID IS GOING TO PUT UP THE
NUMBERS THAT HE HAS.
I REALLY LIKE HOW AGGRESSIVE HE
IS AT HOME PLATE.
LATROY: SO THOME, WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT STAYING ON THE
FASTBALL, IN TODAY'S GAME, HE IS
GETTING 50/50 AND THEY CANNOT
ADJUST TO THE SLIDERS SO HE
THROWS ALL BREAKING BALLS.
WHAT IS THE MINDSET?
HOW DO YOU CORRECT THAT?
JIM: GREAT QUESTION, LATROY.
FIRST OF ALL, YOU HAVE TO KNOW,
AM I GETTING MORE FASTBALLS THAN
BREAKING BALLS?
IF THEY ARE THROWING MORE
BREAKING BALLS THAN THEY ARE
FASTBALLS TO HIM, THEN THERE'S A
COUPLE THINGS.
I THINK YOU HAVE TO MOVE UP IN
THE BOX AND THEN IT MIGHT BE
TIME TO GO AHEAD AND SIT ON
BREAKING BALLS IF HE IS GETTING
A TON OF THEM.
BUT UNTIL THEN, HOW GUYS REALLY
GET OUT OF THEIR SLUMP IS WHEN
YOU DO GET THOSE FASTBALLS, NOT
TO MISS THEM.
AND IF YOU MISS THEM, THEN THE
AT-BATS GO REALLY QUICK AND YOU
STRUGGLE EARLY.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS.
SCOTT: SO ALLEN PUTS AWAY
GARVER, FIRST OUT RECORDED IN
THIS GAME BY THE CLEVELAND
STARTER, AND NOW IT IS BRENT
ROOKER.
ROOKER HOMERED ON MONDAY, FIRST
OF THE SEASON, SECOND OF HIS
CAREER.
LATROY: ROOKER HAS THE POWER TO
HIT THE BALL A VERY LONG WAY.
HE'S A VERY STRONG YOUNG MAN.
SCOTT: WHAT ARE YOU SEEING FROM
ALLEN --
LATROY: I HAVEN'T SEEN FROM
LOGAN TODAY.
BUT FASTBALL, ON RIGHT HAND
HITTERS, YOU HAVE TO KEEP THEM
HONEST.
IF YOU ARE GIVING THEM HARDER
OVER THE PLATE, YOU WILL NOT BE
OUT THERE LONG.
HAVE TO LET THEM KNOW YOU ARE
NOT AFRAID TO TAKE ONE HALF OF
THE PLATE AND RUNNING THAT
FASTBALL IN ON THE HANDS OR
SLOWING -- THROWING THE SLIDER
UP UNDER THEIR HANDS.
SCOTT: YOU CAN SEE THE CLEVELAND
INDIANS HAVE RECEIVED THE FEWEST
STARTS FROM SOUTHPAWS THE START
OF 2018.
THEY'RE HOPING LOGAN ALLEN CAN
FILL THE VOID, HIS 3-2 IS HIT
HARD.
DEEP LEFT FIELD OFF THE BAT OF
ROOKER AND THAT IS CAUGHT IN THE
CORNER.
EDDIE ROSARIO MAKES THE CATCH
AND THERE ARE TWO GONE.
ABOUT 318 FEET, AND ROSARIO WAS
THERE.
NOW WILLIANS ASTUDILLO.
THIS IS JUST A COMPLETE
TURNAROUND FROM YESTERDAY, JIM.
THIS TWINS TEAM COULD BARELY GET
THE BALL OUT OF THE INFIELD,
GROUND BALL AGAINST GROUNDBALL
AGAINST CLEVELAND STARTER AARON
CIVALE.
NOW WE ARE SEEING LOUD CONTACT
DEEP INTO THE DAY.
AGAINST LOGAN ALLEN SO FAR
TODAY.
JIM: YOU SURE HAVE.
I THINK THAT WAS ONE THING A
YEAR AGO WHEN HE LOOKED AT THE
TWINS, IS THE MINUTE THEY DUG
THEIR BACK FOOT INTO THE BOX,
THEY WERE READY TO HIT.
THEY REALLY -- THEY WERE
AGGRESSIVE ON EVERYTHING AND
I'VE ALWAYS ADMIRED THAT.
I LOVE THAT ABOUT MINNESOTA'S
TEAM, IS THEY COME OUT OF THE
DUGOUT READY TO HIT AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT YOU ARE SEEING
TODAY.
SCOTT: ASTUDILLO GOING THE
OTHER WAY AND THAT IS CAUGHT.
JOSH NAYLOR REELS IN AN.
THE TWINS DO DAMAGE.
THEY SET THE RECORD FOR HOME
RUNS IN 2019.
SHADES OF BOMBA SQUAD AGAIN.
BUXTON, DONALDSON, AND POLANCO,
BOTTOM OF THE FIRST, COMING UP.
>>>> HAMMERED, DEEP LEFT CENTER
FIELD AND IT WILL ONE HOP THE
FENCE.
BACKING IT UP IS GARVER, FRANMIL
AROUND SECOND, HE WILL GO FOR
THREE.
THE BIG MAN GOES IN SAFE.
A TRIPLE.
HAMMERED, DEEP LEFT FIELD AND IT
IS OVER THE HEAD OF CLINT
FRAZIER.
COMING HOME AND SCORING IS CESAR
HERNANDEZ.
RAMIREZ.
AT THIRD.
INTO SECOND WITH AN R.B.I.
DOUBLE IS FRANMIL REYES.
THE INDIANS TAKE A 1-0 LEAD.
>> THE RUNNER GOES AND SANCHEZ
DROPPED THE BALL.
>> LOOK AT THE BIG MAN GO.
LOU BROCK, THERE HE GOES.
GET IN THERE WITH A STOLEN BASE,
WHY NOT?
>> HIGH FLY BALL RIGHT FIELD,
JUDGE IS BACK, IT IS OUT OF
HERE.
>> FRANMIL BLAST OFF, DEEP
CENTER FIELD AND IT IS OFF THE
WALL, IT TOOK A CRAZY CAROM.
IT WILL NOT BE IN TIME.
HIS SECOND TRIPLE OF THE SERIES.
SCOTT: FOUR FOR THE TWINS AFTER
HALF AN INNING.
THE CLEVELAND HOME SQUAD, CESAR
HERNANDEZ WILL LEAD THINGS OFF,
JORDAN LUPLOW LEG AGAINST
LEFTIES AND RIGHTIES THIS
SEASON.
THE GREAT JOSE RAMIREZ, FOUR
HOME RUNS AT EIGHT R.B.I. DURING
THE 11 GAME ON BASE STREET --
STREET.
EDDIE ROSARIO MATCHING UP
AGAINST HIS FORMER TEAM.
AMED ROSARIO AT SHORT.
NAYLOR, CHAIN, AND HEDGES ROUND
OUT THE NINE.
J.A. HAPP ON THE MOUND.
HE'S COMING OFF ONE OF THE BEST
ARTS OF HIS CAREER.
HE WAS FIVE OUTS AWAY FROM NO
HITTING PITTSBURGH IN HIS THIRD
START ON FRIDAY.
LATROY: HE HAD A GREAT START,
HAD EVERYTHING WORKING.
HIS FASTBALL WAS PERFECTLY PAID
-- PLACED.
USING HIS BREAKING BALL, MIXING
AND THE CHANGEUP.
HOPEFULLY HE COULD HAVE SOME
CARRYOVER TO TODAY AGAINST A
CLEVELAND BALLCLUB.
SCOTT: CAREER ON-BASE PERCENTAGE
FOR CESAR HERNANDEZ AROUND 35%
OF THE TIME HE IS REACHING BASE.
HE WILL WORK AN AT-BAT, THAT IS
3-1, THE COUNT TO START THE DAY.
J.A. HAPP WANTS TO KNOW WHERE
THAT WAS.
HOW DO YOU STRATEGIZE AGAINST
J.A. HAPP, WHO JUST BRINGS THE
SAME CONSISTENCY FOR YEARS NOW
ONCE HE TRANSFORMS HIMSELF WITH
THE PITTSBURGH PIRATES BACK IN
THE 2015-2016 RANGE.
HE FIGURED OUT FASTBALLS ARE MY
THING, FOUR SEAMERS UP, SINKERS
DOWN.
THERE'S ONE TO THE SHORTSTOP
SIMMONS, EASY COST OF FIRST, ONE
AWAY.
JIM: IT IS LIKE WE TALKED, YOU
HAVE TO BE READY TO HIT.
THIS IS A GUY THAT WILL ATTACK
WITH HIS FASTBALL.
YOU DON'T WANT TO GET BEHIND ON
THIS GUY.
WHEN YOU GET THE OPPORTUNITY.
WHEN YOU GET AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SCORE, I FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE TO
DO IT.
IF YOU GET SETTLED IN, AS WE
HAVE SEEN IN HIS LAST START, HE
COULD REALLY GET LOCKED IN AND
INTO THE FLOW OF THE GAME.
HE HAS BEEN AROUND A LONG TIME.
HE REALLY KNOWS HOW TO PITCH.
SCOTT: NOW UP AGAINST JORDAN
LUPLOW, MR. WALKOFF HOME RUN ON
MONDAY AGAINST CLEVELAND.
RIGHT JIM: JIM:.
SEE THE DIFFERENCE THERE, HIS
FASTBALL IS INSIDE FOR STRIKES.
LOGAN ALLEN'S BALL WAS MORE
MIDDLE, OUT OVER THE PLATE WHEN
HE THREW THE FASTBALL.
MORE IN THAT AREA RIGHT THERE.
HAP SEEMS TO BE THROWING THE
BALL, WHEN HE SEEMS TO BE
THROWING IN, IT IS IN WHERE THE
HITTER TAKES IT OR YOU GET
JAMMED.
LATROY: WITH THAT MINDSET WHEN
YOU ARE GOING IN WITH THAT
FASTBALL, ESPECIALLY FROM THOSE
LEFT-HANDED PITCHERS TO
RIGHT-HANDED HITTERS, ANY MISHAP
AND THE BALL WILL END UP RIGHT
DOWN THERE.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENED TO LOGAN
ALLEN, IF HE CONTINUES TO DO
THAT IT WILL BE A SHORT NIGHT
FOR HIM.
SCOTT: LET'S GET A LITTLE MORE
ON J.A. HAPP, THE STARTER FOR
MINNESOTA WITH OUR GOOGLE PIXEL
PITCHING BREAKDOWN.
81% OF THE TIME IT IS A FASTBALL
WITH THE 38-YEAR-OLD.
LATROY: HE HAS TO PITCH AHEAD
AND THE COUNT.
STAY OUT OF THOSE 2-1, 31
COUNTS.
THOSE ARE HITTER'S COUNTS.
7.1 INNINGS OF NO-HIT BASEBALL
AGAINST THE PIRATES.
DRIVE THE BUS, TEAM IS ON A
LOSING STREAK, THIS IS THE GUY,
THE WAY HE HAS PITCHED SO FAR
THIS SEASON, HE'S THE GUY TO
STOP THIS LOSING STREAK AND GET
A WIN FOR HIS TEAM TODAY.
SCOTT: HE'S BEEN ON THE BUS FOR
15 BIG-LEAGUE SEASONS.
3-2 IS HIT TO DEEP CENTER.
BUXTON GIVING IT A LOOK AT HE
HAS SOME ROOM NEAR THE WARNING
TRACK FOR OUT NUMBER TWO.
WE WILL NOW LOOK AT THE
DEFENSIVE SET UP FOR THE
MINNESOTA TWINS.
THIS IS SOMETHING THE FRONT
OFFICE WAS PROUD OF, PICKING UP
ANDRELTON SIMMONS.
THAT MOVES JORGE POLANCO FROM
SHORTSTOP TO SECOND BASE.
THE YEAR BEFORE THAT THE PICKUP
OF DONALDSON GIVES THEM MORE OF
A SOLIDIFIED LOOK AT THE HOT
CORNER AND PUSHED MIGUEL SANO
OVER TO FIRST BASE.
WILLIANS ASTUDILLO IS THERE
TODAY.
NOW, JOSE RAMIREZ.
BACK-TO-BACK GAMES WITH A HOME
RUN.
JIM, YOU MENTION HIS PLATE
COVERAGE AND THE FACT THAT HE IS
CLOSE TO HOME PLATE, WHY DOES
THAT BENEFIT HIM?
JIM: IT ELIMINATES THE PITCHER
-- IT MAKES THE PITCHER NERVOUS
KNOWING THAT A GUY, IF A PITCHER
IS GOING TO THROW THE BALL AWAY,
IT IS IN RAMIREZ'S MIDDLE OF THE
PLATE FOR HIM WHERE HE STANDS.
WHEN I WAS IN CLEVELAND CHARLIE
MANUEL USED TO MOVE US ON THE
PLATE FOR THAT REASON.
IT CUTS DOWN THE DISTANCE WHERE
THE PITCHER HAS TO THROW.
IN A WAY IT MAKES THEM KIND OF
NERVOUS TO A POINT WHERE I DON'T
WANT TO MISS BUT I DO HAVE TO
THROW THE BALL INSIDE.
BY STANDING ON THE PLATE, I'M
LOOKING AT RAMIREZ HERE,
RIGHT-HANDED, HE'S A LITTLE MORE
OFF THEN HE IS LEFT-HANDED.
AS A PITCHER, WHEN I GUY WAS ON
THE PLATE, WHAT WAS YOUR
THOUGHTS?
SCOTT: IT IS DRIVEN TO CENTER
FIELD, THAT WILL DROP FOR A BASE
HIT TO RAMIREZ.
GO AHEAD, LATROY.
LATROY: THAT BALL WAS SMOKED.
CHALLENGE YOUR PITCHER TO THROW
THREE FASTBALLS INSIDE FOR A
STRIKE.
THAT IS NOT EASY.
YOU COULD THROW INSIDE THREE
TIMES IN A ROW BUT WILL THEY ALL
BE STRIKES?
HE'S TELLING THE PITCHER YOU
COULD DO THAT.
IF YOU COULD DO THAT, I WILL TO
MY HAT.
I WILL TAKE MY CHANCES ON YOU
MAKING A MISTAKE OVER THE MIDDLE
OF THE PLATE, OR MIDDLE AWAY.
IT IS STILL DOWN THE MIDDLE WITH
HIM STANDING SO CLOSE TO THE
PLATE.
SCOTT: DON'T MAKE A MISTAKE TO
THIS MAN, ESPECIALLY IN THE FAST
--PAST WEEK.
SEVEN FOR HIS LAST 12, 3 HOME
RUNS AND TWO OF THEM YESTERDAY.
LATROY: THOSE TO HOME RUNS HE
HIT OFF KENTA MAEDA WERE TWO OF
THE LOUDEST HOME RUNS I HEARD
THIS SEASON.
THEY WERE LOUD.
IT SOUNDED LIKE A CAR CRASH.
SCOTT: IF YOU ARE WATCHING NIGHT
GAME ON YOUR PHONE, THE PHONE IS
VIBRATING AND NO ONE IS CALLING.
IT IS JUST FRANMIL REYES, 452
FEET, THE NEXT ONE JUST FOR 34.
HE IS 6'5" AND TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF HIS BIG BODY AND ALL OF THE
POWER HE BRINGS TO THE TABLE.
RAMIREZ ON FIRST AFTER THE BASE
HIT.
IT IS A BALL AND A STRIKE TO
REYES.
HARD HIT RATE IS NUMBER THREE IN
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
THAT MEANS BALL OFF THE BAT AT
AT LEAST 95 MILES PER, ONLY
GIANCARLO STANTON AND RONALD
ACUNA DO IT MORE OFTEN.
ALL THREE OF HIS HITS YESTERDAY
WERE OVER 100 MILES PER HOUR OFF
OF THE BAT.
JIM: THAT WAS A CLOSE PITCH,
GUYS, I THINK HAPP WANTED
THAT ONE.
LATROY: ONE OF THOSE PITCHES
THAT COULD GO EITHER WAY.
JIM: THERE IS THE EXPERIENCE, HE
WENT DOWN IN THE ZONE AND
ELEVATE WILL BE INTERESTING HERE
IS WHERE HE GOES 2-2 AFTER GOING
LOW, THEN HIGH.
LET'S SEE WHAT HE DOES 2-2.
LATROY: I'D LIKE TO SEE HIM
ELEVATE THAT FASTBALL AGAIN.
SCOTT: HE DOES AND PICKS UP A
GAME, J.A. HAPP LEAVES JOSE
RAMIREZ ON, THE TWINS COME UP
COMING OFF THREE HOME RUNS IN
THE OPENING FRAME.
>> LEFT CENTER FIELD AND HE'S
GOT HIS FIRST BIG-LEAGUE HIT.
ALMOST THE SAME SPOT AS HIS
SECOND INNING PLAST -- BLAST.
KIRILLOFF IS STATE.
CONGRATULATIONS TO KIRILLOFF
FINALLY GETTING HIS FIRST
BIG-LEAGUE HIT.
>> ANXIOUS TO SEE THIS AT-BAT,
FRANMIL REYES.
THERE'S THE SLIDER, WILL HE GET
DOWN?
IT WILL.
COMING AROUND THIRD BASE IS
EDDIE ROSARIO.
THROW AT THE PLATE IS NOT IN
TIME.
>> HOW ABOUT THIS?
RIOS IS OUT OF THE GAME BECAUSE
BALDELLI FORGOT YOU CANNOT MAKE
TWO TRIPS TO THE MOUND IN ONE
INNING.
UNBELIEVABLE.
>> JOSE RAMIREZ, 0-3 STEPS TO
THE PLATE.
HAMMER DEEP RIGHT DOWN THE LINE,
HOME RUN.
TIE GAME.
THEY PLAYED WITH FIRE AND THEY
GOT BURNED.
>> JORDAN LUPLOW WITH THAT AT
SECOND, HIGH FLY BALL DEEP LEFT
FIELD.
BACK, LOOKING UP, IT IS GONE.
THE INDIANS HAVE THEIR FIRST
WALK OF THE YEAR.
SCOTT: A FOUR RUN SURGE FOR THE
TWINS AND THE FIRST INNING OFF
OF LOGAN ALLEN.
HE DISCUSS THINGS WITH SHANE
BIEBER BETWEEN THE INNINGS.
BEAVER IS -- BIEBER IS
MIC'D UP.
>> STAY WITH IT, KID.
YOU HAVE THE USA AND CANADA
SAYING IT IS CHARCUTERIE.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET EXILED.
SCOTT: YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH ONE OF THE TOP
PITCHERS IN THE GAME WHEN IT IS
NOT A START DAY?
CHARCUTERIE.
DID HE SAY IT RIGHT?
LATROY: I BETTER GET THIS RIGHT
BECAUSE MY DAUGHTERS LISTENING.
I THINK IT IS CHARCUTERIE.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
CHARCUTERIE BOARD WITH THE
CHEESES?
YES, HE SAID IT RIGHT.
SCOTT: THAT'S THE ONLY BOARD I
KNOW.
TELL YOUR DAUGHTER TO CONFIRM
THAT.
DEFINITELY NOT MY SPECIALTY.
WHAT ABOUT YOU, JIM?
JIM: SAME THING.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: JUST A LITTLE CAP AND A
LITTLE WORD OF ENCOURAGEMENT TO
LOGAN ALLEN FROM A SHANE BIEBER,
A CY YOUNG WINNER FROM LAST
YEAR.
HE HAS A SMILE ON HIS FACE.
MAYBE JUST TO GIVE HIM A LITTLE
BOOST OF CONFIDENCE HEADING INTO
THIS SECOND INNING, BOTTOM
PORTION OF THE ORDER AGAINST
MINNESOTA.
LATROY: FOR ME, WITH LOGAN
ALLEN, IT LOOKS LIKE HE WANTS TO
TRY TO OVERTHROW.
HIS TOP HALF IS OPENING UP WAY
TOO FAST.
HE'S NOT STAYING CLOSE LONG
ENOUGH TO GIVE HIMSELF AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DRIVE THAT PITCH
INTO THE ZONE.
ROSARIO PUTS AWAY SIMMONS.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SET YOU UP WITH
OUR FIRST POLE OF THE DAY ON
YOUTUBE.
VERY EASY TO CHIME IN, HOW MANY
MORE NO-HITTERS WILL WE SEE THIS
SEASON?
MAYBE IT IS FROM THE GUY ABOVE,
SHANE BIEBER.
WE HAVE HAD TWO ALREADY.
ONE MORE, 2, 3 PLUS?
OF COURSE WE ARE COMING OFF J.A.
HAPP'S START WHERE HE WAS FIVE
OUTS AWAY.
HE'S PITCHING AGAIN TODAY.
AS ALEX KIRILLOFF TAKES THE
FIRST PITCH DOWNSTAIRS.
MADISON BUMGARNER OVER THE WIN
GOT -- WE CAN CONTRIBUTE SEVEN
NO-HIT INNINGS BUT NOT
OFFICIALLY RULED A NO-HITTER.
LET'S GET A TICK, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
LATROY: BEING A PITCHER, I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THREE OR MORE.
SCOTT: JIM, I'M ASSUMING YOU
WILL SAY ZERO?
JIM: FOR THE HITTERS, I SHOULD
SAY ZERO.
I PERSONALLY THINK THERE WILL BE
TWO MORE.
I THINK THE PITCHING NOWADAYS IS
JUST SO GOOD.
THESE GUYS ARE PREPARING AT AN
INCREDIBLE LEVEL.
IT IS SO MUCH FUN TO WATCH.
TO HAVE THIS MANY, THIS EARLY IN
APRIL, I DO BELIEVE WE COULD
HAVE AT LEAST ONE, MAYBE TWO
MORE.
SCOTT: I'M WITH YOU, I WILL GO
TWO.
EVERYONE GET INVOLVED.
WE WILL PROVIDE THEM THROUGHOUT
THE DAY IN THE LIVE DAM
COMMENTARY, AND RESULTS COMING
SOON.
THE ROOKIE, ALEX KIRILLOFF DOES
NOT BITE, TWO BALLS, TWO
STRIKES.
LATROY: YOU SAID BUMGARNER WAS
NOT CREDITED WITH A NO-HITTER
BECAUSE IT WAS SEVEN INNINGS?
SCOTT: CORRECT, THERE WAS SOME
CONTROVERSY THERE.
YOU WANT TO SEE IT BE OFFICIAL?
LATROY: WHY NOT?
IT IS OFFICIAL, HE COULD GET THE
LOSS, A LOT OF THINGS COULD
HAPPEN, HE DIDN'T CHANGE THE
INNINGS.
SCOTT: KIRILLOFF UP THE MIDDLE
AND IT IS A BASE HIT.
YOU ARE RIGHT, DOUBLEHEADERS
ONLY GO SEVEN INNINGS.
KIRILLOFF IS A BOARD WITH THE
BASE KNOCK WITH ONE OUT HERE IN
THE SECOND.
WHAT ABOUT YOU, JIM?
DO YOU THINK BUMGARNER SHOULD
HAVE A NO-HITTER ADDED TO HIS
RESUME?
JIM: ABSOLUTELY.
IF WE ARE GOING TO PLAY SEVEN
INNINGS AND A GUY GOES OUT AND
NO-HIT SAFETY IN, HE SHOULD BE
CREDITED WITH THE NO-HITTER, IT
IS NOT HIS FAULT THAT SEVEN
INNINGS WAS WHAT WE ARE DOING
NOW, HOW MANY INNINGS WE ARE
PLAYING.
YOU HAVE TO REWARD THE YOUNG MAN
FOR GOING OUT AND DOING HIS JOB
AND THAT IS WHAT HE DID.
SCOTT: LONGEST ACTIVE NO-HITTER
DROUGHT NOW BELONGS TO THIS
CLEVELAND TEAM.
WE HADN'T SEEN ONE IN PADRES
FRANCHISE HISTORY BUT JOE
MUSGROVE WAS ABLE TO SCRATCH
THAT OFF.
LATROY: YOU HAD ME THINKING.
IF SOMEBODY COULD TELL US WHEN
THE TWINS LAST NO-HITTER WAS.
WAS IT MILTON?
IT WAS ERIC MILTON, IT WAS A DAY
GAME.
SCOTT: FRANCISCO LIRIANO, 2011.
LATROY: I MISSED THAT WHEN I WAS
STILL PLAYING.
SCOTT: YOU WERE BUSY, WHO WERE
YOU WITH AT THAT POINT?
LATROY: MILWAUKEE BREWERS.
SCOTT: BYRON BUXTON TRYING TO
FOLLOW UP HIS HOME RUN TO START
THE DAY, STATCAST POWERED BY
GOOGLE CLOUD.
BUXTON LEFT THE BUILDING IN A
HURRY.
32 DEGREES ON THE LAUNCH ANGLE,
350 FEET.
THAT IS A HOME RUN IN ONLY FOUR
MAJOR LEAGUE BALLPARKS.
OTHERWISE, IT IS OFTEN A FLY
OUT.
ONLY 32% HIT EXPECTANCY ON THAT
ONE OFF THE BAT OF BUXTON.
HE PICKED THE RIGHT PARK TO GO
THE OTHER WAY.
LATROY: I WOULD ONLY HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT IF THIS WAS
THE ONLY PARK THAT WOULD'VE BEEN
A HOME RUN IN.
THERE ARE OTHERS, SO WE ARE
GOOD.
JIM: RIGHT.
SCOTT: KIRILLOFF ADVANCES INTO
SCORING POSITION.
THIS IS THE GAUNTLET COMING UP
HERE.
IT IS BUXTON, DONALDSON, AND
THEN CRUISE.
SKIPPER, ROCCO BALDELLI HAS BEEN
TINKERING WITH THE LINEUP
LATELY.
COUNT IS FULL TO BUXTON.
YESTERDAY, NELSON CRUZ WAS IN
THE FOUR SPOT.
BUXTON WAS HITTING THIRD.
CRUZ HAD A TRIPLE YESTERDAY.
LATROY: HE SURE DID.
YOU SEE THAT 2-2 SLIDER THAT
LOGAN JUST THREW TO BUXTON?
PREVIOUS YEARS, THAT'S A PITCH
BUXTON WOULD BE SWINGING AT.
SCOTT: HE SWINGS AT THE 3-2 AND
GETS IT PAST THE INFIELD.
BUXTON WITH THE HUSTLE INTO
SECOND, HE HAS HIMSELF A DOUBLE.
BLAZING SPEED FROM THE LEADOFF
MAN, WHO COULD CHECK OFF A
DOUBLE AND A HOME RUN IN HIS
FIRST TWO AT-BATS OF THE DAY.
JIM: FELLAS, THERE ARE SO MANY
THINGS THIS GUY DOES.
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS THIS
GUY DOES FROM THE OFFENSE OF END
-- DEFENSIVE END -- OFFENSIVE
D
ND.
HE MIGHT BE THE MOST DYNAMIC
PLAYER RIGHT NOW IN THE GAME.
OUT-OF-THE-BOX, IF YOU PROBABLY
WATCHED HIM, HE WAS THINKING TWO
RIGHT AWAY.
I HAVE WATCHED HIM OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS, WHEN YOU GET TO THE
BALLPARK THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
THAT JUMPED OUT AT YOU.
TO WATCH THIS GUY RUN ALONE IS
SO IMPRESSIVE.
I DON'T THINK IN MY CAREER I
HAVE EVER SEEN ANYONE JUST GLIDE
AND RUN LIKE THIS.
SCOTT: HE KNOCKS OUT THE
STARTIN'S
DAY IS DONE AFTER JUST FOUR OUTS
RECORDED, A FEW HOMERUNS.
♪
>> HEART IS PALPITATING.
>> YULI ON A 2-2 PITCH, THROWS
HIS BAT AND THOUSAND.
>> AN INDICATION THAT GURRIEL
DOESN'T SQUEEZE THE BAT TOO
TIGHTLY.
>> IN FRONT OF THE PLATE IT IS A
FAIR BALL.
>> HAD TO GET OUT OF DODGE IN A
HURRY.
>> MCKINNEY SLAPS ONE LEFT SIDE,
TOUGH PLAY, WOW.
NEVER HAD A GRIP.
TRYING TO GET RID OF IT.
>> THIS IS IN THE AIR TO LEFT
FIELD, IT WILL GET IN FOR A BASE
HIT.
>> HE HIT THAT BALL TWICE.
DID YOU SEE THAT?
>> FIRST TIME THERE HE BREAKS IT
AND THEN OFF THE BARREL.
SCOTT: MLB ORIGINAL SEASON TO IS
OUT ON YOUTUBE WITH NEW EPISODES
EVERY WEEK.
SEE YOUR FAVORITE PLAYERS AND
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE GAME YOU
LOVE ON YOUTUBE.COM/MLB.
ROCCO BALDELLI MUST BE PLEASED
WITH THE HOT START FROM'S
BALLCLUB KNOCKING OUT STARTING
PITCHER LOGAN ALLEN.
WE ARE JUST IN THE SECOND, ONE
DOWN, TWO ON FOR JOSH DONALDSON.
IT WAS KIRILLOFF IN THE
NINE-HOLE FOLLOWED BY BUXTON'S
DOUBLE.
INCOMES TREVOR STEPHAN, THE
25-YEAR-OLD LAST PITCHED AGAINST
THE YANKEES AND GAVE UP A RUN IN
TWO YANKEE -- INNINGS, SOLO HOME
RUN OFF THE BAT OF GIANCARLO
STANTON.
THAT JUST MISSED TO DONALDSON.
BIG PITCH IS HIS SLIDER.
J.D. ALSO CONTRIBUTING A HOME
RUN IN THE FIRST.
SCOTT BRAUN, LATROY HAWKINS, JIM
THOME, J.P. MOROSI, WE ARE IN
CLEVELAND.
DONALDSON FOUL THAT ONE BACK.
A HOT START FOR MINNESOTA.
YESTERDAY, ROCCO BALDELLI TALKS
TO THE TEAM AFTER THE GAME.
HE SPOKE TO US THIS MORNING AND
MENTIONED DESPITE THE STRUGGLES,
BULLPEN, INJURIES, SOME PLAYERS
DEALING WITH DOUBTS OF COVID.
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A LACK OF
HUSTLE.
WE HAVE SEEN EVERY GAME FROM
THIS MINNESOTA TWINS TEAM
BRINGING THE FIRE, BRINGING THE
COMPETITIVENESS.
THIS GUY HELPS THE CAUSE.
LATROY: WHEN YOU HAVE A TEAM WHO
HAS BEEN STRUGGLING, THAT'S THE
FIRST THING A MANAGER LOOKS FOR.
ARE THEY STILL HUSTLING?
HOW THEY ARE APPROACHING IT,
THEIR ATTITUDE, ALL OF THOSE
THINGS ARE INTACT.
THEY JUST HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
WIN GAMES.
THEY LOST A LOT OF CLOSE GAMES.
THE WAY THIS TEAM WAS
CONSTRUCTED, I'M WILLING TO BET
THOSE CLOSE GAMES WILL START
TURNING INTO WINS.
ARM EVER BEING WITH THE ROCKIES
IN 2007, WE WERE 10-15 AFTER
APRIL.
WE ENDED UP 90-73, THERE IS TIME
FOR THEM TO RECOVER.
NOBODY HAS TAKEN OVER THE
CENTRAL DIVISION.
SCOTT: IF YOU ARE CLEVELAND,
THEY HAVE AN OFF DAY TOMORROW,
LOGAN ALLEN DID NOT HAVE IT.
TERRY FRANCONA FIGURES JOSE
RAMIREZ AND FRANMIL REYES GET
HOT WE HAVE A SHOT, IT IS 4-0.
PLENTY OF TIME TO GO IN THIS
ONE.
JIM: IF YOU COULD STOP IT FROM
HERE ON, ESPECIALLY WITH THOSE
GUYS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE ORDER,
YOU COULD PUT UP A RUN'S QUICK.
HERE ON OUT YOU HAVE TO HOLD
THEM.
MINNESOTA'S OFFENSE, AT TIMES
THAT COULD BE A TOUGH TASK.
THIS WILL BE INTERESTING TO
WATCH HOW IT ALL PLAYS OUT AS
THIS YOUNG KID COMES IN THE GAME
AND HOW HE ATTACKS THESE TWINS
HITTERS.
SCOTT: HE LOSES DONALDSON, THAT
LOADS THE BASES, LET'S BRING IN
J.P.
J.P.: THE AMERICAN LEAGUE
CENTRAL IS NEAR AND DEAR TO ALL
OF US, I MUST NOTE THE
FOLLOWING.
THE BEST RECORD IN THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE TODAY BELONGS TO THE
KANSAS CITY ROYALS.
.636 WINNING PERCENTAGE, TWO
GAMES ABOVE THE WHITE SOX ATOP
THE DIVISION.
ONE OF THE MORE SURPRISING
DEVELOPMENTS I BELIEVE IN ALL OF
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL THIS
MONTH.
SCOTT: THEY WERE MOVING IN THE
OFF-SEASON.
KANSAS CITY DOING SOME WORK,
BRINGING BACK MIKE MINOR,
TRADING FOR ANDREW BENINTENDI.
THEY SIGNED CARLOS SANTANA TO A
TWO YEAR CONTRACT.
FORMER CLEVELAND GREAT.
JIM: THEY HAVE A YOUNG KID,
BOBBY WITT JR. THAT HAD A HECK
OF A SPRING.
I'M SURE AT SOME POINT BASEBALL
WILL SEE HIM SHORTLY.
WHAT A REALLY GOOD YOUNG PLAYER
TO ADD TO WHAT THEY HAVE.
SCOTT: HE'S MY FAVORITE PROSPECT
IN THE SPORT, BOBBY WITT JR..
NELSON CRUZ, LOUD CONTACT TO
RIGHT FIELD AND IT IS OFF THE
TOP OF THE WALL.
THAT IS GOING TO SCORE A COUPLE
FOR MINNESOTA.
NELSON CRUZ CONTRIBUTING THE TWO
RUN SINGLE, IT IS 6-0,
MINNESOTA.
ALMOST LEFT THE YARD.
WOULD'VE BEEN HIS 11TH CAREER
GRAND SLAM.
NELSON CRUZ POUNDED THAT
BASEBALL.
BUXTON SCORES ALONG WITH
KIRILLOFF.
LATROY: FASTBALL RIGHT DOWN THE
MIDDLE, SOMETHING WE DEFINITELY
HAVE SEEN CREWS HANDLE.
ABLE TO MUSCLED UP OFF THE
RIGHT-FIELD WALL.
NOLAN PLAYED THE CAROM PERFECT
TO KEEP THEM TO A SINGLE.
SCOTT: THOSE BASE RUNNERS BELONG
TO LOGAN ALLEN.
THE CLEVELAND STARTER HAS GIVEN
UP 15 RUNS IN HIS LAST 5.2
INNINGS OVER THREE TOTAL STARTS.
NOW JORGE POLANCO.
JIM: I KNOW IN TODAY'S GAME WE
TALK ABOUT LAUNCH ANGLE.
WHAT I WANT TO POINT OUT ON THAT
IS TO HIT A BALL LIKE THAT TO
RIGHT FIELD AND HIT IT ON A
LINE, STRAIGHT -- WHAT A
BEAUTIFUL LEVEL SWING THAT WAS
THAT NELSON HAD.
IF YOU WATCH HIM, HE WILL GO
DOWN AND GET THEM AND GET UNDER
THEM.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WHAT I
LOVE, THAT BALL IS DELHI AND UP,
HE HAS A REALLY NICE LEVEL
SWING.
WHAT A TREMENDOUS HITTER THIS
GUY HAS BECOME OVER THE YEARS OF
HIS CAREER.
SCOTT: POLANCO LOBS ONE TO LEFT,
INCOMES ROSARIO.
TWO GONE IN THE SECOND.
NELSON CRUZ FEAST ON PITCHES
DOWN OR UP, UNFAZED.
JIM: HE REALLY HITS FROM THAT
BACKSIDE SO WELL.
HE'S REALLY KIND OF PRESET TO
THE BACK HIP.
WHEN HE'S GOING WELL, HE WILL
GET THE BALL RIGHT THERE AND HE
DROPS THE BALL -- BARREL TO THE
BASEBALL.
THE BALL JUST JUMPS OFF HIS BAT.
LEFT FIELD, CENTER, RIGHT, HE'S
GOT THE STRENGTH TO GO OUT
ANYWHERE.
SCOTT: RUNNER STAY PUT ON THE
CORNERS FOR MITCH GARVER.
THAT JUST MISSES.
FIRST FOUR HITTERS WERE
SUCCESSFUL FOR THE TWINS AND THE
TOP OF THE FIRST.
BUXTON HOMERED, DONALDSON
FOLLOWED WITH THE SAME RESULT,
NELSON CRUZ WALKED, POLANCO
BROUGHT HIM HOME WITH A TWO RUN
SHOT.
HERE THE SECOND A TWO RUN, IT IS
SIX FOR MINNESOTA.
GARVER STRUCK OUT BACK IN THE
FIRST.
HERE IS THE SPRAY CHART.
HE PLAYS TO PULL THE BASEBALL.
THAT IS ACTUALLY WHAT HIS
MANAGER SAID HE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE, USE MORE OF THAT RIGHT SIDE
OF THE FIELD.
HE HAS NOT GONE AWAY TOO MUCH.
LATROY: IN HIS THIRD AT-BAT
YESTERDAY HE HIT A LINE DRIVE TO
NOLAN IN RIGHT FIELD.
THE TWINS BROADCASTER SAID THAT
IS THE FIRST HARD-HIT BALL HE
SEEN HIM HIT TO RIGHT FIELD IN
TWO YEARS.
THAT'S SAYING A LOT.
ROCCO WAS SAYING WANTED HIM TO
GET BACK TO HITTING, NOT WORRIED
ABOUT THE HOME RUN, PUTTING A
GOOD SWING ON SOMETHING AND
HITTING IT HARD.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE PULLED.
SCOTT: HARD NOT TO LOOK BACK AT
2019 AND THINK ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITIES FOR THE SILVER
SLUGGER WINNER AT THE CATCHING
POSITION.
ALSO THE PLATE APPEARANCES, ONLY
359, YET 31 HOME RUNS.
HE HAD THE BEST HOME RUN FOR AT
THAT RATIO IN THE BIG LEAGUES
THAT YEAR.
HEDGES WILL GIVE THAT ONE A
LOOK, IT IS FOULED OFF.
IT IS 2-2.
YOU KNOW THE OTHER THING THAT
MITCH GARVER DID WELL -- YOU GOT
IT JIM.
JIM: HE HAD A NICE SWING AT THAT
PITCH.
IT WAS A LITTLE UP.
IF THAT BALL WOULD'VE BEEN A
LITTLE BIT DOWN, I HAVE A
FEELING HE WOULD'VE REALLY
SQUARED THAT BALL UP.
THAT IS THE FINE LINE OF
HITTING.
THEN YOU GET INTO A SITUATION
WHERE NOW THEY WILL THROW A
BREAKING BALL.
HE HAD THAT FASTBALL.
IT WAS A LITTLE ELEVATED.
SCOTT: THE TWINS ADD TWO MORE, T
IS 6-0 AND THE MIDDLE OF THE
SECOND IN CLEVELAND.
>> TWO DOWN FOR JOSE RAMIREZ.
SWUNG ON AND HAMMERED TO DEEP
RIGHT, WAY OUT OF HERE.
>> NUMBER SIX FOR JOSE RAMIREZ.
FRANMIL REYES HAS BEEN HITTING A
LOT THE LAST EIGHT GAMES,
HITTING .35 FIVE.
SWUNG ON AND HIT HARD, DEEP TO
LEFT, WAY OUT OF HERE.
ALL MY -- OH MY, THREE QUARTERS
OF THE WAY UP THE BLEACHERS.
RAY SWINGS AND HITS IT DEEP TO
LEFT, FORGET ABOUT IT.
ANOTHER ROCKET.
REYES HAS HIS SECOND HOME RUN
TONIGHT.
>> FACES BUXTON WITH A TWO RUN
LEAD IN THE BASES EMPTY.
BUXTON SWINGS AND LAUNCHES HIGH
AND DEEP TO LEFT FIELD, BACK IT
GOES, DEEP IT GOES, AND GONE.
NUMBER SEVEN FOR BUXTON.
IT IS A ONE RUN GAME.
>> SWING AND A MISS, WIPED HIM
OUT.
BALLGAME.
SCOTT: SIX--- 6-0 TWINS.
DON'T FORGET TO CHECK OUT
YOUTUBE'S LIVE GAME FROM THE
TWINS ACCOUNT, INDIANS ACCOUNT.
THE LIVE GAME COMMENTARY ON YOUR
SMART TV.
WE WILL KEEP AN EYE ON THE
DISCUSSION THROUGHOUT THE
BROADCAST.
SPORTS GAMING UNIVERSE SAYING
HELLO TO JIM AND LATROY.
HE SAYS JIM A HOME RUN THAT HIT
THE FLAGPOLE DURING YOUR RUN
WITH THE TWINS IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPRESSIVE THINGS I HAVE
EVER WITNESSED.
HE HAS A NOTE FOR LATROY AS J.A.
HAPP MISSES TO EDDIE ROSARIO.
HE SAYS I REMEMBER WATCHING
LATROY BREAKING IN AS A ROOKIE
BACK IN THE DAY WITH THE TWINS.
MY FRIENDS AND I WERE ALL ON THE
LATROY FOR ROOKIE OF.
[LAUGHTER]
SKIES THAT ONE, DONALDSON CALLS
FOR IT AND RECORDS THE OUT.
THERE WAS A FAN CLUB THAT
STARTED BACK IN 2000, I BELIEVE
WITH THE TWINS.
LATROY: YES, THE FAN CLUB
STARTED BY A COUPLE OF FANS THAT
WERE STANDING OUTSIDE IN THE
RAIN.
I WAS THE ONLY PLAYER TO STAND
AND STOP -- STOP AND SIGN IN THE
RAIN.
THE PRESIDENT DECIDED HE WOULD
START THE LHFC.
THERE IS OVER 1000 MEMBERS,
THERE'S ABOUT 35-40 THAT I KEEP
IN REGULAR CONTACT WITH.
SCOTT: HOW COOL IS THAT?
GRAB A LUNCH WITH SOMEONE MAYBE
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE AND
REMINISCE?
LATROY: LUNCHES, DINNERS, THEY
HAVE ACTUALLY BABYSAT MY
DAUGHTER.
I WAS AT A FAMILY OUTING.
I LET MY SON -- I LET THEIR SON
DRIVE MY CAR TO THE PROM.
SCOTT: ROSARIO GOING THE OTHER
WAY AND IT IS GONE.
THE INDIANS ARE ON THE BOARD.
ROSARIO'S SECOND HOME RUN OF THE
SEASON.
CLEVELAND BREAKS THE ICE.
JIM: ANOTHER BEAUTIFUL SWING.
THAT BALL MUST BE GOING OUT TO
RIGHT FIELD.
THE BALL SEEMS TO BE JUMPING.
WHAT A NICE BEAUTIFUL SWING,
STAYED ON IT AND SHOUTED OUT TO
RIGHT FIELD.
LATROY: I LIKE TO SEE HITTERS
STAY ON THAT FASTBALL.
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY YOU COULD
DRIVE THAT BALL TO RIGHT FIELD.
AS SOON AS THAT FRONT HIP OPENS
UP, THAT IS A LAZY FLY BALL.
SCOTT: THAT ONE IS ON THE GROUND
INTO THE SHIFT.
JOSH NAYLOR IS RETIRED.
WHEN IT COMES TO PROGRESSIVE
FIELD, IF YOU LIKE GOING TO
RIGHT, THIS IS ONE OF THE BETTER
BALLPARKS TO TEE OFF AND ALL OF
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
SCOTT: A HOME RUN IN 17 PARKS.
45% HIT PROBABILITY.
THAT ONE A LITTLE MORE LIKELY
THAN WHAT WE SAW FROM BUXTON IN
THE FIRST.
NOW IT IS A YU CHANG.
LATROY: HAPP HAS DONE EVERYTHING
I TALKED ABOUT.
THAT HOME RUN WAS A 0-2 HOME
RUN.
IT WAS NOT A BAD PITCH.
IT WAS JUST A BETTER SWING.
SCOTT: THE TWINS COULD USE THE
ASSISTANCE.
THEIR BULLPEN HAS HAD A TOUGH GO
LATELY.
ALEX COLOME, THEY'RE CLOSER,
THERE OFF-SEASON SIGNING HAS
BEEN PUSHED DOWN TO LOWER
LEVERAGE SITUATIONS.
THE OTHER NIGHT HE STRUGGLED
AGAIN.
HE'S EVEN ABOVE LANCE LYNN THESE
DAYS.
LATROY: THAT'S PRETTY
IMPRESSIVE.
ESPECIALLY IN THE AREA OF -- ERA
OF BASEBALL, IT IS ALMOST 50-50
WITH BREAKING BALLS AND
FASTBALLS.
HE IS DOING IT WITH JUSTICE
FASTBALL.
SCOTT: POLANCO CLEAN THAT UP.
J.A. HAPP GIVES UP THE HOME RUN
TO AMED ROSARIO.
SQUAD PROVIDING PLENTY OF
POP.
TWINS SIX, INDIANS ONE.
>> MARK CANHA LEADS OFF.
GROUND BALL IS ROLLING OUT TO
SECOND BASE, BAREHANDS AND
THROWS HIM OUT.
MAKING THAT PLAY.
DONALDSON HAMMERS ONE TO LEFT
FIELD AND DEEP.
BACK IT GOES, DEEP IT GOES, AND
GONE.
A HOME RUN TO LEFT, HIS FIRST OF
THE SEASON AND THE TWINS TAKE A
1-0 LEAD.
>> SWING AND A DRIVE LEFT FIELD
AND DEEP.
BACK IT GOES, DEEP IT GOES,
GONE.
TWINS TAKE THE LEAD ON A 3-2
HANGER.
A TWO RUN SHOT.
>> NOW I BLAST TO LEFT CENTER
FIELD.
A DIVING CATCH IN CENTER.
WHAT A CATCH BY BYRON BUXTON.
PRESERVING THE LEAD.
A TREMENDOUS CATCH BY BUXTON TO
KEEP THE TWINS OF 10-9.
>> LEFT FIELD, GONE, A HOME RUN.
WILLENS AUSTIDILLO'S FIRST
OF THE YEAR.
SCOTT: 30 -- READY FOR THE THIRD
INNING IN CLEVELAND, THE YOUTUBE
PLAYER OF THE GAME.
FANS COULD VOTE FOR WHICH PLAYER
WILL RECEIVE THE TROPHY, THE
TROPHY IS IN CLEVELAND WAITING
TO BE HANDED OUT DURING THE
POSTGAME SHOW.
STAY TUNED FOR THE PLAYER OF THE
GAME POLLING OPTIONS LATER IN
THE SHOW.
YOU WILL HAVE A CHANCE TO
CONTRIBUTE AND HAND THE TROPHY.
THEY ALL HAVE HOME RUNS THE FAR
TODAY.
LET'S WRAP UP OUR FIRST POLE,
COMEDY MORNEAU HITTERS WILL WE
SEE THIS SEASON?
THE WINNER IS THREE PLUS.
LATROY HELPED SWAY THE CROWD A
LITTLE BIT WITH THE VOLUME.
LATROY: IT IS ONE OF THOSE
SITUATIONS WHERE IF WE COULD SEE
PITCHING IS A LOT MORE ADVANCED
WHEN IT COMES TO ANALYTICS.
THE PITCHING GUYS UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO WITH THE
CARRYING, WE HADN'T FIGURED OUT
THAT HITTING ASPECT YET.
SCOTT: THE SWING LEADS TO A
GROUND BALL OUT.
WILLIAMS AUSTIN DILLA --
WILLIAMS AUSTIN DELO IS COMING
UP.
WE WILL SPEAK TO ONE OF THE FINE
PITCHERS AND MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL THE NEXT HALF INNING.
YOUTUBE CREATORS, YOU KNOW WHAT
TO DO.
LOAD UP YOUR QUESTIONS RIGHT
NOW.
WE WILL ASK SOME OF THEM LIVE
DURING THE GAME.
PULLS THAT ONE DOWN THE LINE AND
IT IS GONE.
LA TORTUGA GOES LONG.
THE FOURTH HOME RUN OF THE DAY
FOR THE TWINS, WE ARE ONLY HIM
THE THIRD.
HIS SECOND OF THE SEASON.
JIM: BEAUTIFUL SWING, BREAKING
BALL HERE AND STAYED ON IT.
WHAT A NICE, LEVEL BEAUTIFUL
SWING.
CAME DOWN TO THE BALL NICE.
LATROY: I'VE THROWN BATTING
PRACTICE A FEW TIMES OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
THERE'S NOT A PITCH THAT HE DOES
NOT LIKE.
HE WILL SWING AT EVERYTHING AND
PITCHES DOWN IN THE ZONE HE
COULD REALLY TATTOO.
SCOTT: SIMMONS. HE FOUND THAT
OFF, TWO DOWN.
HIS 10TH CAREER HOME RUN.
YOU GOT IT, JIM.
JIM: SOMETIMES WHAT HAPPENS,
WHEN YOU ARE THROWING BATTING
PRACTICE LIKE THAT YOU ARE
THROWING TO A GUY IN SWING MODE,
THEY ALWAYS SAY HOW DO YOU GET
OUT OF A SLUMP?
SOMETIMES IT IS BEING AGGRESSIVE
AND SWINGING THE BAT.
I THINK THAT IS THE CASE WITH
THIS KID.
WHEN THEY WILL GO THROUGH A BAD
TIME, TO BE IN SWING MODE COULD
GET YOU OUT OF THAT QUICKLY BY
PUTTING THE BALL IN PLAY AND
MAKING GOOD THINGS HAPPEN.
LATROY: HE IS SO VALUABLE TO THE
TEAM BECAUSE HE PLAYS MULTIPLE
POSITIONS.
WITH INJURIES AND GUYS BEING ON
THE COVID LIST, HE HAS BEEN ABLE
TO PLAY SOME THIRD BASE, LEFT
FIELD, FIRST BASE, SECOND BASE.
HE ALSO CATCHES.
HE HAS MADE HIMSELF VERY
VALUABLE IN THIS ERA OF PLAY.
GOOD FASTBALL, JUST TATTOOED
DOWN IN THE ZONE.
ALEX KIRILLOFF IS ONE OF THE TOP
PROSPECTS IN THE TWINS
ORGANIZATION.
THIS KID WILL HIT AT THE MAJOR
LEAGUE LEVEL.
HIS BALL TO BAT SKILLS ARE OFF
THE CHARTS.
I'M SAYING THAT WHILE HE STRIKES
OUT.
SCOTT: A LOT OF LOUD CONTACT
FROM HIS.
FORMER FIRST-ROUND PICK, TOP 25
OVERALL PROSPECT.
ASTUDILLO JOINS A HOME RUN
PARTY, IT IS 7-1.
>> THE PRIDE OF MOUNDSVILLE HIGH
SCHOOL.
>> SWING AND A MISS, NICE CURVE
TO GET ADAM EATON.
>> HE STRIKES OUT HIS FIRST
MAJOR LEAGUE HITTER.
>> ANOTHER BULLET BUT THIS ONE
IS TURNED INTO A DOUBLE PLAY.
>> RIGHT AT YOU, PERFECT.
>> HAMMERED, DEEP LEFT CENTER
FIELD AND IT IS GOING TO ONE HOP
THE FENCE.
AROUND SECOND, HE'S GOING TO GO
FOR THREE.
HERE'S THE THROW, THE BIG MAN
COMES IN SAFE.
>> HAMMERED HIGH ON THE AIR,
DEEP LEFT FIELD, HE'S LOOKING
UP, DON TO SEE THE NEAR CITY.
THE INDIANS ARE ON THE BOARD.
>> HIGH FLY BALL, RIGHT FIELD
AND DEEP.
JUDGE IS BACK.
IT IS OUT OF HERE.
FRANMIL REYES AND THE INDIANS,
RIGHT BACK AND TAKE THE LEAD.
SCOTT: FOUR HOME RUNS THIS
AFTERNOON FOR MINNESOTA.
WE ARE IN THE LAST OF THE THIRD.
LA TORTUGA HOMERED IN THE LAST
HALF, WHICH CURRENT PLAYER HAS
THE BEST NICKNAME?
WE GIVE YOU SOME GOOD OPTIONS.
PETE ALONSO, POLAR BEAR.
LA TORTUGA, YOU ARE LOOKING AT
HIM.
FRANMIL REYES, FRANIMAL.
JUAN SOTO, CHILDISH BAMBINO.
J.A. HAPP GETS READY TO GO
AGAINST 9, 1, 2 FROM CLEVELAND.
STARTS WITH AUSTIN HEDGES.
TIME TO BRING IN OUR GUEST
TODAY.
JOSE BERRIOS, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
IN THE CHAT, YOUTUBE CREATORS,
IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS FOR JOSE,
GOOD AFTERNOON, HOW ARE YOU
DOING?
JOSE: GOOD AFTERNOON, GUYS,
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME TODAY, I
AM FINE.
SCOTT: I WILL HAVE YOU START OFF
WITH THE ANSWER TO THE POLL
QUESTION, BEST NICKNAME IN MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL, COULD YOU GO
OFF ONE OF THE OPTIONS?
OR I WILL LET YOU GO OFF THE
BOARD AS WELL.
WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT THE BEST
NICKNAME IN THE GAME?
JOSE: WE HAVE A FEW THAT ARE
GOOD.
I LIKE MAYAN.
I ENJOY IT.
ASTUDILLO IS LA TORTUGA.
HE RUNS LOW BUT AT THE SAME TIME
HE IS FUNNY.
SCOTT: YOUR NICKNAME IS THE
MACHINE, WHERE DID THAT COME
FROM?
JIM: THAT COMES FROM --
JOSE: THAT COMES FROM THE
TRAINER.
WHEN I WORK OUT.
THAT'S WHERE THAT COMES FROM.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
LATROY: IT'S LATROY, HOW ARE
YOU?
JOSE: HOW YOU BEEN?
LATROY: WHAT HAS BEEN THE REASON
FOR YOUR GREAT START SO FAR IN
THE 2021 SEASON?
I'M GLAD TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
JOSE: --
JOSE:JOSE: I'M GLAD TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY.
WE HAVE MORE TO COME.
MY MINDSET EVERY DAY, EVERY
OUTING.
WHAT I HAVE BEEN DOING SO FAR,
WHAT I HAVE TO DO AND GETTING
BETTER.
I THINK THAT WILL HELP ME
THROUGH THE BEGINNING OF THE
SEASON.
JIM: CONGRATULATIONS, YOU HAVE
BECOME SUCH AN ELITE PITCHER IN
THE GAME.
IS THERE ANYTHING ON THE FOUR
DAYS OFF THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
DOING TO MAINTAIN SUCH AN ELITE
LEVEL MOVING FORWARD IN YOUR
CAREER?
JOSE: THE GUYS ALWAYS HAVE A
ROUTINE.
I HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THAT TO
CREATE MY OWN.
THIS IS MY DAY BECAUSE I THROUGH
-- THREW TWO DAYS AGO.
WE MAKE A JUDGMENT WHEN WE HAVE
AN OFF DAY, AN EXTRA DAY.
WE CAME TO THE BALLPARK TODAY
AND DID LONG TOSS.
THEN I GO TO THE WEIGHT ROOM.
WE WILL PITCH WITH THE SAME
MINDSET.
WE WILL GIVE 100%.
AT THE SAME TIME, BE HEALTHY AND
FRESH FOR THE NEXT DAY.
SCOTT: WE ARE HANGING OUT WITH A
WORLDWIDE AUDIENCE ON YOUTUBE.
THE CLEVELAND LEADOFF HITTER,
CESAR HERNANDEZ.
TWINS UP 7-1.
WE WILL BRING IN SOME OF THOSE
YOUTUBE CREATOR COLLECTIONS --
QUESTIONS.
ZACH HAMPEL JOINED US ON THE
PREGAME.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE PITCHING IN AN
MLB GAME IN PUERTO RICO?
I WAS THERE AND IT WAS GREAT TO
SEE.
JOSE: FOR ME, THAT THEY WERE
SPECIAL.
PITCHING IN FRONT OF MY FAMILY,
FRIENDS, I ENJOY THE TIME I
SPENT THERE WITH MY TEAMMATES,
ALL OF THE PEOPLE.
THAT IS THE BIG THING FOR ME.
I WILL TAKE THAT FOR THE REST OF
MY CAREER IN BASEBALL.
SCOTT: THAT WAS A BIG BUCKET
LIST MOMENT AND YOU WERE
FANTASTIC.
IT WAS AWESOME TO WATCH.
WHO WAS YOUR FAVORITE BALLPLAYER
TO WATCH GROWING UP?
JOSE: WHEN I WAS GROWING UP I
LIKE TO BE A CATCHER.
MY DAD WOULD LET ME BE A CATCHER
BECAUSE I WAS TOO SHORT.
MY FAVORITE PLAYER WAS IVAN
RODRIGUEZ, PUDGE.
SCOTT: I LOVE IT.
HERE'S ONE FROM MADE THE CUT AS
THE TWO-ZERO OFFERING IS COMING
UP TO JORDAN LUPLOW FROM J.A.
HAPP.
WHICH OF YOUR PITCHING MATES
COULD PLAY A POSITION OUTSIDE OF
PITCHER THE BEST?
WHAT POSITION WOULD BE?
OUT OF YOUR FELLOW PITCHING
TEAMMATES, COULD ANY OF THEM
PLAY A NUMBER OF POSITIONS LIKE
YOUR BUDDY LUIS ARRAEZ SITTING
RIGHT NEAR YOU?
JOSE: THIS GUY COULD PLAY
EVERYWHERE ON THE FIELD.
WE'VE GOT PLENTY.
OUR PITCHERS ARE ATHLETES.
THEY CAN PLAY ANYWHERE OUT ON
THE FIELD.
ME, I WOULD LIKE TO PLAY
SHORTSTOP.
SCOTT: LUPLOW FLIES OUT.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE YOU PLAY
SHORTSTOP, MAYBE A LITTLE
CATCHER THANK YOU, GUYS.
SCOTT: TWINS UP 7-1 AFTER THREE
ON YOUTUBE.
♪
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> GREAT BASEBALL RIGHT THERE.
>> THAT ONE IS GOING TO GO.
>> THIS IS GOING TO DO IT.
STRIKE THREE.
>> THAT IS A GREAT PLAY.
>> HE TALKED ABOUT HIS FIELDING
SKILLS, THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
SCOTT: WE ARE IN THE FOURTH AND
CLEVELAND IS ABOUT TO SEND IN
THEIR THIRD PITCHER OF THE GAME
ALREADY BECAUSE BYRON BUXTON AND
COMPANY ARE PUTTING ON A SHOW.
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD.
BUXTON LEFT THE YARD AND HIS
FIRST AT-BAT.
LOOK AT THIS SEEING EYE DOUBLE
THAT HE PRODUCED IN OUT NUMBER
TWO IN THE SECOND INNING.
SHOWING OFF THE ELITE
HARD-HITTING CONTACT,
TOP-OF-THE-LINE SPEED, HE'S ALSO
A GOLD GLOVE DEFENDER OUT AND
CENTER.
THE SEVENTH FASTEST IN TERMS OF
SPEED -- PRINT SPEED IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE.
JUST SHY OF 29 FEET PER SECOND.
THAT IS BLAZING SPEED.
HE COULD DO IT ALL.
HE GOES AFTER THE FIRST PITCH
AND HE FINDS OPEN SPACE ON THE
RIGHT SIDE.
J.P. MOROSI, WHAT ELSE COULD YOU
ADD TO THE VIBRANT DISPLAY OF
SKILLS THAT BYRON BUXTON BRINGS
TO THE TABLE EVERY DAY?
J.P.: FIRST OF ALL IS THE FOURTH
INNING AND BUXTON IS NOW A
TRIPLE SHY OF THE CYCLE.
A DEVELOPING STORY TO SAY THE
LEAST.
I LOVED A RECENT COLUMN WRITTEN
BY JIM SUEHAN.
HE SAID BUXTON'S UPSIDE LOOK
SOMETHING LIKE THE SISTINE
CHAPEL, ONE OF MY FAVORITE LINES
I'VE EVER READ.
ALSO, HE SAID BUXTON COULD BE
THE MOST EXCITING TWIN SINCE
YOUR FORMER TEAMMATE, KIRBY
PUCKETT, YOUR THOUGHTS?
LATROY: JIM AND I GO WAY BACK,
25 YEARS.
THERE IS A CENTER FIELDER IN
BETWEEN POCKET AND BUXTON.
HIS NAME IS TORII HUNTER.
WE HAVE TO THROW TOREY IN THE
MIX.
TORI WAS ABSOLUTELY EXCITING.
HE WASN'T AS FAST AS BUXTON.
HE JUMPS HE GOT ON BASEBALLS, HE
MADE UP FOR SPEED WITH HIS
ABILITY TO GET GREAT JUMPS.
SCOTT: I WILL PERHAPS BLOW YOUR
MIND.
SAM HENTGES IS THE NEW PITCHER
FOR CLEVELAND, HE IS A TWINS FAN
GROWING UP.
HIS FAVORITE PLAYER WAS TORII
HUNTER.
LATROY: WHAT IS THE ABOUT 6'10"?
SCOTT: HE'S GOT SOME SERIOUS
HEIGHT.
MADE HIS MLB DEBUT ON APRIL 20.
LOT OF ACTION COMING AT YOU.
FOUR STRIKEOUTS, HE'S OUT OF
MOUNDSVILLE HIGH SCHOOL IN
MINNESOTA.
LISTED AT 6'6".
HE LOOKS 6'10" WHEN YOU'RE
WATCHING HIM ON THE SCREEN.
LATROY: THAT'S A LOT OF LEGS AND
A LOT OF ARMS COMING OUT A
HITTER FROM THE RIGHT SIDE.
THE BALL IS GETTING ON TOP OF
YOU VERY FAST.
HOW DID YOU LIKE OR DID NOT LIKE
TO FACE LEFTIES LIKE THIS?
JIM: I DID NOT LIKE TO FACE GUYS
THIS TALL, ESPECIALLY
LEFT-HANDED.
IT WAS JUST UNCOMFORTABLE.
RANDY JOHNSON THROUGH VERY HARD
-- THREW VERY HARD.
UNLESS THEY ARE STRAIGHT OVER
THE TOP, IF THAT ARM DROPS A
LITTLE BIT, IT IS A TOUGH AT-BAT
ON A LEFT-HANDER.
THE SIZE HERE DEFINITELY STANDS
OUT FOR ME.
SCOTT: HE GETS THE DOUBLE PLAY
BALL THAT HE NEEDS.
PLENTY OF TIME TO TOSS TO
SECOND.
TWO ELSEWHERE NELSON CRUZ -- TWO
OUTS FOR NELSON CRUZ.
JIM, ARE YOU OK WITH THAT?
JIM: I ALWAYS ASK THIS -- YOU
NEVER KNOW WHAT A GUY IS DEALING
WITH INJURY-WISE.
THE FIRST QUESTION I LIKE TO ASK
IS, HAVE YOU DEALT WITH
INJURIES?
ARE YOUR LOWER EXTREMITIES, ARE
THEY BOTHERING YOU?
WHAT I ASK IS LOOK, IF YOU ARE
60 AND YOU CAN ROUND 70%, GIVE
ME 70 OF YOUR BEST 70%.
I DO NOT REALLY WANT TO COMMENT
AND NOT REALLY KNOW AT THE END
OF THE DAY.
DONALDSON HAS PLAYED REALLY HARD
OVER HIS CAREER, AND HE HAS BEEN
A FABULOUS PLAYER.
I LIKE TO KNOW THE INFORMATION.
LOOK, IF A GUY IS 100%, GIVE ME
95-100%.
I ALWAYS WANT TO KNOW AND SEE
WHAT A GUY IS DEALING WITH.
SCOTT: THAT IS FAIR.
HE IS COMING OFF RIGHT HAMSTRING
STRAIN, 10 DAYS OFF THE IL
NELSON CRUZ, THAT WAS 109 MILES
AN HOUR.
CREATES ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE TWINS WITH TWO OUTS.
JORGE POLANCO WITH A HOME RUN IN
HIS POCKET FROM THE FIRST
INNING.
LATROY: I WANT TO GO BACK TO THE
DONALDSON -- HE HAS HAD SO MANY
LOWER EXTREMITY ISSUES WITH HIS
CALF AND THE HAMSTRING.
THE HAMSTRING ON HIS FIRST
AT-BAT ON A DOUBLE BETWEEN FIRST
AND SECOND BASE.
I HARD-HIT BALL -- A HARD-HIT
BALL, I DO NOT MIND HIM TAKING
THAT PARTICULAR RUN FROM HOME TO
FIRST OFF.
HE HAS HAD SOME ISSUES WITH HIS
LOWER EXTREMITIES.
HE HAS WORKED VERY HARD TO GET
BACK TO WHERE HE IS TODAY.
I AM SURE HE DOES NOT WANT TO
SET HIMSELF BACK WITH TRYING TO
BEAT OUT A HARDBALL THAT IS
GOING TO BE A 543 DOUBLE PLAY --
5-4-3 DOUBLE PLAY.
SCOTT: A ROBINSON CANO
SITUATION.
HE WOULD PUT TOGETHER A FULL
SEASON OF WORK EVERY YEAR.
THAT ONE LOOKS LIKE IT HURTS FOR
JORGE POLANCO.
LATROY: THAT GOES BACK TO
MACHADO, THE STATEMENT HE MADE.
WHEN HE WAS A FREE AGENT, HE GOT
CRUCIFIED ABOUT IT, NOT RUNNING
HARD TO FIRST BASE.
YOU CANNOT DO IT EVERY DAY.
YOU DO NOT KNOW WHAT A PERSON,
HOW HIS BODY IS FEELING.
YOU CAN SAVE THAT ENERGY FOR
WHEN YOU HIT ONE IN THE GAP THAT
MIGHT BE A SINGLE BUT YOU'RE
PUSHING IT TO BE A DOUBLE.
SAVE THAT ENERGY FOR THAT AT-BAT
WHEN YOU CAN GET TO SECOND BASE.
SCOTT: POLANCO LAYS OFF.
THE PREVIOUS PITCH WAS OFF THE
RIGHT THIGH.
IF HE IS DOING ANY SQUATS THIS
WEEK, HE IS REALLY GOING TO FEEL
IT.
JIM: YEAH, THERE IS NO DOUBT.
THAT IS THE LITTLE THINGS OF
BASEBALL THAT AS YOU PLAY THIS
GAME, FOUL BALLS, WHAT CATCHERS
GO THROUGH, WHAT MIDDLE
INFIELDERS GO THROUGH, IT ALL
ADDS UP.
THAT IS WHY -- LATROY, YOU CAN
ATTEST TO THIS -- AS A NEXT
PLAYER YOU REALLY RESPECT -- AS
AN EX-PLAYER, YOU REALLY RESPECT
HOW THESE GUYS GO OUT AND PLAY.
THEY ARE STARTING TO GET LITTLE
DINGS HERE AND THERE.
THE MENTALLY TOUGH ONES, YOU
KNOW, THEY SURVIVE IN THE END.
SCOTT: SAM HENTGES WITH A LITTLE
PAINT TO GET OUT OF THE FRAME
UNSCATHED.
MIDDLE OFOURTH.
WE TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT TRISTON
MCKENZIE IN THIS INFIELD CHATTER
FUTURE.
>> REMEMBER THIS VIDEO?
WE WILL COME BACK TO IT IN A
MOMENT.
WE HAVE TO TELL THE STORY OF
THIS FRIEND.
>> HE SENT ME A COOL PHOTO FROM
UP THERE.
>> THIS IS TRISTON MCKENZIE.
ON AUGUST 20 SECOND, HE MADE HIS
MAJOR, SIX INNINGS, ONE RUN, 10
STRIKEOUTS.
>> HE IS A REALLY OUTGOING GUY.
>> THIS IS NOLAN JONES,
CLEVELAND'S NUMBER ONE PROSPECT.
LAST WINTER, JONES WAS REHABBING
IN ARIZONA.
SO WAS MCKENZIE.
>> HE HAS BATTLED SOME INJURIES.
>> WHICH BRINGS US BACK TO THE
VIDEO.
ONE FRIEND ON THE MOUND AT
PROGRESSIVE FIELD IN CLEVELAND,
THE OTHER ACROSS THE STREET AT
-- A TOP A PARKING GARAGE
DETERMINED TO BE THERE EVEN
THOUGH HE WAS NOT ALLOWED IN.
>> I KNEW WHERE I WAS GOING TO
BE AT 7:00 FOR HIS DEBUT.
>> THE PICTURE HE SENT ME.
A REAL KINDHEARTED FRIEND.
SCOTT: FOUR HOMERS.
EACH WEEK THE SEASON ARE
BROADCAST, WE WILL FOCUS ON
YOUTUBE CONTENT CREATOR.
TODAY, OUR CREATOR SPOTLIGHT
SHINES ON ZACH HAMPLE.
OVER 11,000 BASEBALLS CAUGHT
AROUND MAJOR LEAGUE BALLPARKS.
THAT IS AN INCREDIBLE NUMBER.
IF YOU WOULD HAVE TOLD ME OVER
100, I WOULD HAVE SAID THAT IS A
LOT.
OVER 11,000 IS WHY HE HAS A
YOUTUBE CHANNEL THAT IS SO
SUCCESSFUL.
WE HEARD FROM HIM EARLIER.
IF YOU HAVE A QUESTION, GIVE US
SOMETHING GOOD.
HE CAUGHT ALEX RODRIGUEZ 3000
HIT.
HE CAUGHT MIKE'S FIRST CAREER
HOME RUN -- MIKE TROUT'S FIRST
CAREER HOME RUN.
CAN YOU IMAGINE CATCHING OVER
11,000 BASEBALLS AROUND A
BALLPARK?
JIM: THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
SCOTT: THERE IS A SCIENCE TO IT
WHERE HE KNOWS THE PERFECT SPOTS
WHERE FOUL BALLS WILL ALSO --
WILL OFTEN END UP.
THIS GUY IS JUST CHILLING.
HE IS NOT GOING TO MOVE.
RAMIREZ GOING FOR IT, BUT IT IS
FOUL.
ZACH HAMPLE SUFFERED A SPILL
GOING FOR EIGHT FOUL BALL.
APRIL 19, DOES NOT SICK THE
LANDING.
-- DOES NOT STICK THE LANDING.
THAT HAS A LOT OF VIEWS ON
YOUTUBE.
LATROY: I DO NOT THINK MOST
PEOPLE REALLY UNDERSTAND THE
DEDICATION THAT HE HAS TO GO
AROUND THE COUNTRY TO DIFFERENT
BALLPARKS, TO BE ABLE TO CATCH
THOSE BALLS.
THAT TAKES DEDICATION, A LOT OF
DEDICATION.
SCOTT: IT IS A FULL-TIME JOB.
HE HAS BEEN TO OVER 60 PARKS.
ONE DOWN.
JOSE RAMIREZ IS RETIRED.
WHICH CURRENT PLAYER HAS THE
BEST NICKNAME?
LA TORTUGA WINS THE SHOW.
POLAR BEAR PICKING UP 21% OF THE
PIE.
FAVORITE OF THESE FOUR, JIM
THOME?
JIM: I LIKE FRANIMAL.
IT SEEMS LIKE HE IS GOING TO
HURT A BASEBALL AND LOOK AT HOW
BIG HE IS.
I LOVE THAT NICKNAME.
IT MATCHES HIM PERFECTLY.
SCOTT: WHAT ABOUT YOU, LATROY?
LATROY: I AM A FAN OF LA
TORTUGA, THE TURTLE.
SCOTT: THAT IS A GOOD ONE.
LATROY: HE IS JUST THE GUY ON
THE TEAM ALWAYS HAVING A GOOD
TIME.
HE IS MAKING SURE ANYBODY ELSE
IN HIS PRESENCE IS HAVING A GOOD
TIME AS WELL.
SCOTT: HE PUTS ON A SHOW, RARELY
STRIKES OUT.
FOUR HOMERS IN HIS LAST SIX.
HIS TEAM NEEDS SOME HELP.
THEY TRAIL BY SIX RUNS.
TWO OUTS, BOTTOM OF THE FOURTH.
WE ARE PUMPED TO BE JOINING YOU,
A GLOBAL AUDIENCE WITH US TODAY
ON YOUTUBE.
LATROY: EDDIE ROSARIO, FORMER
TWINS LEFT FIELDER FOR THE LAST
FIVE YEARS.
NOT TENDERED AND SIGNED WITH THE
CLEVELAND BALLCLUB.
WHEN YOU GET TRADED OR SIGN WITH
THE IN DIVISION RIVAL, THERE IS
A LOT OF BUILT UP ANGER, I AM
SURE, YOU WANT TO DO SO WELL
AGAINST YOUR FORMER TEAM.
SCOTT: HE DESCRIBED IT IN MORE
KIND WAY BY SAYING, IT IS LIKE
GOING UP AGAINST -- SEEING YOUR
EX FOR THE FIRST TIME.
YOU WANT TO BE WELL-DRESSED AND
HAVE YOUR BEST DAY AND SHOW THEM
WHAT THEY ARE MISSING.
LATROY: I AM SURE HE IS WAITING
TO GO DEEP SO HE CAN DO A
SOMERSAULT, FLIP HIS BAT.
I AM SURE HE WILL DO ALL OF
THOSE THINGS.
SCOTT: THIS IS ANOTHER GUY WHO
SWINGS AT JUST ABOUT ANYTHING
AND SOMETIMES, TO HIS
DISADVANTAGE, PITCHERS WORKED
OUTSIDE OF THE ZONE AGAINST
ROSARIO.
DO YOU THINK THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT CAN DEVELOP EVEN FOR A
PLAYER THAT IS THIS LATE INTO
HIS CAREER?
IT MIGHT CHANGES GAME TOO MUCH?
JIM: I THINK HE CAN DEVELOP.
WATCH THE TWO SWINGS.
THEY WERE OUT OVER THE PLATE
SLIDERS.
HIS BACK SIDE IS FALLING AWAY.
HOPEFULLY, HE WILL MAKE THAT
ADJUSTMENT AS HE GETS MORE
EXPERIEN IS 0-2 TODAY.
CLEVELAND DOWN BY SIX AFTER
FOUR.
WE ARE LIVE ON YOUTUBE.
>> WELCOME TO GAME ONE OF THE
WORLD SERIES.
>> ATLANTA --
>> 14-5.
>> HE CAUGHT IT.
>> LEAPS IN THE AIR AND MAKES
THE CATCH.
>> INTO DEEP LEFT CENTER.
WE WILL SEE YOU TOMORROW NIGHT.
>> PERFECT PITCHING MATCHUP.
>> SWINGS AND MISSES AND DOWN HE
GOES.
FIVE MORE INNINGS TO PLAY.
ATLANTA, NOTHING.
MINNESOTA, NOTHING.
>> BOTTOM OF THE 10TH INNING, NO
SCORE.
>> THE TWINS ARE GOING TO WIN
THE WORLD SERIES.
SCOTT: WE HAVE REACHED THE
FIFTH.
TWINS, SEVEN.
CLEVELAND, ONE.
NELSON CRUZ PROVIDING A LITTLE
VERBAL ASSISTANCE TO OUR YOUTUBE
BROADCAST.
CAULKS I KNOW SOMETHING THAT YOU
DO NOT KNOW -- >> I KNOW
SOMETHING THAT YOU DO NOT KNOW.
>> WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
SAY FAIR, SAY FAIR, SAY FAIR.
LA TORTUGA.
SCOTT: MITCH GARVER BLASTS THE
BASEBALL, AND IT IS GONE.
WOW.
ON CUE.
I CANNOT WAIT TO HEAR WHAT
NELSON CRUZ SAID ON THAT ONE.
YOU CAN SEE HIM CELEBRATING IN
THE DUGOUT.
GARVER, AFTER TWO STRIKEOUTS,
LAST SOFT FOR HIS THIRD OF THE
SEASON.
-- BLASTS OFF FOR HIS THIRD OF
THE SEASON.
LATROY: HE WAS ABLE TO GET THE
BARREL TO THAT BALL AND HIT IT
OFF THE FACING OF THE EXIT GATE
IN LEFT FIELD.
SCOTT: THAT IS A BOMB, GUYS.
THAT IS A BOMB.
HE IS GOING TO GET HOT.
YOU WATCH.
HE IS TOO GOOD OF A PLAYER AND
SOMETHING LIKE THAT CAN GET YOU
GOING FROM HERE ON OUT.
WHAT A TALENTED HITTER.
I KNOW HE HAS NOT STARTED OFF
LIKE HE HAS WANTED, BUT THAT IS
NICE TO SEE HIM GET A GOOD SWING
LIKE THAT.
SCOTT: 413 FEET OFF THE BAT OF
MITCH GARVER.
THAT IS A HOME RUN IN ANY
BALLPARK.
GOBBLED UP BY RAMIREZ.
LATROY: THIS IS A VERY SPECIAL
DAY.
HE IS PITCHING AGAINST HIS
HOMETOWN TEAM.
FACING SOME OF THE PLAYERS HE
WATCHED GROWING UP, LIKE NELSON
CRUZ.
SCOTT: TORTUGA COMING OFF THE
HOME RUN IN THE THIRD.
WE HEARD CRUZ TALK ABOUT THAT
ONE.
WE WILL GET THE WORD FROM NELSON
CRUZ AFTER THE NEXT PITCH.
>> WOO-HOO!
SCOTT: A GREAT POINT.
YOU HIT IN THE WEST FOR A LONG
TIME.
ROSARIO RECORDS THE OUT.
IT IS COLD IN THE MIDWEST IN
APRIL.
THE WEATHER REALLY HEATED UP
FROM YESTERDAY'S FIRST PITCH AT
ABOUT 82 DEGREES AND THE TWINS
ARE HEATING UP WITH IT.
JIM: YOU PLAY IN CHICAGO,
MINNESOTA, CLEVELAND, YOU CANNOT
WAIT FOR MAY TO GET HERE,
ESPECIALLY THE FIRST 75 DEGREES
OR 80 DEGREES DAY.
IT KIND OF REVIVES YOU.
THE BALL STARTS CARRYING A
LITTLE BETTER AS YOU GET INTO
MAY AND JUNE AND THROUGHOUT THE
SUMMER.
I KNOW THESE GUYS ARE PROBABLY
REALLY EXCITED TO FINALLY GET
SOME GOOD WEATHER.
SCOTT: FIVE HOMERS TODAY FOR THE
TWINS.
AFTER THREE HOME RUNS IN THE
PREVIOUS FOUR GAMES, ALL LOSSES.
DONALDSON WITH ONE OF THEM.
BUXTON, POLANCO, GARVER, AND
ASTUDILLO.
NELSON CRUZ HAS TO GET INVOLVED.
THIS ONE FOR ROSARIO ON THE
MOVE, AND HE MAKES THE PLATE.
THREE GROUND BALL OUTS.
BEFORE THAT, MITCH GARVER
LEADING OFF WITH ANOTHER ONE.
NO DOUBT ABOUT IT, THE TWINS ARE
UP 8 IN CLEVELA♪
>> >> TOUCHES THE BILL OF THE
CAP, RUBS HIS SLEEVE.
>> GOT HIM TO CHASE A FASTBALL
AWAY.
>> A CAREER-HIGH 13 STRIKEOUTS.
>> STRIKE THREE CALLED.
>> HE GOT HIM ON THREE PITCHES.
GOOD MORNING, GOOD AFTERNOON,
AND GOOD NIGHT.
>> 11 STRIKEOUTS FOR CLIFF LEE.
>> THE NASTIEST GUY I SAW WAS
COREY KLUBER.
>> KLUBER STRIKES HIM OUT.
>> THE CY YOUNG WINNER IN THE
AL, COREY KLUBER.
>> SWING AND A MISS.
>> STRUCK HIM OUT.
>> 2020 AMERICAN LEAGUE CY YOUNG
AWARD WINNER, SHANE BIEBER.
>> SHANE BIEBER.
HE GOT ALL 31ST-PLACE VOTES.
-- ALL 30 FIRST-PLACE VOTES.
SCOTT: NEW TO THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK, IT IS THE YOUTUBE
PLAYER OF THE GAME.
IF YOU ARE WATCHING, MOBILE
DEVICE, COMPUTER, HOWEVER YOU
ARE WATCHING, VOTE FOR THE
PLAYER WHO SHOULD RECEIVE THE
TROPHY DURING THE POSTGAME SHOW.
WE WILL CHAT WITH THAT PLAYER
AFTER THE GAME.
YOU GET TO DECIDE.
STAY TUNED FOR THE PLAYER OF THE
GAME PULLING OPTIONS COMING UP
IN A FEW INNINGS.
AMED ROSARIO WITH A HOME RUN IN
HIS FIRST AT-BAT OF THE DAY BACK
IN THE SECOND.
J.A. HAPP STARTING TO GET ON A
LITTLE RUN.
HE HAS RETIRED EIGHT IN A ROW.
WORKING WITH A NICE ADVANTAGE,
GIVEN UP JUST THAT ONE RUN.
THAT IS THE ONLY BLEMISH.
HE IS COMING OFF A LOT OF NO-HIT
BASEBALL AGAINST PITTSBURGH.
BRENT ROOKER LINED IT UP BUT IT
IS OFF THE GLOVE.
ROSARIO IS INTO SECOND.
>> ROSARIO TRYING TO HIT THE
BALL TO THE OPPOSITE FIELD.
THAT WAS A GREAT ATTEMPT BY
ROOKER.
THE BALL POPPED OUT OF HIS
GLOVE.
SCOTT: HE HAS HAD A NICE DAY AT
THE PLATE.
ROOKER WAS THERE.
THE SLIDE, THE COVERAGE, JUST
OFF THE GLOVE.
JIM: HE CAME A LONG WAY, AND IT
WAS A HECK OF A TRY, TO BE
HONEST.
HE WENT INTO THAT GRAVEL AREA
OUT THERE AND THAT WAS A GOOD
TRY TO GET IT.
ROSARIO STAYED ON THE BALL NICE,
SHOT IT THE OTHER WAY AGAIN.
WHAT A NICE APPROACH FOR HIM IN
HIS TWO AT-BATS TODAY.
SCOTT: ROSARIO HAS A TON OF
SPEED.
THIS HIT COULD DRIVE HIM HOME.
THE TWO MAJOR LEAGUE PLAYERS
THAT COME ALONG IN THE DEAL WITH
FRANCISCO LINDOR AND CARLOS
CARRASCO.
ALONG WITH TWO PROSPECTS.
A STRIKE DOWN THE PIPE TO
NAYLOR.
LATROY: I HAVE SEEN A LOT OF
GAMES HERE AT PROGRESSIVE FIELD
AND I CANNOT REMEMBER EVER
SEEING THE BALL HIT OFF THE
FACING IN LEFT FIELD.
I HAVE SEEN SOME HIT UP THE
BLEACHERS.
I CANNOT REMEMBER SEEING ONE HIT
OFF THE FACING GOING OUT OF THE
EXIT.
JIM: ESPECIALLY IN FAIR
TERRITORY.
I HAVE SEEN GUYS HIT IT FOUL,
BUT NEVER EVEN HIT THAT.
IT WILL GO WHERE THE LITE SIGN
IS.
NEVER HIT THAT FACING.
I HAD ALWAYS WONDERED, WOULD
SOMEBODY EVER CLEAR THAT?
I HAVE NEVER SEEN IN ALL MY
YEARS IN CLEVELAND.
I HAVE SEEN MANNY GO WAY, WAY UP
WHERE REYES WENT LAST NIGHT AND
I HAVE SEEN SOME -- I SAW
MCGWIRE HIT THE SCOREBOARD ONE
NIGHT.
NOTHING DOWN THE LINE LIKE
GARVER DID TODAY.
LATROY: PRETTY IMPRESSIVE SHOT.
SCOTT: NOTHING FROM MIKE NAPOLI
TO THAT DISTANCE IN HIS DAYS?
JIM: YOU KNOW, I DO NOT KNOW,
SCOTTY.
NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE.
WE WOULD HAVE TO ASK SOMEBODY --
INDIANS OFFICIALS.
I DO NOT REMEMBER, TO BE HONEST.
EVER A BALL GOING OFF THAT
FACADE OR FACING.
SCOTT: THIS IS YOUR BALLPARK.
190 HOME RUNS AT PROGRESSIVE,
MORE THAN ANY OTHER CLEVELAND
PLAYER.
JIM: I WAS FORTUNATE.
I HAD A LOT OF REALLY GOOD
HITTERS IN THE 1990'S.
IT WAS SO MUCH FUN.
WE PLAYED THE TWINS.
THE WHITE SOX WERE IN OUR
DIVISION.
THEY HAD SOME GOOD OFFENSE.
SUCCESS IS WHAT IS AROUND YOU AS
WELL.
IT IS CONTAGIOUS.
WHEN ONE GUY GOES, YOU CAN ALL
GO.
THAT IS WHAT I REMEMBER OF OUR
CLEVELAND TEAMS IN THE 1990'S.
WE PLAYED THE GAME HARD AND WHEN
GUYS WOULD GET ON A ROLL AND THE
WEATHER WOULD START HEATING UP,
WE LOVED TO HIT IN THIS
BALLPARK.
SCOTT: I LOVE THE STATUTE.
THERE IS SANDY ALOMAR JUNIOR.
SOME SUCCESSFUL CLEVELAND
SQUADS.
WE SAW YU CHANG GROUND OUT AND
BRING HOME AMED ROSARIO.
IT IS 8-2.
THERE IS THE LONGTIME COACH
HERE.
LATROY: WHEN YOU GUYS HAD ALL OF
THOSE CONSECUTIVE SELLOUTS AND
WE COULD NOT GET A WIN IN THIS
BALLPARK.
WE COULD NOT GET A WIN AT
PROGRESSIVE.
THAT ENERGY FROM THE FANS IN
CLEVELAND ALWAYS FOUND A WAY TO
PREPARE -- PROPEL YOU GUYS OVER
US.
IT WAS IMPRESSIVE AND AT THE
SAME TIME, IT WAS PRETTY
INTIMIDATING.
SCOTT: BYRON BUXTON USES HIS
HAND TO MEASURE THE WALL AND
MAKES THE CATCH.
AUSTIN HEDGES GOES DOWN.
CLEVELAND DOES GET A RUN.
BETTER THAN THIS
GUY.
JIM THOME WITH US TODAY ON
YOUTUBE.
>> FIRST AND THIRD, THE ROOKIE
KAPLER.
>> SWING AND A, BACK GOES.
HIS FIRST MAJOR LEAGUE HOMER IS
A WALKOFF.
>> TWO DOWN.
>> CLOBBERED AND CRUSHED.
>> 3-3 TIE, BOTTOM OF THE 17TH
INNING.
>> A WALKOFF WINNER IN 17
INNINGS.
>> TWO OUTS, 6-6 GAME.
>> A WALKOFF WIN AND IT IS
KAPLER DELIVERING AGAIN.
>> A LINER TO LEFT FIELD.
EDDIE IS AROUND THIRD.
>> 1-0 PITCH.
BASE HIT, HERE COMES LOUIS, AND
THE TWINS WALK IT OFF.
>> THAT IS THE SIXTH TIME HE HAS
DONE THAT.
SCOTT: ALL SEASON LONG, MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL WILL HONOR FRONT
AND ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO
CONTINUE TO LIFT UP THEIR FELLOW
CITIZENS DURING THE PANDEMIC.
THANK YOU, FRONTLINE HEROES.
SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE.
JOIN THE TEAM AND GET THE
VACCINE TO HELP US GET BACK TO
DOING WHAT WE LOVE TOGETHER.
THAT IS THE STAGE GETTING SET UP
FOR THE NFL DRAFT.
JP, YOU ARE BUSY OUT THERE.
I KNOW THERE IS ALSO A LOT OF
ACTION AROUND TOWN.
J.P.: LET'S HOPE THESE
FOREBODING SKIES HOLD OFF.
I AMSINGER BIT MORE GRAY THAN I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
-- I AM SEEING A BIT MORE GRAY
THAN I WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
I KEEP THINKING ABOUT HOW LUCKY
WE HAVE BEEN THIS MONTH, WHETHER
IT IS OHTANI, VLAD JR., TATIS,
ACUNA.
HOW MUCH YOUNG TALENT ONTO THE
GAME TODAY.
SCOTT: SUPERSTARS ALL WITH
UNIQUE PROFILES.
BYRON BUXTON BRINGS THE SPEED
AND POWER AND DEFENSIVE
EXCELLENCE.
HE IS GUARANTEED AT LEAST TWO
MORE AT-BATS.
ALEX KIRILLOFF BEHIND IN THE
COUNT 1-2.
LATROY: LOOKING FORWARD TO
BUXTON HAVING TWO MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO HIT IT FOR THE
CYCLE.
SCOTT: WOULD YOU RATHER HAVE A
CYCLE OR A TWO HOMER GAME?
JIM: I WOULD RATHER GO CYCLE, NO
DOUBT.
THE CYCLE, YOU ARE GETTING FOUR
HITS.
IS IT A TWO-HIT HOMER GAME?
I WOULD RATHER HAVE THE HITS AT
THE END OF THE DAY.
SCOTT: CAROL OFF DOWN ON
STRIKES.
-- KIRILLOFF DOWN ON STRIKES.
BUXTON, FIRST BATTER OF THE GAME
AND HE CONNECTS TO THE OPPOSITE
FIELD.
BYRON BUXTON, SO IT IS NOT A
BASE HIT.
IT IS TWO BAGS.
IN THE FOURTH, YOUR AVERAGE
SINGLE.
SO MUCH SPEED.
HIS FEET MOVE FASTER THAN WHAT
HE IS THINKING SOMETIMES.
THE QUICKNESS IS OFF THE CHARTS
FROM THE TWINS LEADOFF BATTER,
WHO CHASES STRIKE ONE.
LOOK AT THE LAST FIVE CYCLES IN
TWINS FRANCHISE HISTORY AS BYRON
IS A TRIPLE AWAY.
JORGE POLANCO PULLED IT OFF BACK
IN 2019.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO GO BACK A
DECADE BEFORE THAT.
LATROY: MICHAEL CUDDYER IS ON
THAT LIST.
JIM: CUDDY, ONE OF MY FAVORITE
TEAMMATES EVER.
LOVE MICHAEL.
PLAYED THE GAME THE RIGHT WAY.
GREAT AMBASSADOR FOR THE TWINS
ORGANIZATION.
TORII HUNTER.
SO MANY.
MAUER, YOU GUYS PLAYED THE GAME
THE RIGHT WAY.
I WAS THERE A VERY SHORT PERIOD
BUT ALWAYS RESPECTED HOW THAT
ORGANIZATION BROUGHT ALL YOU
GUYS UP AND HOW YOU GREW INTO
GREAT YOUNG MEN.
SCOTT: BUCK'S -- BUXTON IS GOING
TO PULL OFF AN INFIELD SINGLE.
BOY, CAN HE MOVE.
LATROY: HERNANDEZ HOW TO STAY
BACK ON THAT BALL.
HE SHOULD NOT HAVE EVEN THROWN
IT BECAUSE WHEN THE BALL HIS HIT
ON THE GROUND, OXEN IS WIDE OPEN
-- BUXTON IS WIDE OPEN.
TENDINITIS IN THE PATELLA,
HAMSTRING, WHATEVER HE IS --
WHATEVER IS GOING ON, HE WILL
STILL BE THAT BALL.
SCOTT: WHEN YOU SAY TENDINITIS,
IT GETS ME THINKING ABOUT OUR
CONVERSATION WITH TERRY FRANCONA
THIS MORNING.
JIM: WE WERE ASKING ABOUT BYRON
AND HE HAD A SIMILAR INFIELD
SINGLE LAST NIGHT, AND THERE HE
GOES AGAIN STEALING SECOND BASE.
WE ASKED TERRY ABOUT HIS
ATHLETICISM.
I THOUGHT TO MYSELF, IF HE HAS
GOT TENDINITIS, I WANT IT.
YOU CAN SEE IT THERE, NO SIGNS
OF TENDINITIS FOR BUXTON TODAY.
SCOTT: GIVE ME THAT TENDINITIS.
LOOK AT HIS STOLEN BASE
PERCENTAGE, 88%.
THAT IS BEST AMONG ACTIVE
PLAYERS WITH AT LEAST 50 STOLEN
BAGS.
INCREDIBLE BALLPLAYER.
JOSH DONALDSON FOULS THAT ONE
BACK.
A BALL AND A STRIKE FOR THE
TWINS NUMBER TWO HITTER.
LATROY: YOU HAVE TO TIP YOUR HAT
TO CLEVELAND'S PITCHER.
HE HAS SETTLED THINGS DOWN,
GIVEN THE TEAM THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GET THEMSELVES BACK INTO THIS
GAME.
SCOTT: POPPED UP.
IT IS PLAYABLE FOR YU CHANG.
LOOK AT THE TOP TWO HITTERS IN
THE LINEUP FOR MINNESOTA TODAY
-- TOP THREE, MAKE THAT.
BUXTON, DONALDSON, AND NELSON
CRUZ.
CREATING TRAFFIC AND LITTLE BIT
OF DAMAGE CONTRIBUTING TO THE
EIGHT RUNS.
>> THEY HAVE ALL HAD FABULOUS
AT-BATS ALL DAY, NO DOUBT ABOUT
IT.
LATROY: THE LINEUP WAS
CONSTRUCTED TO DO JUST THIS.
WE KNOW WHAT WE ARE GOING TO GET
FROM NELSON CRUZ.
POLANCO IS A VERY GOOD HITTER.
LOOKS LIKE HE IS STARTING TO
COME AROUND.
HAVING GARVER AND ASTUDILLO,
JUST ADDING TO THAT.
THEY HAVE A SOLID LINEUP FROM
1-9.
THEY HAVE TO CONTINUE TO TAKE
REALLY GOOD AT-BATS AND WHEN THE
PITCHER MAKES MISTAKES, THEY
HAVE TO CAPITALIZE ON THOSE
MISTAKES.
SCOTT: THERE IT IS, YOUR TOP
THREE ERRORS -- TOP THREE
HITTERS.
BUXTON, DONALDSON, CRUZ.
JIM: I AM SURE THAT IS WHAT THEY
WERE HOPING FOR HERE.
THE WEATHER IS STARTING TO HEAT
UP, GET WARMER, AND THE BAT IS
COMING ALIVE.
SCOTT: LET'S BE REAL, IT IS TIME
TO GO.
I KNOW IT IS APRIL AND YOU CAN
SAY DEEP WRATH, THIS DESK DEEP
BREATH, THIS TEAM IS -- DEEP
BREATH, THIS TEAM IS 7-15.
CLEVELAND BRINGS THE EXCELLENT
PITCHING.
IF YOU FALL TOO FAR BEHIND, IN
APRIL, IT CAN SET YOU BACK FOR
THE ENTIRE SEASON, AND THIS IS A
TEAM THAT WON BACK TO BACK A.L.
CENTRAL CROWNS.
NELSON CRUZ IS GOING TO PULL THE
BASEBALL MORE OFTEN THAN NOT.
JIM: NO DOUBT.
YOU CANNOT WIN A CHAMPIONSHIP IN
APRIL BUT YOU DO NOT WANT TO GET
BEHIND TOO MUCH.
YOU COULD LOSE GAMES, BUT YOU
DON'T WANT TO BE CONSISTENT AND
HAVE STREAKY LOSSES.
YOU WANT TO ELIMINATE SCOTT: THE
AWAY THE BAD LOSING TASTE THEY
HAVE HAD LATELY.
UP BIG IN THE SIXTH.
♪
>> WITH THE FIRST SELECTION, THE
WASHINGTON NATIONALS SELECT
BRYCE HARPER.
>> A 19-YEAR-OLD PHENOM BY THE
NAME OF BRYCE HARPER HUSBAND
CALLED UP BY WASHINGTON.
HE WILL BE IN THE STARTING
LINEUP PLAY LEFT FIELD TONIGHT.
>> REACHED UP TO SNARE IT.
A CAREER HAS BEGUN.
COOKS LINE DRIVE -- >> LINE
DRIVE DEEP TO CENTER FIELD.
THE FIRST BIG-LEAGUE HIT FOR
BRYCE HARPER IS A DOUBLE OFF THE
WALL AT DODGER STADIUM.
>> THE NATIONALS TAKE THE LEAD.
>> BRYCE HARPER'S FIRST
BIG-LEAGUE R.B.I.
>> DOESN'T GET ANY BETTER THAN
THIS?
>> WELCOME BACK TO PROGRESSIVE
FIELD WHERE J.A. HAPP LOOKS VERY
COMFORTABLE IN HIS FIRST START
SINCE LAST WEEK'S NO-HIT BID.
J.A. HAPP, 38 YEARS YOUNG WAS IN
DEMAND THE LAST OFF-SEASON.
HE SIGNED A ONE-YEAR DEAL WITH
THE MINNESOTA TWINS.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT LONGEVITY,
WE ARE JOINED BY LATROY AND JIM.
YOUR LENS, THE -- YOUR
LONGEVITY, A MIDWESTERNER.
LATROY: I DEFINITELY THINK BEING
A MULTISPORT ATHLETE HELPS
ATHLETES COMING UP.
NOT RELEGATED TO BEING -- DOING
ONE SPECIFIC SPORT.
MUSCLE MOVEMENT, MUSCLE MEMORY.
YOU ARE USING ALL OF YOUR
MUSCLES FOR BASEBALL,
BASKETBALL, FOOTBALL, TRACK.
THAT HELPED ME EXTEND MY CAREER.
SCOTT: ONE DOWN IN THE BOTTOM OF
THE SIXTH.
LET'S BRING IN A LITTLE AGE 40
POLL ACTION.
NOLAN RYAN, 1987.
RANDY JOHNSON, 2004.
DAVID ORTIZ, 2016.
RESULTS A LITTLE BIT LATER.
I WILL ASK OUR FRIENDS HERE AS
WELL.
JORDAN LUPLOW, NUMBER TWO HITTER
FOR CLEVELAND.
PICK ONE, AGE 40 SEASON, WHO DID
IT BEST?
LATROY: I AM GOING TO GO WITH MY
FRIEND BIG PAPI.
HIS 2016 SEASON AT AGE 40 WAS
THE BEST I HAD SEEN AT THAT
TIME.
SCOTT: HE LED THE MAJORS WITH A
10.21 O.P.S.
I MUST SAY, NELSON CRUZ LOOKS
LIKE HE IS VERY CAPABLE OF
PUTTING TOGETHER NUMBERS LIKE
THAT.
I THINK YOU CAN BOOK NELSON CRUZ
FOR 40 PLUS HOMERS FOR THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS IF HE KEEPS HIMSELF
IN THAT KIND OF SHAPE WITH THAT
KIND OF PRODUCTION WE HAVE SEEN
ON A YEARLY BASIS.
THAT ONE IS THE MOST RECENT FROM
BIG PAPI.
NELSON CRUZ IS PROVIDING THAT
FOR MINNESOTA.
HE IS AN AGELESS WONDER.
JIM: IT IS A TESTAMENT TO HIM ON
HIS CONDITIONING AND THE FACT
THAT HE -- AT THE AGE OF 40, YOU
KNOW THE GAME, KNOW WHAT GUYS
ARE DOING.
I WOULD SAY, GETTING INTO A GOOD
ROUTINE AND UNDERSTANDING THAT
ROUTINE EVERY DAY, WHAT MAKES
YOU SUCCESSFUL, AND THE DAYS YOU
HAVE OFF, RIGHT?
OFF DAYS ARE SO VALUABLE TO
RECOVER AND REST AS YOU GET INTO
YOUR 40'S AND NELSON CRUZ AND
GUYS THAT REACH THAT AGE DO IT
VERY WELL.
SCOTT: WOULD THAT BE YOUR PICK,
TOO, JIM?
ARE YOU GOING TO GO SOMEWHERE
ELSE ON THE BOARD?
JIM: I WOULD SAY ORTIZ.
THAT HERE WAS INCREDIBLE AND
WHAT HE DID, YOU KNOW, AS AN
OFFENSIVE PLAYER WATCHING HIM
WAS SO MUCH FUN.
I AM A BIG PAPI FAN.
I LOVE EVERYTHING ABOUT HIM.
HOW HE REPRESENTED THE GAME.
HE IS A GOOD MAN, GREAT TO KIDS.
ANOTHER GUY THAT REALLY, REALLY
TOOK CARE OF HIMSELF AND HAD
SOME GREAT YEARS.
SCOTT: JOSE RAMIREZ FLIES OUT TO
CENTER FIELD.
I WILL ADD THIS, IF YOU GO WITH
NOLAN RYAN, NOT ABOUT OPTION.
HE LED THE LEAGUE IN E.R.A. AND
STRIKEOUTS THAT YEAR IN HIS AGE
40 SEASON.
AND HE PITCHED SIX MORE SEASONS
AFTER THAT, BY THE WAY.
NOLAN RYAN WOULD BE ON THE LIST.
SCOTT BRAUN, JIM THOME, LATROY
HAWKINS HANGING WITH YOU ON
YOUTUBE.
THIS IS FRANMIL REYES.
HITLESS TODAY BUT THE AVERAGING
-- BUT THE BATTING AVERAGE AT A
CLEAN .300.
SEVEN HOMERS THIS SEASON.
HE LOOKS BETTER THAN EVER.
37 HOME RUNS BACK IN 2019 FOR
FRANIMAL.
25 YEARS OLD.
HE WENT AROUND.
ONE BALL AND TWO STRIKES.
DO YOU SEE ANYONE IN FRANMIL
REYES?
IT IS OK IF YOU DON'T.
IS THERE ANYBODY THAT YOU PLAYED
AGAINST OR THAT WE ARE WATCHING
IN TODAY'S GAME THAT COMPARES TO
REYES?
JIM: I MEAN, NOT REALLY.
WITH HIM, THE SIZE STANDS OUT.
NOT MANY HUMANS LIKE THIS THAT
ARE THIS BIG.
AND THE THING THAT IMPRESSES ME
ABOUT THAT, WHEN YOU LOOK AT HIS
SWING, IT IS VERY SHORT AND
QUICK.
HE WILL HIT THE BALL IN AND HE
CAN SHOOT THE BALL OUT TO RIGHT
CENTER, BUT TO DO IT AT THIS
SIZE IS IMPRESSIVE.
BIG PAPI WAS THIS BIG.
I DO NOT KNOW IF HE WAS THIS
TALL.
THIS KID IS ATHLETIC.
I BET THAT HE CAN DO A LOT OF
THINGS AND BE A GOOD ATHLETE.
SCOTT: CLEVELAND, WHEN
FIELD IS ON OUR POLL.
THE TWINS UP 8-2 IN CLEVELAND.
>> THE BOMBER SQUAD.
>> SOMETHING FUN WE LIKE TO CALL
OURSELVES.
COOKS GARVER -- GARVER, 82 HOMER
NIGHT.
-- A TWO-HOMER NIGHT.
SAVE SOME FOR TOMORROW.
WITH EIGHT HOME RUNS.
>> WE KNOW WHY THEY CALL THEM
THE BOMBA SQUAD.
>> I DO NOT KNOW WHERE THAT
COMES FROM BUT IT IS DEFINITELY
A GOOD ONE.
>> FIVE HOME RUNS FOR THE TWINS
LAST NIGHT AND FIVE MORE THIS
AFTERNOON.
>> GRAND SLAM, BYRON BUXTON.
>> SOLO HOME RUN, THREE RUN
HOMER.
>> MAX KEPLER HAS THREE TONIGHT.
>> A WALKOFF FOR SNOW AND THE
TWINS WIN -- FOR SANO AND THE
TWINS WIN IT.
SCOTT: WE ARE INTO THE SEVENTH,
THE TWINS HAVE FIVE HOME RUNS
AND EIGHT TOTAL ACROSS-THE-BOARD
TODAY.
CLEVELAND WITH JUST TWO.
SHANE BIEBER, LAST YEAR'S CY
YOUNG WINNER, PROVIDING SOME
AUDIO FOR US.
>> GOT ANYTHING
SELF-INCRIMINATING THAT YOU WANT
TO SAY?
>> IS THAT THING ON?
>> WE WON BIG YESTERDAY.
MY LITTLE BRAIN CANNOT HANDLE
ALL THE HANDSHAKES.
SCOTT: A TON OF PERSONALITY FROM
MR. BEAVER.
I LOVE IT -- FROM MR. SHANE
BIEBER.
I LOVE IT AND WE APPRECIATE THE
ACCESS HE IS PROVIDING.
SHANE BIEBER CHOOSING TO SELL
SOME OF HIS -- TELL SOME OF HIS
FRIENDS IN THE DUGOUT THAT HE IS
MIKED UP.
JIM: YOU ALWAYS LOOK IN GUY'S
JERSEY AND GO ARE YOU MICED?
THAT IS A GOOD TEAMMATE.
LATROY: YES, IT IS A GOOD
TEAMMATE.
DO NOT SAY ANYTHING
SELF-INCRIMINATING.
SCOTT: ARE YOU WEARING A WIRE?
IT IS POLANCO, GARVER, AND
ROOKER FOR MINNESOTA.
I MENTIONED FIVE LONG BALLS
TODAY FROM THE TWINS.
SAM HENTGES RETURNS TO THE MOUND
FOR ANOTHER INNING OF WORK.
THAT IS FOULED OFF BY JORGE
POLANCO.
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE CLOUD
TAKES US BACK TO THE FIRST
INNING, TWO-RUN BLAST, 106 MILES
PER HOUR OFF THE BAT.
THE TWINS TAKING ON LEFT FIELD
TODAY AT PROGRESSIVE.
THAT ONE SKIPS BY RAMIREZ AND
ROSARIO.
POLANCO REACHES HERE IN THE
SEVENTH.
JIM: HE HIT HIM A CHANGEUP,
LATROY.
[LAUGHTER]
LATROY: I WAS WONDERING IF YOU
COULD GIVE TWO ERRORS RIGHT
THERE.
RAMIREZ IS USUALLY PRETTY
SUREHANDED.
SCOTT: I HAVE SEEN A BASEBALL
GET PAST TO BALLPLAYERS.
I CANNOT RECALL GOING PAST TWO
BALLPLAYERS THROUGH THEIR LEGS
SPECIFICALLY.
LATROY: PROBABLY A FIRST.
JIM: I THINK RAMIREZ THOUGHT THE
BALL WAS HIT A LITTLE HARDER.
YOU KNOW, AND THEN, THE OTHER
ONE GOT THROUGH.
MAYBE HE COULD NOT SEE IT.
WHO KNOWS?
SCOTT: ROSARIO IS SPLITTING HIS
TIME BETWEEN SHORTSTOP AND
CENTER FIELD THIS YEAR.
MITCH GARVER HOMERED IN HIS LAST
TRIP TO THE PLATE.
GARVER ALSO DOING A NICE JOB
CATCHING J.A. HAPP THIS
AFTERNOON.
WHAT GETS OVERLOOKED ABOUT HIS
2019 31-HOMER SEASON IS THE FACT
THAT HE MADE SIGNIFICANT STRIDES
BEHIND THE PLATE.
HE IS ONE OF THE BEST PITCH
FRAMERS IN MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL
.
CATCHING STRIKES THAT ARE JUST
ON THE EDGE OF THE ZONE AND
STICKING THEM WITH THE GLOVE AND
MAKING SURE HIS STARTING PITCHER
OR RELIEVER GETS THE CALL.
LATROY: GARVER HAS DEFINITELY
WORKED VERY HARD AT BEING A
BETTER CATCHER, FRAMING.
HIS PRESENTATION HAS GOTTEN WAY
BETTER.
HIM CALLING THE GAME HAS GOTTEN
SCOTT: HIM BLASTING HOME RUNS
LOOKS REALLY GOOD TODAY.
MITCH GARVER CIRCA 2019, THERE
HE GOES AGAIN.
IT IS A TWO-HOME RUN PERFORMANCE
.
THE TWINS HAVE A DOUBLE-DIGIT
RUN DAY.
LATROY: GARVER IS VERY GOOD
AGAINST LEFT-HANDED PITCHING.
OUTSTANDING TODAY AGAINST THEM.
HOPEFULLY, THIS STARTS A TREND
OR HE CAN GET BACK TO DRIVING
THE BALL -- WHERE HE CAN GET
BACK TO DRIVING THE BALL OFF OF
LEFT-HANDERS.
JIM: WHAT A NIGHT -- NICE SHORT
SWING.
LOOK, IF YOU CAN GET THROUGH
APRIL -- AND NOBODY WANTS TO
STRUGGLE -- I AM A BIG BELIEVER
THAT A GUY IS WHO HE IS.
GARVER, HE HAS TREMENDOUS POWER.
IT ONLY TAKES ONE GOOD SWING.
I THINK THE FIRST HOMER RELAXED
HIM AND PUT HIM IN POSITION.
NOW HE CAN GO UP THERE AND DIAL
IN ON AN AREA AND HE OBVIOUSLY
DID THAT IN THIS SECOND HOME
RUN.
SCOTT:SIXTH CAREER MULTI-HOMER E
FOR GARVER SINCE THAT 2019 HE
HAD.
♪
>> YOU WANT TO PLAY FOR THOSE
PEOPLE.
>> THAT IS THE BIGGEST PART OF
THE GAME.
>> THEY GIVE US AN EXTRA BOOST.
>> I GREW UP BEING A FAN WHEN I
WAS A KID.
>> THE CHEERS WHEN WE ARE DOING
WELL, THE BOOZE WHEN WE ARE --
THE BOOS WHEN WE ARE NOT DOING
WELL.
>> EVEN THE SMELL OF HOT DOGS
AND STUFF, THE WHOLE ATMOSPHERE
IS WHAT WE NEEDED.
>> IS A GREAT DAY TODAY.
PLAYERS, STAFF, EVERYONE COULD
NOT BE ANY HAPPIER TO WELCOME
YOU BACK TO TARGET FIELD.
>> IS GOING TO BE A VERY SPECIAL
MOMENT FOR US.
SCOTT: YOU CAN GO BEHIND THE
SCENES, WATCH EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEWS AND LEARN MORE ABOUT
YOUR FAVORITE PLAYERS ON THE
MINNESOTA TWINS YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
FOLLOW THE TWINS TODAY.
IF YOU ARE FOLLOWING THE TWINS
BATS TODAY, YOU ARE HAPPY.
FRANCHISE RECORD IS EIGHT.
THEY HAVE A SHOT.
ROOKER BATTING AGAINST NICK
WITTGREN.
WELCOME BACK TO THE BIG-LEAGUE
BALLCLUB.
ACTIVATED FROM THE PATERNITY
LIST TODAY.
HE AND HIS WIFE WELCOMED THEIR
SECOND CHILD, CAMDEN, ON MONDAY.
HE ALSO TURNS 30 YEARS OLD
TOMORROW.
GOING UP AGAINST ROOKER, WHO IS
HITLESS SO FAR THIS AFTERNOON.
THAT PITCH MISSES WIDE.
I FEEL LIKE THE ANSWER WILL BE
YES BECAUSE YOU PLAYED FOR SO
LONG -- DID EITHER OF YOU SPEND
TIME ON THE PATERNITY LIST WHILE
YOU WERE A PLAYER?
LATROY: THEY DID NOT HAVE THE
PATERNITY LIST WHEN JIM AND I
WERE PLAYING THE GAME.
YOU HAD TO RUN HOME, SEE YOUR
KID, AND GET BACK TO THE GAME.
MY DAUGHTER WAS BORN IN AUGUST
16, 2000 01, AND WE WERE AT --
IN CLEVELAND AT THE TIME.
WE SPENT A DAY AND A HALF AND
GOT BACK TO CLEVELAND TO FINISH
THE SERIES.
JIM: FOR ME, MY KIDS ARE
NOVEMBER AND DECEMBER.
I DID NOT HAVE TO LEAVE THE
BALLPARK AND GO.
WE HAD OFF-SEASON BABIES.
SCOTT: YOU TIMED IT WELL.
BRENT ROOKER STRIKES OUT.
ASTUDILLO COMING UP.
HERE IS THE STRIKEOUT PITCH.
LET'S SEND IT TO J.P. MOROSI.
J.P.: FOUR YEARS AGO YESTERDAY,
SPEAKING UP SONS WHO HAVE PLAYED
SPORTS, THE SON OF ONE OF YOUR
TEAMMATES WAS DRAFTED 10TH
OVERALL IN THE NFL DRAFT.
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU TRY TO
CONVINCE HIM TO PLAY BASEBALL.
HOW DID THAT TURN OUT?
LATROY: THAT IS NOT TRUE.
I DID NOT CONVINCE HIM TO PLAY
BASEBALL.
YOU MAKE THE DECISION.
HE WAS GOOD AT BASEBALL,
FOOTBALL.
I THOUGHT HE WAS A BETTER
BASKETBALL PLAYER THAN THE OTHER
TWO SPORTS.
HE TOLD US WHAT HE WANTED TO
PLAY.
WE FULLY SUPPORTED IT.
IT WAS YESTERDAY ON FACEBOOK,
SENT ME A REMINDER THAT IT HAD
BEEN FOUR YEARS SINCE THE DRAFT.
SCOTT: TALKING ABOUT PAT MAHOMES
, SUPERSTAR WITH THE KANSAS CITY
CHIEFS.
LATROY PLAYING WITH HIS FATHER.
THE VIKINGS RECEIVED THE 14TH
PICK THIS YEAR AND THE BROWNS
WILL PICK AT NUMBER 26.
J.P. WILL NOT BE STAYING OUT
THERE FOR THE DRAFT.
WE NEED YOU FOR ANOTHER GAME, I
THINK.
J.P.: HEADING TO ATLANTA
TOMORROW.
SCOTT: THAT WILL BE ON MLB
NETWORK.
10 RUNS FOR THE TWINS.
IF YOU LIKE POWER, BOMBA SQUAD
IS PUTTING ON A SHOW.
ASTUDILLO WITH ONE OF THEM.
THIS IS WILD.
SHALLOW CENTER.
READY FOR THIS STAT?
JIM, YOU WERE A MAN WHO KNEW HOW
TO TAKE A WALK BACK IN YOUR DAY.
WILLIANS ASTUDILLO HAS 10 CAREER
HOME RUNS AND 113 GAMES.
HE HAS SEVEN CAREER WALKS.
MORE HOMERS THAN WALKS.
HE HAS NOT INTO WATCHING
PITCHES.
JIM: NO, NO.
THAT IS OK.
THERE ARE GUYS WHO ARE
AGGRESSIVE AND WANT TO HIT.
WHEN YOU LEAVE THE ON-DECK
CIRCLE, THE GOAL IS TO -- I AM
GOING TO BE READY TO HIT.
THERE ARE CERTAIN GUYS THAT HAVE
A GREAT GIFT AND HE IS ONE OF
THEM.
WHERE THIS IS VALUABLE IS YOU
GET A GUY ON THIRD BASE LESS
THAN TWO OUTS AND WHEN HE COMES
UP, HE IS GOING TO PUT THE BALL
IN PLAY AND MORE THAN LIKELY GET
AN R.B.I. AND A RUN SCORED FOR
THEIR TEAM.
THERE IS THE POSITIVE SIDE OF
PUTTING THE BALL IN PLAY AND HE
IS ONE OF THEM FOR SURE.
SCOTT: THINK ABOUT MAX MUNCY OF
THE DODGERS.
FIVE GAMES, HE HAS WALKED 12
TIMES, FIVE MORE THAN ASTUDILLO
IN THE PAST FEW YEARS.
LATROY: HE DOES NOT STRIKE OUT
THAT OFTEN AS WELL.
HE DOESN'T STRIKE OUT AND HE
IS PUTTING THE BALL IN PLAY.
SCOTT: 16 CAREER STRIKEOUTS,
THAT IS WHAT YOU LOVE.
OUR GUY THAT MAKES CONTACT, PUTS
THE BALL IN PLAY.
DAVID FLETCHER OF THE ANGELS HAS
A SIMILAR SKILL SET.
MICHAEL BRANTLEY HAS BEEN DOING
IT MANY YEARS.
WE NEED MORE LA TORTUGAS IN THE
GAME TODAY.
FUN TO WATCH.
JIM: NO DOUBT THE KID ENJOYS
PLAYING THE GAME.
SO REFRESHING.
SCOTT: SIMMONS TO THE RIGHT
SIDE.
GROUND BALL OUT WILL DO IT FOR
THE SEVENTH.
MITCH GARVER HAS TWO HOME RUNS.
ONE OF THEM ACTUALLY MADE IT TO
THE NFL DRAFT PARTY OUT THERE IN
CLEVELAND.
LET'S STRETCH.
SCOTT: GOOGLE CLOUD HELPING
EMPOWERING STATCAST WITH DEEPER
INSIGHTS INTO THE GAME THEN EVER
BEFORE.
GOOGLE CLOUD, THE OFFICIAL CLOUD
TECHNOLOGY WITH MLB, HELPING US
OUT WITH STATCAST POWERED BY
GOOGLE CLOUD.
THIS IS UNIQUE.
EDDIE ROSARIO LOVES PITCHES OUT
OF THE ZONE.
WE TOOK ALL THE BASEBALLS OUT OF
THE ZONE THAT HE HAS TURNED INTO
KNOCKS.
MOST IN BASEBALL SINCE 2016.
JIM, DO YOU CRINGE BECAUSE YOU
KNEW YOUR ZONE SO WELL AND OFTEN
STAYED WITHIN IT BECAUSE YOU
KNEW YOU COULD PRODUCE THE BEST
CONTACT RESULT?
JIM: YEAH YEAH BUT SCOTTY I
STRUCK OUT A LOT TO BE HONEST.
THERE WERE TIMES I WOULD CHASE.
NICE HIT TO RIGHT FIELD.
SCOTT: HARD CONTACT PAST
POLANCO.
JIM: SO YOU KNOW I THINK YOU GO
THROUGH THE UPS AND DOWNS WHERE
YOU GET INTO CHASE MODE.
OBVIOUSLY, WHEN THE BALL IS IN
THE ZONE, THIS KID WILL SQUARE
IT UP.
HE IS A REALLY GOOD PLAYER.
IT TAKES EXPERIENCE AND TIME.
THE CEILING IS SO HIGH FOR
ROSARIO.
HE LOVES HAVING FUN PLAYING THE
GAME.
IT IS NICE TO SEE HOW HE ATTACKS
THE BASEBALL AND GOES ABOUT IT.
SCOTT: CLEVELAND'S BEST HITTER
TODAY AT THE PLATE.
ROSARIO, HOME RUN AND DOUBLE IN
HIS TRIPS, HE HAS SCORED BOTH OF
THE CLEVELAND RUNS, 10 FOR
MINNESOTA.
HE FOULS THAT ONE BACK.
ANOTHER SLUGGER WHO HITS OUT OF
THE ZONE AND JUST DOESN'T CARE,
JP.
J.P.: ANOTHER PLAYER WHO LIKES
TO SWING THE BAT.
JAVIER BAEZ, 35 STRIKEOUTS, ONE
WALK THE SEASON.
-- THIS SEASON.
WHO, BY THE WAY, STILL RANKS AS
ABOVE AVERAGE BY OBS PLUS.
SCOTT: SHOWING OFF WHAT HE CAN
DO.
SIMMONS MAKES THE CATCH.
OUT 1 IN THE SEVENTH.
LET'S PAY OFF THE POLL.
THE CAR GOING ALONG WITH OUR
CHOICE.
DAVID ORTIZ, 37%, 2016.
I HELPED OUT NOLAN RYAN WITH HIS
1987 NUMBERS, LED BASEBALL IN
STRIKEOUTS, 270.
CLOSE RACE BETWEEN RYAN AND
ORTIZ.
IT IS JOSH NAYLOR.
LET'S GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF WHAT
AGE 40 CAN DO IF YOU ARE ONE OF
THE BEST IN THE WORLD.
RYAN, WINFIELD, HAROLD BAINES,
RICKEY HENDERSON, RANDY JOHNSON,
DAVID ORTIZ.
OFF THE BOARD, LATROY HAWKINS,
.29 3 -- 2.93 E.R.A. WITH THE
METS, AGE 40 SEASON IN 2013.
FOUL BALL.
JIM THOME, 15 HOMERS AND 93
GAMES, .838+ IN '11 AT AGE 40.
YOU PLAYED FOR BOTH TEAMS,
CLEVELAND AND MINNESOTA.
JIM: WE TALKED EARLIER.
WHEN YOU GET TO BE 40, LOOKING
AT THE GUYS THAT HAVE THOSE
GREAT GREAT YEARS, YOU REALLY
RESPECT THEM BECAUSE OF WHAT
THEY DID AT THAT AGE.
I DID NOT PLAY EVERY DAY.
WHEN I DID, YOU KNOW, FOR THE
MOST PART I WAS SUCCESSFUL AND
HAD, I KNEW MY ROLE AT THE AGE
OF WAS IN BUT ALSO KIND OF KNEW
ON MY DAYS OFF TO HELP TAKE CARE
OF MY BODY AND HOW TO APPROACH
PLAYING FOR 4, 5 DAYS A WEEK
INSTEAD OF SEVEN.
SCOTT: JOSH NAYLOR TO LEFT.
DRIFTING OVER, KIRILLOFF MAKES
THE CATCH.
NELSON CRUZ STICKING TO A RACINE
-- TO A ROUTINE.
HE WILL OFTEN LOOK AT VIDEO ON
THE TABLET IN BETWEEN AT-BATS,
WHICH J.D. MARTINEZ DOES SO
WELL, WANTED ACCESS BACK, WHICH
MAKES THE DH SPOT FOR THE RED
SOX A VALUABLE.
J.P.: HOW ABOUT THIS?
JAMIE MOYER WON 105 GAMES IN THE
MAJOR LEAGUES AFTER HIS 40TH
BIRTHDAY.
YOU COULD ARGUE HIS 40'S WHERE
HIS BEST DECADE.
IN FACT, JAMIE MOYER'S LAST GAME
IN THE MAJOR LEAGUES CAME AT THE
AGE OF 49.
LATROY, YOU ARE YOUNGER THAN
THAT.
HOW WAS YOUR RIGHT ARM FEELING
THESE DAYS?
LATROY: NOT SO GOOD.
I REMEMBER WATCHING JAMIE MOYER.
KIRBY USED TO SAY THROW ABOVE OR
BELOW THE SPEED LIMIT.
JAMIE MOYER THROUGH IT BELOW --
THREW IT BELOW THE SPEED LIMIT
AND HE HAD PINPOINT CONTROL.
AMAZING TO WATCH HIM PITCH, AND
YOU SEE HOW SUCCESSFUL HE WAS.
GUYS THROWING 90+ MPH AND HE IS
THROWING NOWHERE CLOSE TO THAT,
MAKING HITTERS LOOK VERY BAD.
SCOTT: ELITE GLOVE AT THE HOT
CORNER PUTS IT AWAY IN THE SIDE
IS RETIRED.
SEVEN, 10-2.
LIVE ON YOUTUBE.
SCOTT: TWINS LEAD 10-2.
DOWNLOAD THE MLB APP TO GET IN
GAME VIDEO HIGHLIGHTS, LIVE
PITCH BY PITCH, STAT LEADER
BOARDS AND MORE ON YOUR FAVORITE
TEAM AND THE REST OF THE LEAGUE.
THIS COPYRIGHTED TELECAST IS
PRESENTED BY THE AUTHORITY OF
THE COMMISSIONER OF BASEBALL AND
MAY NOT BE REPRODUCED OR
RETRANSMITTED IN ANY FORMS AND
ACCOUNTS OF DESCRIPTIONS OF THE
GAME MAY NOT BE DISSEMINATED
WITHOUT EXPRESS WRITTEN CONSENT.
IT IS A WARM DAY AGAIN IN
CLEVELAND.
PRECIPITATION HAS HELD OFF.
THANK YOU MOTHER NATURE, WE
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH.
PHIL MATON, THE 28-YEAR-OLD IS
THE FIFTH PITCHER OF THE DAY FOR
CLEVELAND.
IT WAS NOT LOGAN ALLEN'S DAY.
FEW STARTS IN A ROW NOW HAVE
BEEN ROCKY FOR THE LEFT-HANDER.
THE TWINS WERE ALL OVER HIM.
THREE HOME RUNS IN THE FIRST.
THEY HAVE NOT STOPPED.
SIX HOMER DAY FOR MINNESOTA AND
BOMBAS SQUAD.
ALEX KIRILLOFF, THE NUMBER NINE
HITTER, ROOKIE, 23 YEARS OLD.
LISTEN CAREFULLY.
HE STARTED HIS REGULAR SEASON,
MLB CAREER0-15 UNTIL HIS FIRST
KNOCK ON MONDAY.
HIS FIRST BIG-LEAGUE HIT CAME IN
THE POSTSEASON.
FIRST PLAYER TO DO THAT.
GAME 2, WILD-CARD ROUND LAST
YEAR FOR MINNESOTA, THE TWINS
KNOCKED OUT IN THAT
OPENING-ROUND.
ALEX KIRILLOFF GETTING PLAYOFF
EXPERIENCE, MAKING HIS DEBUT IN
THE POSTSEASON BEFORE THE
REGULAR SEASON.
CAN YOU IMAGINE WHAT THE NERVES
WERE LIKE?
JIM: HAD TO BE INCREDIBLE.
IT SAYS A LOT HOW THE TWINS
ORGANIZATION, WHAT THEY THINK OF
THIS KID, TO PUT HIM OUT THERE
IN A SITUATION IN PLAYOFF
ATMOSPHERE.
THAT HAVE TO BE VERY HIGH ON
HIM.
TO DO THAT -- I CAN ONLY IMAGINE
THE EMOTIONS GOING THROUGH THIS
KID'S HEAD.
SCOTT: THERE IS.
PLAYERS TO MAKE A DEBUT IN THE
POSTSEASON.
ONLY BEEN DONE THREE TIMES.
THE LATEST FROM ALEX KIRILLOFF.
HELLO THERE TO MONTAS HE
APPEARING IN THE -- MONDESI
APPEARING IN THE '15 SERIES FOR
CASEY.
-- KC.
LATROY: HE WAS THE FIRST PLAYER
TO START IN A PLAYOFF.
SCOTT: RIGHT INTO THE FIRE AS HE
BOUNCES OUT.
HE IS 1-4 TODAY.
THIS TEAM IS READY FOR THE SWEET
LEFT-HANDED SWING LINE DRIVE
GUY, USES ALL FIELDS, SUPER
QUICK HANDS, ROCCO BALDELLI AND
COMPANY EXCITED TO HAVE
KIRILLOFF IN THE LINEUP FOR MANY
YEARS TO COME.
LATROY: HE IS SO EVEN KEELED.
HIS DEMEANOR.
BEEN AROUND HIM FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS NOW.
FOUR YEARS.
NEVER TOO HIGH OR TOO LOW.
STRAIGHT ACROSS THE BOARD.
THOSE ARE TRAITS YOU CANNOT PAY
FOR.
SCOTT: WHAT ABOUT THE TRAITS
THAT BYRON BUXTON HAS THIS
AFTERNOON?
FIVE HIT DAY, HANDLES THE
BREAKING STUFF, HIS FIRST CAREER
FIVE HIT PERFORMANCE, ALL SMILES
THIS AFTERNOON.
CONGRATS ON THE MILESTONE.
MANY TO COME FOR YOUNG BYRON
BUXTON, 27 YEARS OLD.
HIS APRIL HAS BEEN FANTASTIC.
JIM: THIS KID I MEAN WE TALKED
EARLIER I MEAN EVERYTHING HE
DOES IS SO IMPRESSIVE.
YOU KNOW IT'S JUST IT'S HE'S
ONLY GOING TO GET BETTER LATROY,
THE SKIES THE LIMIT AND THE
LEAGUE IS GOING TO KNOW ABOUT
THIS GUY.
I KNOW THEY KNOW ABOUT HIM NOW
BUT HE IS GOING TO KEEP SOARING
THROUGH BASEBALL.
IT IS FUN TO WATCH.
SCOTT: FIRST FIVE HIT GAME FOR A
TWIN SINCE C.J. CRON DID IT IN
2019.
I WANT TO HEAR YOUR BEST
THOUGHTS ON BYRON BUXTON AS A
PLAYER AND WHAT HE HAS DONE
TODAY.
WOW, PUTTING ON A SHOW.
JOSH DONALDSON WITH BUXTON AT
SECOND.
THAT IS BACK TO THE PITCHER.
PHIL MATON PUTS HIM AWAY.
NELSON CRUZ STEPPING UP.
HE HAS BEEN STEPPING UP BIG WITH
THE MICROPHONE TODAY TOO.
NELSON: SO AMAZING.
THAT WOULD BE THE STOLEN BASE OF
THE YEAR.
ONE TRIPLE AND THEY DON'T TRUST
ME YET?
I HAVE TO STEAL A BASE?
LET ME FREE, MAN.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: VETERAN CONVERSATIONS
GOING ON WITH NELSON CRUZ, THAT
TRADEMARK PHRASE, LATROY, AFTER
EVERY HOME RUN, WE HAVE BEEN
HEARING IT, HE WILL PROBABLY GO
VIRAL WITH HIS ONE-LINER TO HIS
TWINS TEAMMATES.
LATROY: HE IS LIKE THAT WHEN HE
IS NOT MICROPHONE.
YOU CAN HEAR NELSON ALL OVER THE
FIELD.
HE IS ALWAYS TALKING, ALWAYS
TRYING TO KEEP THE GUYS HYPED
UP, KEEP THE ENERGY GOING.
HE IS NOT JUST SITTING OVER
THERE MINDING HIS OWN BUSINESS.
HE IS MAKING SURE EVERYONE'S
ENGAGED IN KEEPING THE GUYS
LAUGHING.
SCOTT: HE HAS BEEN ENTERTAINING
US TODAY.
HE HAS REACHED THREE TIMES THIS
AFTERNOON.
HE TURNS 41 YEARS OLD.
LATROY: TALK ABOUT BUXTON.
HOW MANY AT-BATS JIM, DOES A
HITTER NEED TO START MAKING
THOSE STRIDES TO REACH HIS
POTENTIAL?
I HAVE HEARD 1500-2000 AT-BATS,
THAT IS WHEN GUYS START TO
FIGURE IT OUT.
HOW MANY?
JIM: YOU KNOW YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT IS ABOUT RIGHT.
I TO GO 1200-1500.
TWO YEARS.
PLAYING A FULL TWO SEASONS IN
THE BIG LEAGUES, I THINK YOU
START TO GET COMFORTABLE.
I THINK YOU ARE STILL MAKING
ADJUSTMENTS.
SOME GUYS IT COMES A LITTLE
QUICKER.
SOME GUYS IT TAKES LONGER.
THERE IS NO TIMETABLE WHEN
SOMEBODY IS GOING TO REACH THEIR
POTENTIAL BUT YOU LOOK -- WITH
BUXTON, LOOK AT THE OVERALL
DYNAMIC OF HIS GAME.
IT IS HARD TELLING HOW MUCH
BETTER THIS GUYS GOING TO GET.
BASEBALL WILL NOTICE QUICKLY.
RIGHT NOW HE IS PUTTING HIMSELF
IN THAT CATEGORY WHERE IF HE
KEEPS IT UP, YOU WILL TALK
M.V.P..
I KNOW IT IS APRIL.
THIS IS IMPRESSIVE TO WATCH.
SCOTT: HE MIGHT EARN HIMSELF
PLAYER OF THE MONTH, .438
BATTING CLIP SO FAR THE SEASON,
LEADS BASEBALL IN SLUGGING
PERCENTAGE, FIVE HITS TODAY.
LATROY, 1444 CAREER AT-BATS,
GETTING RIGHT AROUND TO THAT
SWEET SPOT YOU ARE ALLUDING TO.
NELSON CRUZ WITH A SLOW ROTOR.
HE WILL BE RETIRED.
THE EIGHTH INNING IS CLEAN FOR
TWINS SAY THAT IS ALL RIGHT,
SIX HOMERS, 10 RUNS, HAVE A
DAY.
SCOTT: JOSÉ RAMIREZ STEPPING TO
THE PLATE.
SCOTT: WE ARE IN THE HOME
EIGHTH, CLEVELAND DOWN BY 8.
TO SEE THIS TROPHY, LIVE ON
YOUTUBE COMING UP, PLAYER OF THE
GAME TROPHY.
I LOVE THE WAY THIS WAS
CONSTRUCTED.
SOMEBODY IS GOING TO BE HOLDING
THAT, NOT YOU EDDIE, NOT YOU
NELSON, THERE ARE PLAYERS THAT
HAVE DONE MORE DAMAGE IN TODAY'S
GAME.
THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
YOUR CHOICES TODAY.
CHOOSE FROM ONE OF THESE THREE
MINNESOTA TWINS.
IN THE LIVE CHAT, SECRET BASE,
MITCH GARVER AND BUXTON ARE
HAVING GOOD ONES BUT I WILL TAKE
NELSON PURELY FROM HIS DUGOUT
CELEBRATIONS.
THAT IS TRUE.
THAT CAN BE A STAT FOR TODAY.
NELSON CRUZ MAYBE HAS NOT DONE
AS MUCH SLUGGING AS BYRON BUXTON
AND MITCH GARVER, HAS REACHED
BASE THREE TIMES, WALK AND A
PAIR OF SINGLES BUT HE HAS TO
MAKE THE LIST BECAUSE HE IS
MICROPHONED.
LATROY: I'M GOING COMPLETELY
AGAINST THE GRAIN.
HAPP.
HE PITCHED A FANTASTIC BALLGAME,
GAVE HIS TEAM AN OPPORTUNITY,
THEY SCORED RUNS.
HE IS EXACTLY WHAT THE DOCTOR
ORDERED FOR THE TWINS.
SCOTT: SPOKEN LIKE A TRUE
PITCHER.
[LAUGHTER]
JIM: NO DOUBT, FOR SURE.
SCOTT: WHAT ABOUT YOU?
JIM: I LIKE THE HITS.
BUXTON.
ANYTIME YOU GET FIVE HITS, YOU
GOT TO BE THE GUY THAT DAY.
IT HAS BEEN AN ALL-AROUND GREAT
GAME BY REALLY SEVERAL OF THEM
BUT BUXTON STANDS OUT THE MOST
FOR ME.
SCOTT: BYRON BUXTON WAS ON THE
PREGAME SHOW.
AWESOME IF HE JOINS US TWICE.
FUN TO TALK TO.
HE IS BLOSSOMING AS A PLAYER, AS
A PERSONALITY.
HE WAS QUITE SHY WHEN HE
ENTERED.
HE IS NOW A BLAST TO TALK TO AND
WATCH.
J.P.: HE IS.
I LOVE FROM OUR POSITION AT THE
BALLPARK SEEING HIS REACTION
WHEN HE ARRIVED AT SECOND WITH
THAT DOUBLE, SMILING BUT ALSO
THAT LITTLE HINT OF FRUSTRATION
SAYING I WANTED THAT TO BE A
TRIPLE.
HE WAS SMILING THE WHOLE TIME.
HAVING SO MUCH FUN ON THE FIELD.
CERTAINLY IN THE OFF-SEASON, HE
ADDED SOME GOOD WEIGHT, SOME
STRENGTH THAT WILL MAKE YOU MORE
DURABLE.
YOU ALLUDED TO IT.
THE M.V.P. DISCUSSION.
I HAVE BEEN A VOTER IN THE PAST.
I WILL ONLY SAY, MY NOTEBOOK IS
OUT.
I AM MAKING SOME END OF APRIL
THOUGHTS I MAY REFER TO IN
SEPTEMBER.
SCOTT: CLEVELAND FANS WILL ENJOY
THE FACT YOU CHOSE JOSÉ RAMIREZ
AS YOUR AL M.V.P. LAST YEAR.
YOU ARE AN OFFICIAL VOTER.
J.P.: EXACTLY.
YOU KNOW MY BALLOT WELL.
RAMIREZ, ABREU, BIEBER.
IT IS ALWAYS ROBUST.
IN SOME CASES YOU CAN VOTE A
PITCHER THAT HIGH.
RAMIREZ, I ALWAYS LOVED HIS
OFFENSE-DEFENSE COMBO.
A LITTLE BETTER THAN ABREU, EVEN
THOUGH ABREU IS AN UNDERRATED
FIRST BASEMAN.
I WAS HAPPY FOR JOSE TO WIN.
I HAVE BEEN A BIG FAN OF RAMIREZ
FOR A LONG TIME.
ONE YEAR, I BOOSTED HIM UP MY
M.V.P. BALLOT BECAUSE HE HAD
MOVED TO SECOND BASE TO CLEAR A
PATH FOR JOSH DONALDSON TO PLAY
THIRD FOR CLEVELAND.
GREAT TEAMMATE AS WELL.
SCOTT: I LIKE WHERE YOUR HEADS
AT.
JOSÉ RAMIREZ, REYES AND THIS GUY
PROVIDING MOST OF THE OFFENSE SO
FAR THIS SEASON FOR A CLEVELAND
TEAM CHECKING IN AT 11-11.
THEY HAVEWON THREE IN A ROW
WHICH WILL BE HALTED TODAY
UNLESS THEY HAVE A LOT OF LATE
LIFE IN THEIR BATS.
FULL COUNT.
HERE OUR GOOGLE PIXEL PLAYER
SPOTLIGHT, JORDAN LUPLOW,
DRAFTED 2014, ACQUIRED BY
CLEVELAND 2018 AND HE ENTERS THE
DAY THE 974 CAREER OPS AGAINST
LEFT-HANDED HITTERS.
BYRON BUXTON IS THERE.
JORDAN PLAYING AGAINST RIGHTIES
AND LEFTIES THIS YEAR.
WALKOFF HOME RUN MONDAY.
BEEN GREAT FOR CLEVELAND
TOWARD THE TOP.
10-2, TWINS AFTER 8
>> THERE IS A DRIVE, DEEP LEFT
FIELD.
THAT ONE IS GONE, UP AND OUT.
>> OFF THE SCOREBOARD.
WOW.
>> HE WILL GET AN OVATION FROM
THE FANS IN CLEVELAND FOR
HITTING THE SCOREBOARD.
UNBELIEVABLE.
>> DOUBLE WOW.
>> HOLY SMOKES.
SCOTT: HE WAS THE BIG MAN, THE
BIG MAC IN THE LATE 1990'S.
APRIL 30, WOW, WHAT A BLAST OFF
THE BAT OF MARK MCGWIRE.
JIM: SCOTTY, I COULDN'T BELIEVE
IT THAT NIGHT WHEN I SEEN IT.
IT WAS JUST AN INCREDIBLE BLAST.
TO BE THERE THAT NIGHT, YOU
OBVIOUSLY DON'T WANT A GUY DOING
IT AGAINST YOU BUT IT WAS
SOMETHING THAT OVER THE YEARS I
HAVE NEVER SEEN A BALL WENT THAT
ARE.
-- FAR.
SCOTT: HE WAS POPULAR BACK IN
THE LATE 1990'S.
THE ROAD CROWD OFTEN CHEERING
FOR MARK MCGWIRE JUST TO SEE HOW
FAR THE BASEBALL WOULD GO.
POLANCO IS THE BETTER FOR
MINNESOTA, THE CLEANUP HITTER
FOR THEM TODAY.
4, 5, 6 DUE UP IN THE TOP NINE.
THE TWINS LOOKING TO SNAP A FOUR
GAME LOSING SKIT, 2-13 IN THE
LAST 15, GOING BIG THIS
AFTERNOON.
24-YEAR-OLD LEFT-HANDER, KYLE
BELSON MAKING HIS SEASON DEBUT
TODAY.
THAT IS PULLED, LEFT SIDE.
THERE IS YOUR FIRST OUT.
ROCCO BALDELLI, A LITTLE YOUNGER
THAN TERRY FRANCONA, SO MUCH SO
THAT ROCCO PLAYED FOR TERRY AND
HIS ONE SEASON WITH BOSTON.
ROCCO BALDELLI ALREADY MANAGING
HIS THIRD YEAR WITH MINNESOTA,
STILL THE YOUNGEST MANAGER IN
MLB.
BOTH OF THEM HAVE WON MANAGER OF
THE YEAR IN THE PAST.
ROCCO BALDELLI THE YOUNGEST TO
DO IT.
HE IS YOUNGER THAN NELSON CRUZ.
LATROY: YEAH.
[LAUGHTER]
NELSON IS OLDER THAN OUR
MANAGER.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I ACTUALLY ENJOY THE FACT WE
HAVE SUCH A YOUNG MANAGER AND
YOU HAVE A PLAYER ON THE TEAM
OLDER THAN THE MANAGER.
DOES HE CONCEDE TO THE VETERAN?
OR NOT?
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: MITCH GARVER FLIES OUT TO
RIGHT.
YOU ARE SAYING IF THERE'S A
SITUATION WHERE THERE LIKE I
DON'T KNOW I CANNOT REMEMBER I
HAVE TO THINK BACK TO WHATEVER
THE 1980'S NELSON CRUZ WOULD GO
HOLD ON ROCCO, I CAN DO THIS A
LITTLE BETTER THAN YOU I HAVE
ONE YEAR ON YOU?
LATROY: ASK NELSON.
[LAUGHTER]
JIM: [LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: BRENT ROOKER WITH TWO
OUTS IN THE NINTH.
JIM, NOW WHAT FOR MINNESOTA?
HOW TO THEY BUILD OFF THIS?
THIS TEAM IS BEEN IN THE
NATIONAL CONVERSATION IN THE
PAST WEEK BASED ON THE FACT THEY
HAVE UNDERPERFORMED SO FAR THE
SEASON.
CLEVELAND WILL DROP AGAIN BELOW
IF THEY FALL TODAY BUT FOR
MINNESOTA HOW DO YOU KEEP THIS
MOMENTUM GOING ESPECIALLY WITH A
DAY OFF TOMORROW?
JIM: YEAH AFTER A DAY LIKE TODAY
YOU WOULD LIKE TO PLAY BUT
ANYTIME YOU CAN GET A DAY OFF
OVERALL IT HELPS YOUR BALLCLUB.
THE BIG THING IS JUST A
CONSISTENT WITH YOUR ROUTINE AND
LOOK, WE KNOW THE WEATHER IS
GOING TO START GETTING BETTER
HERE.
LATROY, YOU KNOW THIS.
IT IS ALL ABOUT PITCHING.
IF YOU GET GOOD STARTING
PITCHING AND YOUR BULLPEN STARTS
PITCHING WELL ALSO LIKE YOU KNOW
IT IS A LONG GRIND YOU KNOW, WE
TALK ABOUT APRIL BUT ALSO YOU
KNOW THERE IS A LOT OF SEASON
LEFT.
MORE THAN ANYTHING, FOR ME, IT
IS JUST BEING REALLY CONSISTENT
WITH YOUR ROUTINE AND PLAYING IT
OUT WITH THE GOOD VETERANS THEY
HAVE TO KEEP THE YOUNG GUYS
FOCUSED.
LATROY: STAYING CONSISTENT,
TAKING IT ONE DAY AT A TIME.
SEVEN GAMES UNDER 500 NOW?
DON'T TRY TO WIN SEVEN GAMES IN
ONE GAME.
DOESN'T WORK THAT WAY.
TAKE SOME TIME, GET GUYS OFF THE
DL, GET THEM BACK.
ND DOWN WITH BIG
WORK TO DO.
SCOTT: IF YOU WANT TO SEE MORE
EXCLUSIVE CLEVELAND CONTENT,
SUBSCRIBE TO THEIR YOUTUBE PAGE
AT YOUTUBE.COM/CLEVELANDINDIANS,
HIT UP THEIR CHANNEL AND
SUBSCRIBE.
CLEVELAND, OHIO, THE SPOT FOR
OUR THIRD YOUTUBE GAME OF THE
WEEK ARE, THEN WE ROLL INTO MAY.
EXCLUSIVELY, YOUTUBE.COM/MLB,
BRAVES AND NATIONALS NEXT ON MAY
6, MUCH MORE ON THAT IN THE
POSTGAME SHOW, 30 MINUTES
DEDICATED TO THE TWINS AND
INDIANS, COMING UP RIGHT AFTER
THIS ONE.
JAKE BAUERS IS GOING TO LEAD OFF
THE LAST OF THE NINTH FOR
CLEVELAND.
HE CAME INTO THE GAME IN THE
LAST HALF INNING AT FIRST BASE,
MOVING YU CHANG OVER TO THIRD
AND SITTING DOWN JOSÉ RAMIREZ
FOR THE REST OF THE DAY.
RANDY DOBNAK BACK TO WORK, JAKE
BAUERS SENDS IT TO CENTER AND IT
FALLS FOR A BASE HIT TO START
OFF THE BOTTOM NINE.
HITLESS TODAY, FRANMIL REYES.
ALSO PROPS TO THE YOUTUBE
CREATORS, EVERYONE HANGING OUT
WITH US IN THE LIVE CHAT THIS
AFTERNOON.
WE CAN SEE SOME OF YOUR
QUESTIONS THROUGHOUT THE DAY
THAT DID NOT GET ANSWERED.
WE WILL TRY TO ADDRESS A FEW OF
THEM IN THE POSTGAME SHOW.
I LIKE THIS ONE.
IS NELSON CRUZ GOING TO PLAY
UNTIL HE IS 45?
THE MLB YOUTUBE CHANNEL TRYING
TO PUT AN AGE RANGE ON NELSON
CRUZ, SHELFLIFE REALLY FOR HIS
CAREER BECAUSE HE HAS SHOWN NO
SIGNS OF SLOWING DOWN.
IN FACT, KIND OF FEEL LIKE
THINGS HAVE BEEN SPEEDING UP FOR
HIM IN THE PAST FOR YEARS.
KNOWS THE ZONE SO WELL.
JUST OFF THE PLATE TO FRANMIL
REYES.
WHAT DID YOU LEARN, JIM, LATER
IN YOUR CAREER YOU WISH YOU KNEW
EARLY ON?
JIM: WHEN TO SIT ON BREAKING
BALLS AND HOW TO DO IT, WHERE I
DID NOT FEEL RUSHED TO THEM.
EARLY ON, I OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW,
YOU HUNT THE FASTBALL.
THEN YOU LEARN OVER TIME, OK,
THIS GUY IS FLIPPING ME FIRST
PITCH CURVEBALLS OR IN HITTER'S
COUNTS, HE IS THROWING A
CHANGEUP -- I LEARNED HOW TO
SLOW DOWN AND GET TO THE
BREAKING STUFF BETTER THAN I DID
WHEN I WAS A LOT YOUNGER.
SCOTT: I LIKE THAT.
LATROY?
WHAT LATE LEARNING DID YOU DO?
LATROY: JUST BEING COMFORTABLE
IN UNCOMFORTABLE SITUATIONS
AND UNDERSTANDING MY BREATHING,
RELAXING.
SAYING TO MYSELF, I HAVE BEEN
HERE BEFORE.
GET OUT OF IT.
YOU END UP LEARNING WHAT YOU
NEED TO DO TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
7, 8, 10 TIMES.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL EVERY TIME.
THIS IS BASEBALL.
BUT UNDERSTANDING YOUR BODY,
WHAT YOUR STRENGTHS AND
WEAKNESSES ARE AND BEING
COMFORTABLE IN UNCOMFORTABLE
SITUATIONS.
SCOTT: FRANMIL REYES SWINGS AND
MISSES.
ONE OUT IN THE NINTH.
JIM: LATROY, WHAT WAS THAT LAST
PITCH?
LATROY: LOOK LIKE HIS
TWO-SEAMER.
HE HAS A HEAVY SINKER.
JIM: YES!
LOOKED NASTY.
CHANGEUP.
LOOK AT IT.
WOW.
LATROY: THAT WAS HIS CHANGEUP?
HE DOESN'T THROW A LOT.
CAME INTO SPRING LOOKING FOR
HORIZONTAL MOVEMENT ON THE
SLIDER AND WORKED VERY HARD AT
IT AND DEVELOPED A PRETTY GOOD
SLIDER TO GO WITH HIS TWO-SEAM
FASTBALL, HAS SOMETHING RUNNING
AWAY AND INTO RIGHTIES BUT THAT
CHANGEUP IS AN EQUALIZER RIGHT
THERE.
JIM: YEAH YEAH, NICE HUMP ON IT.
LOOKED LIKE A GOOD PITCH.
SCOTT: 26-YEAR-OLD CRAFTY RANDY
DOBNAK, HIS SINKER HAS ONE OF
THE BEST VERTICAL DROPS IN MLB.
YOU COULD BE FOOLED FOR THE
SINKER.
FOUL BALL.
GREAT STORY TOO.
FIRST PLAYER TO COME OUT OF THE
UNITED SURE PRO BASEBALL LEAGUE,
IN THE GREATER DETROIT AREA, HE
PLAYED FOR THE UTICA UNICORNS,
UN-DRAFTED OUT OF COLLEGE AS
WELL, 2017 AND LOOK AT HIM GO,
FROM INDEPENDENT BALL TO THE
MAJOR LEAGUES, NOW ON A
LONG-TERM CONTRACT WITH THE
TWINS.
LATROY: GOES WITHOUT SAYING HE
HAS PUT IN A LOT OF WORK WITH
PITCHING COACH WES JOHNSON AND
PETE MAKI TO GET TO THIS POINT.
JIM: ALWAYS GREAT TO SEE SOMEONE
WORK SO HARD AND GET REWARDED
AND ALL THE HARD WORK THEY DO
PAYS OFF OF THEM AND THEIR
FAMILY.
IT IS GREAT TO SEE.
SCOTT: DOBNAK SIGNED
THROUGH2025 WITH THE TWINS.
SOME CLUB OPTIONS THAT COULD
KEEP HIM WITH THE TEAM UNTIL
'28.
AGREED TO EXTENSION BACK IN
SPRING TRAINING.
LATROY: GREAT DEAL FOR DOBNAK
AND HIS FAMILY AND FOR THE
MINNESOTA TWINS ORGANIZATION.
SCOTT: HE HAS GOT THE SPECS, GOT
THE FOOD MANCHU, GOT IT GOING.
--  THEFU MANCHU, HE HAS GOT IT
GOING.
LATROY: SINKERBALLER LIKE DOBNAK
, YOU KNOW WHEN YOUR STUFF IS
GOOD BECAUSE YOU GOT GUYS
HITTING THE BALL ON THE GROUND.
WHEN YOU START HITTING FLY BALLS
OFF OF YOU, THAT IS AN AREA OF
CONCERN FOR A SINKERBALLER.
SCOTT: HE GETS ROSARIO TO CHASE.
STRIKEOUT NUMBER 2 FOR DOBNAK
WHO USES THAT SINKER 50% OF THE
TIME.
CHANGEUP.
ONLY GOES TO THAT 8% OF THE
TIME.
BEEN PICKING IT UP MORE AS A
WEAPON THIS AFTERNOON.
JP, HOW ABOUT RANDY DOBNAK?
ONE OF THE BEST STORIES IN THE
LEAGUE.
J.P.: FOR A LONG TIME, YOU
MENTIONED HIS ROOTS PLAYING
INDEPENDENT BASEBALL IN MY HOME
STATE, MICHIGAN, ALSO THE PATCH
ON HIS RIGHT ARM IN HONOR OF THE
LATE MIKE BELL, ONE OF THE GREAT
BASEBALL FAMILIES, CERTAINLY ALL
OF US AROUND THE GAME NOVEMBER
WELL.
THEY REMAIN IN OUR HEARTS TODAY.
-- AROUND THE GAME KNOW THEM
WELL.
SCOTT: 46-YEAR-OLD, MIKE BELL
PASSES AWAY FROM CANCER, FROM
SUCH A GREAT BASEBALL FAMILY,
HIS BROTHER, MANAGER OF THE
CINCINNATI REDS.
WE MISS HIM.
LATROY: WE LIKE TO CALL THAT
BASEBALL ROYALTY.
SCOTT: THAT IS RIGHT.
LATROY: I WAS WITH A BIG-LEAGUE
TEAM LAST YEAR AND THE
ABBREVIATED SEASON, GOT A CHANCE
TO SPEND TIME WITH MIKE.
GOT THERE JULY 2, WE LOST IN THE
PLAYOFFS.
JUST BEING AROUND HIM EVERYDAY,
TALKING ABOUT FAMILIES,
BASEBALL.
HE IS DEFINITELY GOING TO BE
MISSED.
SCOTT: BASEBALL LIFER.
HE WOULD LOVE TO SEE WHAT THE
TWINS ARE DOING TODAY.
ROCCO BALDELLI PLEASED TO SEE
HIS CLUB BACK ON TRACK.
CLEVELAND TOOK THE FIRST TWO IN
THIS SERIES.
FIRST SERIES OF THE SEASON
BETWEEN THE INDIANS AND TWINS.
THIS SHOULD DO IT.
OUT AT SECOND.
DONALDSON GOES THE SHORT WAY,
GAME OVER.
THE TWINS TOP THE INDIANS BY A
FINAL SCORE, 10-2, SIX HOME RUNS
THIS AFTERNOON, TWO FROM MITCH
GARVER, BYRON BUXTON FIVE HIT
DAY, NELSON CRUZ REACHED THREE
TIMES.
HOOKING US UP WITH AUDIO ON THE
FIELD, HELPING US OUT.
YOUR YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME
RESULTS COMING UP IN A MOMENT.
LET'S START THE POSTGAME SHOW.
WE ARE ABOUT TO CHAT WITH ONE OF
THE TWINS IN A MOMENT.
SCOTT: THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
POSTGAME SHOW PRESENTED BY
GOOGLE PIXEL, HUGS AND
HIGH-FIVES AND SMILES AND
CELEBRATIONS FROM THE TWINS
TODAY, WHO IMPROVED  TO8-15 ON
THIS YOUNG SEASON FOR THE W,
THEY WERE UP BIG FROM THE JUMP.
THREE HOME RUNS IN THE FIRST,
HALF OF THEIR TOTAL FOR THE DAY,
IN TERMS OF LONG BALLS.
10-2, FINAL SCORE.
WE ARE WITH YOU FOR 30 MINUTES.
WE WILL HAVE OUR YOUTUBE PLAYER
OF THE GAME, THE TROPHY, THE
PLAYER ON THE FIELD.
WE WILL HAVE A NICE LENGTHY
CONVERSATION IN A MOMENT.
LET'S START WITH THE BATS.
THEY CAME OUT AND BASHED.
THIS TEAM WAS KNOWN AS BOMBAS
SQUAD IN 2019 AND THEY SHOWED US
WHAT THEY WERE ALL ABOUT WHEN
THEY SET THE MAJOR LEAGUE HOME
RUN RECORD.
JIM: FOR SURE.
THAT NUMBER 1, IT STARTED, THEY
WERE AGGRESSIVE, THEY HAD THIS
MENTALITY TODAY THEY WERE GOING
TO ATTACK THE STRIKE ZONE.
IT SHOWED ALL DAY LONG.
THE WEATHER?
IT HAS BEEN GETTING A LITTLE
WARMER.
GUYS ARE GETTING COMFORTABLE.
FOR THE MINNESOTA TWINS
ALL-AROUND TODAY WAS A GREAT DAY
AND FOR THEM IT IS A GREAT
BUILDING BLOCK.
THEY HAVE AN OFF DAY TOMORROW
AND SEE WHERE THEY GO FROM HERE
BUT FOR THEM IT WAS A NICE DAY.
SCOTT: I KNOW WHAT LATROY WOULD
SAY.
DON'T SLEEP ON HAPP.
LATROY: YES.
HE WENT OUT THERE AND DID
EXACTLY WHAT WE NEEDED HIM TO DO
TO GET THIS TEAM IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
THREW THE BALL OVER THE PLATE.
HAD SOME COUNTS 2-0 BUT WAS ABLE
TO MAKE QUALITY PITCHES IN
THOSE, JUST WENT OUT THERE AND
CALMED THE TEAM DOWN WITH HIS
DEMEANOR ON THE MOUND.
SEVEN INNINGS, FOUR HITS, MADE
MISTAKES, HITTERS WILL MAKE YOU
PAY FOR THOSE BUT ALL IN ALL, HE
HAD A GREAT DAY.
HE IS MY PLAYER OF THE GAME.
BUXTON HAVE FIVE HITS.
WE NEEDED J.A. HAPP TO GO OUT
THERE AND GIVE THE TWINS THIS
MUCH-NEEDED PERFORMANCE THEY HAD
BEEN LONGING FOR.
SCOTT: HAPP'S E.R.A. UNDER 2 TO
FILL THAT CRAFTY LEFTY VETERAN
ROLE RICH HILL PROVIDED FOR THE
TWINS LAST YEAR.
THAT IS YOUR PICK.
I'M GOING WITH BYRON BUXTON.
THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME,
HOLDING THE TROPHY, JOINING US
LIVE WORLDWIDE RIGHT NOW.
[LAUGHTER]
FIRST CAREER FIVE HIT DAY.
HE JOINED US PREGAME.
YOU ARE THE MAN, BYRON.
HOW'S THE TROPHY?
FIREMAN: PRETTY HEAVY.
[LAUGHTER]
IT WAS GOOD.
WE STARTED GOOD, ATTACKED THE
ZONE.
HAPP DOES WHAT HE DOES AND THE
BATS CAME ALIVE.
WE KEPT THE LINE MOVING, PUSHED
IT TO THE NEXT GUY AND HAD FUN
TODAY.
ONE OF THOSE THINGS TO LOOK AT
AS THAT TURNAROUND SPOT.
SCOTT: WHEN FANS ARE WATCHING
AND YOUR TEAM HAVE A SIZABLE
LEAD THROUGHOUT THE AFTERNOON,
WE START TO THINK THIS IS A
PLAYER CAPABLE OF CONTRIBUTING A
TRIPLE.
OUR RETHINKING CYCLE?
DID YOU HAVE THAT ON YOUR MIND
LATER IN THE GAME?
BYRON: HONESTLY, THE ONLY AT-BAT
I THOUGHT ABOUT THE TRIPLE WAS
MY LAST ONE.
JUST ONE OF THOSE, I KNOW WHO'S
IN LEFT.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN MORE OF A
GAME FOR ME TO GO TO THIRD JUST
THEN.
JUST STAYING WITHIN MYSELF AND
MY APPROACH.
IT IS WHAT IT IS.
OVERALL IT WAS A GOOD DAY FOR
EVERYBODY.
JIM: CONGRATULATIONS ON A GREAT
DAY.
YOUR FIRST AT-BAT, YOU SHOT THE
BALL TO RIGHT FIELD FOR THE HOME
RUN.
I REMEMBER WHEN I WOULD HIT A
BALL THE OTHER WAY, IT KIND OF
SETS THE DAY TO HAVE GOOD
AT-BATS ALL DAY.
DID YOU FEEL THE SAME WAY?
BYRON: I DID.
JUST WENT UP, DIDN'T TRY TO DO
MUCH, JUST TRIED TO HAVE QUALITY
AND CONSISTENT AT-BATS.
THAT IS SOMETHING WE TALKED
ABOUT A LITTLE BIT.
TODAY IT CARRIED OVER TO WHAT WE
WANT TO DO.
WE HAD A LOT OF FUN TODAY.
DEFINITELY A TURNING POINT TO
WHERE WE WANT TO GET TO.
LATROY: HOW YOU DOING?
BYRON: I'M GOOD.
WHAT UP?
LATROY: THIS IS LATROY.
BYRON: I KNOW THAT VOICE.
LATROY: CONGRATS ON THE FIVE HIT
GAME BIG DOG.
HOW HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO RESIST
SWINGING AT THOSE 0-2 SLIDERS
EARLY IN THE COUNT LIKE YOU HAVE
IN THE PAST?
WHAT HAS BEEN YOUR THOUGHT
PROCESS AT THE PLATE?
BYRON: I'M NOT THE HITTER THAT'S
GOING TO TRY TO WALK.
EARLY, LAST AT-BAT, SECOND AT
LAST, HE GAVE ME A GOOD SLIDER I
SWUNG AT.
FIRST PITCH.
ONE OF THOSE THINGS WHERE I KIND
OF GOT A LOOK AT THE MOVEMENT,
THE TILT OF WHERE IT STARTED.
THAT IS SOMETHING I AM GETTING
BETTER AT.
TRYING TO GET RID OF THAT PITCH
AND MOVE ONTO THE NEXT ONE.
IT IS ALL PITCH TO PITCH FOR ME
RIGHT NOW AND MAKING ADJUSTMENTS
PITCH BY PITCH.
THAT SLIDER IN THE DIRT, JUST
ONE OF THOSE WHERE I KNOW IN THE
PAST IT HAS BEEN A PITCH THAT
STRUGGLED ME.
IT IS ALL ABOUT SEEING THE BALL
UP AND PUTTING A GOOD SWING ON
IT.
SCOTT: THE LINE OF THE DAY.
TERRY FRANCONA IS SUCH A FUN
PERSONALITY.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT YOU AND
YESTERDAY AS YOU CAME BACK FROM
TENDINITIS.
HE SAID THIS MORNING, IF THAT IS
TENDINITIS, I WANT IT!
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF TITO'S
REMARK AND HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
BYRON: OBVIOUSLY TITO IS A VERY
SPECIAL MANAGER.
A LOT OF RESPECT FOR HIM OVER
THERE.
BEING IN THE GAME AS LONG AS HE
IS, PAST FOR YEARS HAS NOT BEEN
THE WAY HE WANTED TO GO BUT HE
IS BATTLING AND HE IS STILL OUT
HERE.
IT IS A BLESSING TO BE ABLE TO
LOOK ACROSS THE DUGOUT AND SEE
HIM OVER THERE WATCHING THE
GAME.
FOR ME, IT IS JUST COMING OUT
HERE, LIKE I SAID, NOT DOING TOO
MUCH.
EVERYONE IS STAYING WITHIN
THEMSELVES, KNOWING WHAT THEY
CAN DO.
SCOTT: CONGRATS ON THE W AND THE
TROPHY.
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME, GOOD
LUCK.
WE WILL TALK SOON.
BYRON: YOU GOT IT.
SCOTT: HE RAN AWAY WITH THIS
THING.
WHEN YOU HAVE A FIVE HIT DAY,
LEADING THE LEAGUE IN SLUGGING
PERCENTAGE, HITTING WELL OVER
.400, YOU EARNED IT.
THE PLAYER OF THE GAME, HE'S GOT
THE TROPHY, HE'S GOT ALL THE
TOOLS, THE EXIT VELO OFF THE
BAT, THE ELITE SPEED, THE GLOVE
AMONG THE BESTTWINS, 10-2.
WE STILL HAVE SO MUCH MORE TO
COVER WITH YOU ON THE POST GAME
SHOW PRESENTED BY GOOGLE PIXEL.
SCOTT: THIS IS THE POST GAME
SHOW.
THE TWINS ALL OVER THE INDIANS
THIS AFTERNOON.
IF YOU ARE HUNGRY FOR HOME RUNS,
WE ARE ABOUT TO FEED YOU.
WATCH WHAT HAPPENED TODAY.
BYRON BUXTON'S GOING TO LEAD THE
WAY FOR MINNESOTA, TIED FOR THE
MOST HOME RUNS IN THE AL WITH
SEVEN.
HE WILL GO THE OTHER WAY.
JOSH NAYLOR FADING BACK AND IT
IS GONE.
SECOND PITCH OF THE GAME.
BYRON BUXTON MUSCLES UP.
HIS EIGHTH HOME RUNS OF THE
SEASON AND THE TWINS GRABBED THE
LEAD.
EASY POWER.
JIM: THIS GUY IS ON A ROLL.
THAT BALL ACTUALLY GOT DEEP ON
HIM.
SCOTT: THAT BRINGS US TO
DONALDSON.
LATROY: HE IS ON 100 ALL DAY
LONG.
HIS ENERGY LEVEL IS SO HIGH.
SCOTT: HE CLOCKS THAT ONE TO
DEEP LEFT.
FORGET ABOUT IT!
THE TWINS GO BACK TO BACK TO
START THE GAME.
JOSH DONALDSON RECORDS HIS
SECOND HOME RUN OF THE SEASON.
2-0 MINNESOTA.
JIM: THEY ARE NOT MESSING AROUND
HERE.
COMING OUT READY TO HIT.
THIS IS A REALLY REALLY GOOD
OFFENSE.
SCOTT: THE TWINS SECOND BASEMAN
BACK IN THE LINEUP.
JIM: TALK ABOUT ENERGY AND WHAT
HE DOES UP THE MIDDLE.
JUST A DYNAMIC PLAYER THAT CAN
GET THE TWINS THERE YOU GO.
SCOTT: HE TEES OFF AND POLANCO
MAKES IT THREE HOME RUNS IN THE
FIRST FOR THE TWINS.
A BURST OF ENERGY FROM THIS
TWINS OFFENSE.
4-0.
LATROY: TALK ABOUT PITCHERS
HAVING TO PITCH AHEAD IN THE
COUNT.
STAY OUT OF HITTER'S COUNTS.
WHEN YOU PUT YOURSELF IN THAT
SITUATION, YOU GIVE THE HITTERS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO DAMAGE,
LIKE POLANCO ON THIS FASTBALL.
J.P.: NELSON CRUZ HAS A GRAND
SLAM THIS YEAR, EARLY IN
DETROIT.
SCOTT: LOUD CONTACT TO RIGHT,
OFF THE TOP OF THE WALL.
THAT WILL SCORE A COUPLE FOR
MINNESOTA.
NELSON CRUZ CONTRIBUTING THE TWO
RUN SINGLE, 6-0, MINNESOTA.
ALMOST LEFT THE YARD, WOULD HAVE
BEEN HIS 11TH CAREER GRAND SLAM.
NELSON CRUZ POUNDED THAT
BASEBALL.
BUXTON SCORES ALONG WITH
KIRILLOFF.
THAT IS REALLY NEAT.
ROSARIO GOING THE OTHER WAY AND
IT IS GONE!
ROSARIO ON 0-2 PITCH HAS TEED
OFF AND THE INDIANS ARE ON THE
BOARD.
HIS SECOND HOME RUN OF THE
SEASON.
CLEVELAND BREAKS THE ICE.
JIM: ANOTHER BEAUTIFUL SWING
FELLOWS.
THAT PAUL MUST BE GOING -- THAT
BALL MUST BE GOING TO RIGHT
FIELD.
SCOTT: HE PULLS THAT ONE DOWN
THE LINE AND IT IS GONE!
LA TORTUGA GOES LONG!
THE FOURTH HOME RUN OF THE DAY
FOR THE TWINS AND WE ARE ONLY IN
THE THIRD.
HIS SECOND OF THE SEASON.
7-1, MINNESOTA.
JIM: BEAUTIFUL SWING SCOTTY.
BREAKING BALL HERE, STAYED RIGHT
ON IT.
AGAIN, WHAT A NICE, LEVEL
BEAUTIFUL SWING.
SCOTT: WHAT -- MITCH GARVER
BLASTS THAT BASEBALL AND IT IS
GONE!
WOW!
ON CUE!
I CANNOT WAIT TO HEAR WHAT
NELSON CRUZ SAID ON THAT ONE.
YOU CAN SEE HIM CELEBRATING
AGAIN IN THE DUGOUT.
MITCH GARVER AFTER TWO
STRIKEOUTS, THIS TIME BLASTS OFF
FOR HIS THIRD OF THE SEASON.
LATROY: BREAKING BALL DOWN AND
IN.
HE WAS ABLE TO GET THE BARREL TO
THE BALL AND HIT IT OFF TO
SPACE.
HE HAS DEFINITELY WORKED HARD AT
BEING A BETTER CATCHER, FRAMING,
HIS PRESENTATION HAS GOTTEN
BETTER.
HIS OVERALL GAME HAS GOTTEN
SCOTT: BLASTING HOME RUNS LOOKS
REALLY GOOD TODAY.
MITCH GARVER CIRCA 2019, THERE
HE GOES AGAIN, HEY TWO HOME RUN
PERFORMANCE DOUBLING HIS TOTAL
ON THE SEASON TO FOUR.
THE TWINS HAVE A DOUBLE-DIGIT
-- LATROY: HE IS VERY GOOD
AGAINST LEFT-HANDED PITCHERS.
HOPEFULLY THIS STARTS A TREND.
SCOTT: WHAT A DAY FOR THE TWINS
BATS.
RANDY DOBNAK FINISHES UP FOR US.
COUPLE INNINGS IN RELIEF.
DONALDSON GOING TO SECOND.
THAT IS A W TO SNAP A FOUR GAME
LOSING SKID.
CLEVELAND DROPS TO 11-12 ON THE
YEAR.
ROSARIO WITH A HOME RUN ON THE
CLEVELAND SIDE.
IT WAS ALL TWINS TODAY.
SIX LONG BALLS.
GETS YOU THINKING BACK TO WHAT
THEY ARE CAPABLE OF DOING AT THE
PLATE.
2019, SET THE RECORD IN THE
MAJOR LEAGUES FOR MOST HOME RUNS
IN A SEASON.
LOOK AT THE POWER THEY CAN
PROVIDE.
TODAY,, THE SHORTEST DISTANCE ON
A HOMER WAS BUXTON IN THE FIRST
AND THE LONGEST BELONGS TO JORGE
POLANCO, 426 FEET.
MITCH GARVER WITH 413 FEET.
LOOK AT THE LAST FIVE GAMES FOR
MINNESOTA.
THEY DOUBLED THEIR HOME RUN
OUTPUT FROM THE PREVIOUS FOUR IN
TODAY'S GAME ALONE AND THEY
ALMOST MATCHED THE RUN SCORING
AS WELL.
SEVEN BARRELS, ULTIMATE CONTACT
OFF THE BAT IN TERMS OF EXIT
VELOCITY AND LAUNCH ANGLE.
MINNESOTA NEEDED A DAY LIKE THIS
FAST BECAUSE THE AL CENTRAL BE
COMPETITIVE THIS YEAR WITH A
SURPRISING ROYALS BALLCLUB, THE
SUPER TALENTED WHITE SOX SQUAD
AND CLEVELAND CAN PITCH.
LATROY: THE TWINS DEFINITELY
NEEDED THIS.
THEY HAD THE RECIPE TODAY FOR
SUCCESS.
THEY HAD GREAT STARTING
PITCHING.
J.A. HAPP GAVE THEM SEVEN
INNINGS.
THE HITTERS CAME OUT.
THE OFFENSE WAS EXPLODING FROM
THE FIRST BATTER ALL THE WAY TO
THE EIGHTH, WHEN THEY SCORE
THEIR LAST RUN.
THEY CAUGHT THE BALL.
THEY HAVE NOT DONE THOSE THREE
AT THE SAME TIME THE SEASON.
WHEN YOU DO ALL THREE AT THE
SAME TIME YOU WILL HAVE GOOD
RESULTS.
SCOTT: THIS IS WHAT WE WERE
EXPECTING FROM THIS TEAM, MORE
OF THIS.
THE BULLPEN HAS BEEN A PROBLEM.
THIS WAS NOT A HIGH LEVERAGE
PROBLEM.
J.A. HAPP, NICE SIGNING IN THE
OFF-SEASON GETTING THE JOB DONE
PROVIDING CONSISTENT INNINGS OF
WORK GOING SEVEN PLUS FOR
BACK-TO-BACK STARTS.
THE POWER WE EXPECTED WAS NOT
ALL THERE BESIDES WHAT BUXTON,
NELSON CRUZ FOR THE YEAR, YOU
SEE MITCH GARVER GET INVOLVED
AND THAT IS A BIG SIGN FOR THEM.
JIM: AS LATROY SAID, HAPP COMING
OFF THE ONE HITTER REALLY
PITCHED WELL.
THE OFFENSE EXPLODED.
THEY WERE READY TO HIT FROM
PITCH 1.
THE WARM WEATHER, WE SPOKE ON
THAT.
THAT KIND OF WAS A TOPIC OF THE
DAY.
THIS IS CONTAGIOUS.
WHEN YOU CAN HAVE GOOD AT-BATS
LIKE THIS AND YOU GET GOOD
STARTING PITCHING, YOU CAN GO ON
GOOD RUNS.
WE WILL SEE MOVING FORWARD WHERE
THEY GO.
SCOTT: I AM JEALOUS OF J.P.
MOROSI AT THE PARK TODAY.
THE WEATHER HELD UP.
HE GOT TO WATCH A SHOW.
THERE WERE SOME LOUD, FAR HOME
RUN BALLS FROM THE MINNESOTA
TWINS BATS THIS AFTERNOON.
JP, WHAT DID IT LOOK LIKE IN
PERSON IN CLEVELAND, OHIO?
J.P.: FIRST OF ALL, AN HONOR TO
WORK WITH YOU THIS AFTERNOON.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
I WAS GRATEFUL TO WATCH ONE OF
THE BEST SHOWS GOING IN THE
SPORTS WORLD.
BYRON BUXTON PLAYING BASEBALL.
ONE WILD MOMENT AFTER ANOTHER
FROM THE SECOND PITCH OF THE
GAME ONWARD.
BRILLIANT, GRACEFUL DEFENDING IN
CENTER AS WELL.
THE ONLY SURPRISE WAS HE DID NOT
COMPLETE THE CYCLE.
THAT WAS THE ONE LAST THING HE
WAS TRYING TO DO TODAY.
FIVE HITS, FIRST TIME IN HIS
CAREER.
PROBABLY NOT THE LAST TIME.
HE HAS BEEN BRILLIANT SO FAR.
TREMENDOUS TO WATCH HIM PLAY
THIS SEASON.
AFTER A GAME LIKE THIS, YOU
WONDER WHAT DID WE SEE HERE
TODAY THAT IMPLIES TO THE
FUTURE?
FOR THE TWINS, IT WAS THE
QUALITY AT-BATS FOR MITCH
GARVER.
NELSON CRUZ HAS BEEN CONSISTENT
DOING EVERYTHING HE DOES YEAR
AFTER YEAR.
THAT IS NOT A SURPRISE.
BUXTON HAS BEEN A REVELATION.
I AM MAKING NOTES IN MY M.V.P.
BOOK FOR SEPTEMBER FOR THE
FUTURE.
MITCH GARVER'S AT-BATS REALLY
STOOD OUT.
HAPP STOOD OUT.
THE REST OF THE BULLPEN FOR THE
TWINS IN A COMPETITIVE WEEKEND.
THEY HAVE TO FACE THE FIRST
PLACE ROYALS BACK AT TARGET
FIELD.
TOUGH ASSIGNMENTS.
BRADY SINGER AND DANNY DUFFY,
ARGUABLY THE BEST IN THE AL THIS
SEASON.
HE IS THEIR ASSIGNMENT ON
SATURDAY.
VERY MUCH NEEDED WIN FOR THE
TWINS IN CLEVELAND.
FOR THE HOME TEAM, ONE TREND TO
WATCH I HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS, THE LACK OF
OUTFIELD PRODUCTION.
WE CAN SAY FOR THE INDIANS,
LOGAN ALLEN, ABBREVIATED START,
HARD TO WIN BUT COMBINE THE
OUTFIELD, 1-10 BY THE CLEVELAND
OUTFIELD IN THE LAST THREE
YEARS, THEY RANKED FOURTH FROM
THE BOTTOM OF THE AL IN TERMS OF
OPS FROM THOSE OUTFIELDERS.
OVERALL, THAT HAS TO GET BETTER
FOR THIS TEAM AND FOR JOSÉ
RAMIREZ AND REYES.
THEY NEED MORE SUPPORT TO
PRODUCE IN THE OUTFIELD.
FORTUNATELY, TOUGH ASSIGNMENT
THIS WEEK AGAINST THE WHITE SOX
BUT THEY HAVE SHANE BIEBER, THE
REIGNING CY YOUNG AWARD WINNER
ON THE MOUND FOR THEM IN THE
SERIES OPENER ON FRIDAY.
ONE MORE BIT OF A NEWS TO KEEP
YOU APPRISED OF, GEORGE
SPRINGER, EXPECTED TO MAKE HIS
BLUE JAYS DEBUT TONIGHT AGAINST
THE NATIONALS.
ONE INJURY AFTER THE OTHER.
THE OBLIQUE, THE QUAD INJURIES.
ALL THINGS CHECKING OUT NOW.
GEORGE SPRINGER BACK IN THE
LINEUP.
HE SAW VLAD JR. HIT THREE HOMERS
YESTERDAY.
HE WANTS SOME OF HIS OWN HERE IN
HIS OWN AND HIS BLUE JAYS DEBUT
THIS EVENING.
MORE TO COME AS WE HAVE OUR MLB
ON YOUTUBE ACTIONPOSTGAME COVERS
AFTER THIS.
SCOTT: 10 RUNS, 13 HITS, SIX
HOMERS FOR THE TWINS TO SALVAGE
A GAME IN THIS THREE-GAME SET
AGAINST ONE OF THEIR RIVALS IN
CLEVELAND.
EVEN THOUGH BYRON BUXTON WAS THE
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME AND
GETS THE TROPHY, NELSON CRUZ
STILL HAS A SPECIAL PLACE IN OUR
HEARTS BECAUSE HE HAD A
MICROPHONE AND PROVIDED SOME OF
THIS.
NELSON: I KNOW SOMETHING YOU
DON'T KNOW.
I GOT THE MICROPHONE.
I CANNOT TELL YOU.
ALL DAY!
YES, YEAH, I AM WAY OLDER THAN
YOU, YOU HAVE MORE GRAY HAIR
THAN I.
YES YOU HAVE.
IS THAT YOUR REAL AGE?
WHERE YOU FROM?
SENT HIM SENT HIM SENT HIM SENT
HIM SENT HIM!
EDDIE, I'M GOING.
TELL EVERYBODY.
THAT WAS SO AMAZING.
STOLEN BASE OF THE YEAR.
I GOT TO INFIELD HITS, ONE
TRIPLE AND THEY DON'T TRUST ME
YET?
STOLEN BASE?
LET ME FREEMEN.
POLANCO, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
I WAS ALMOST A SECOND BASE.
YEAH!
TWO R.B.I.'S?
SECOND BASE.
STAY FAIR STAY FAIR STAY FAIR
STAY FAIR STAY FAIR!
WHAT A LA TORTUGA!
HEY!
TAKE HIM OUT!
SCOTT: THEY DIDN'T KICK HIM OUT.
GOOD NEWS.
NELSON CRUZ IS SO -- IT IS LIKE
HE IS ENJOYING THE GAME EVERY
DAY AS MUCH AS ANYBODY AT THE
BALLPARK AND WANTS TO PLAY
FOREVER AND IT SEEMS LIKE HE
CAN.
TOP THREE HITTERS IN THE LINEUP
TODAY FOR THE TWINS.
BUXTON, DONALDSON, CRUZ, THREE
OF THE BEST IN MLB.
THAT IS WHY LOVE HEARING PLAYERS
WITH A MICROPHONE DURING THE
GAME.
NELSON CRUZ IS SO ENTERTAINING.
I LOVE MORE AND MORE OF THAT,
THE NATURAL, ORGANIC
CONVERSATIONS GOING ON, TALKING
TO EVERYBODY, PUTTING ON A SHOW
AND JIM, WE MIGHT HAVE TO HAVE
FREE NELSON CRUZ SHIRTS BECAUSE
APPARENTLY HE WANTS TO STEAL A
BASE AND ONCE THE GREEN LIGHT.
-- WANTS THE GREEN LIGHT.
JIM: HE DOES.
HE WANTS TO SHOW OFF HIS SPEED.
I KNOW THIS WATCHING HIM AND
LISTENING TO HIM ALL DAY, THE
ENERGY, IT REMINDS ME OF CARLOS
BAERGA, WHO I PLAYED WITH IN
CLEVELAND.
WHEN GUYS LIKE THAT BRING THE
ENERGY AND EXCITEMENT LEVEL,
VOCALLY SPEAKING, IT RUBS OFF.
THERE IS NO WONDER WHY HE IS
THEIR TEAM LEADER.
YOU CAN SEE THAT LISTENING TO
HIM TODAY.
SCOTT: 76 CAREER STOLEN BASES BY
THE WAY FOR NELSON CRUZ.
IF HE WANTS TO GET INVOLVED, HE
SHOULD GO, 76, GOOGLE IT OK?
[LAUGHTER]
LATROY: DID YOU HEAR HOW HEAVY
HE WAS BREATHING ON THE BASE
PATHS?
[LAUGHTER]
I GUARANTEE YOU HE DOES NOT
BREATHE THAT HEAVY WHEN HE IS
TAKING THOSE 1000 SWINGS IN THE
CAGE.
[LAUGHTER]
THE ONLY TEAM I CAN COMPARE HIM
TO WITH THE ENERGY HE BRINGS
EVERYDAY IS KIRBY PUCKETT.
HE BROUGHT THAT ENERGY EVERYDAY,
EVEN IN THE CLUBHOUSE.
YOU HEARD KIRBY BEFORE YOU SAW
HIM.
HE WAS JUST THAT LOUD, PUMPING
EVERYBODY UP.
PLENTY OF ENERGY.
IF YOU NEEDED A HYPE MAN, KIRBY
PUCKETT WAS IT.
SCOTT: TODAY ALSO WE RECEIVED
AUDIO FROM THE GREAT SHANE
BIEBER.
PITCHERS CAN CHAT TOO,
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY ARE NOT
PITCHING, RIGHT SHANE?
SHANE: I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
EXIT VELO IS ON THAT.
>> WHAT'S UP KID?
SHANE: YOU DON'T EXPECT THAT TO
LEAVE THE YARD.
YOU ARE GOING TO LAUGH AT THAT
IS WHAT I WAS GOING TO DO IF I
HIT ONE IN CINCINNATI.
[LAUGHTER]
WAVE IT FAIR.
DEAD CENTER, I'M WAVING IT FAIR.
ON THE OUTSKIRTS OF HONG KONG
WHERE THERE IS LIKE A FULL-TIME
PAID JOB OF A HUMAN BEING TO
SELF POLLINATE FLOWERS BECAUSE
THERE IS SUCH A SHORTAGE OF
BEES.
>> DID YOU GO TO COLLEGE FOR
THAT?
>> I DID GO TO COLLEGE.
THAT IS WHERE I LEARNED IT.
ARE YOU SAYING YOU HAVE TO HAVE
A DEGREE?
I WILL PUT IT IN MY GLOVE LIKE
THAT IF A RIGHTY IS UP.
CURVEBALL, SLIDER, HEATER.
IF I THROW CHANGEUP, I WILL
SOMEHOW GET TO IT.
I DON'T DO THAT.
IF A LEFTY IS UP, I WILL GO,
KIND OF SIMILAR.
CURVEBALL, CHANGEUP, HEATER.
SCOTT: HEY, ZACH PLESAC'S PRETTY
SMART FOR SITTING NEXT TO SHANE
BIEBER, THE CY YOUNG WINNER IN
THE AL LAST YEAR GOING TO HELP
THIS CLEVELAND TEAM STAY
COMPETITIVE IN THE AL CENTRAL
WHICH INVOLVES AT LEAST FOUR
CONTENDERS.
YOU THINK THEY ARE GOING TO PICK
THINGS BACKUP.
THE TIGERS STILL IN A BUILD
BACKUP TO CONTENTION.
SECT PLESAC SOAKING IT ALL AND
FROM LEARNING ABOUT THE
POLLINATION KNOWLEDGE TO THE
PITCH GRIPS, WHICH HE CAN APPLY
MORE TO HIS OWN CAREER.
LATROY: JUST LISTENING.
JIM: GREAT TO SEE THESE YOUNG
GUYS TALK.
JIM: IT IS GREAT TO SEE THESE
YOUNG GUYS TALKING AND LEARNING
THE GAME.
COMMUNICATING.
LATROY, YOU KNOW WHEN WE WERE ON
THE BENCH, WE DEFINITELY WATCHED
AND TALKED THE GAME.
JUST FUN TO SEE THAT.
GREAT TO SEE BIEBER, THEY
COMPETITOR ON THE MOUND, SHOW
HIS PERSONALITY TO THE FANS OUT
THERE THAT FOLLOW HIM.
KIND OF FOLLOW WHAT KIND OF A
GREAT PLAYER HE IS.
PRETTY COOL.
LATROY: I REALLY ENJOY THE
AMOUNT OF USELESS INFO ABOUT
POLLINATION.
THAT WAS AWESOME FOR ME.
[LAUGHTER]
WHEN YOU HAVE A GUY LIKE BIEBER
ON YOUR TEAM AND HE IS DOING
SOMETHING RIGHT, IF HE IS
WILLING TO SHARE THAT KNOWLEDGE
WITH THE GUYS AROUND HIM, I
MEAN, IT IS LIKE A TEACHER.
WHEN A TEACHER IS TEACHING THE
PUPILS SHOULD BE PAYING
ATTENTION.
PLEASE ACT WAS DEFINITELY --
ZACH PLESAC WAS DEFINITELY
PAYING ATTENTION.
SCOTT: IF YOU ARE A BEEKEEPER,
WE ALSO HELPED YOU OUT TODAY ON
YOUTUBE.
WE WILL BE BACK ALL MAY LONG
WITH A GAME OF THE WEEK.
THAT IS THE BRAVES AND THE
NATIONALS NEXT WEEK, 4:00
EASTERN FOR THE FIRST PITCH.
TWO TEAMS IN A VERY COMPETITIVE
DIVISION IN THE NL EAST AND
THREE MORE TO GO IN MAY.
MANY MORE THE REST OF THE
SEASON.
THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE PRESENTED BY GOOGLE
PIXEL.
THAT IS A WRAP HERE FROM ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY, AS YOU CAN
SEE.
GREAT JOB BY LATROY AND JIM
THOME, THE GREAT J.P. MOROSI,
OUR ENTIRE SUPERSTAR CREW.
THE TWINS WIN BIG, SIX HOMERS,
10 HOME RUNS.
SEE YOU NEXT WEEK ON YOUTUBE.
LOGGING OUT FOR NOW.